ओके आई थिंक आई एम लाइव नाउ आई एम फाइनली
लाइव आई थिंक कैन यू हियर माय वॉइस गाइस
आवाज आ रही है आप सभी को बताइए जल्दी से
फटाफट बता दीजिए
तब तक मैं बाकी लोगों को नोटिफाई कर देता
हूं यहां से
सही है आवाज बिल्कुल क्लियर जा रही है
सबको
कोई प्रॉब्लम ऑडियो में कोई प्रॉब्लम तो
नहीं आ रही है?
जल्दी बता दो जल्दी जल्दी फटाफट मैं भी
इधर भी मैं ओपन कर लेता हूं एक बार।
लेट्स ओपन इट।
हां,
ठीक है। सभी लोग आ रहे हैं अभी। ओनली अभी
68 पीपल हैव जॉइंड। वेट करते हैं और लोगों
को ज्वाइन होने देते हैं।
कुछ लोग और कुछ और लोगों को ज्वाइन करने
देते हैं क्योंकि आज की जो सेशन है वो
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग होने वाली है। काफी मजा
आएगा आप लोगों को। थोड़ा थोड़ा सेशन लंबा
हो सकता है। बहुत ज्यादा लंबा तो नहीं
होगा बट अ बिट ऑफ
लॉन्ग।
ओके।
देयर आर 94 पीपल आर हियर। आज अटेंडेंस कम
है। देखो देखो ये गलत बात है। अटेंडेंस कम
कर दी आप लोगों ने। यही यही गलत चीज है।
अगर आप लोग आओगे नहीं लाइव में तो फिर
मेरा भी मन नहीं लगेगा। एंड मैं भी
फ्रीक्वेंसी वीडियो की कम कर दूंगा। राइट?
चलिए देखते हैं। लेट्स सी।
लेट मी सेंड। ओके। ओके। चलिए। सो फाइनली
वी आर हियर। 103 पीपल आर 100 प्लस पीपल आर
हियर नाउ। वाचिंग करेंटली। आ मुझे लगता है
कि और भी आने चाहिए। 135 पीपल आर हियर।
ग्रेट। अच्छी बात है।
ओके। सो गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग टू
एवरीबॉडी। वेरी वेरी गुड इवनिंग। आप सबके
लिए आज का जो सेशन है वो काफी इंटरेस्टिंग
होने वाला है। एंड धीरे-धीरे जैसे-जैसे हम
आगे बढ़ रहे हैं वो सेशंस आपके लिए और भी
ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग होने वाले हैं। ठीक
है? एंड मैं आपको ये सेशंस अटेंड करने के
लिए अ इसलिए नहीं बोलता क्योंकि ये एक
रैंडम YouTube सेशन है या रैंडम कोर्स है
बेसिकली जो आपको अ जो आपको प्रोवाइड करी
जा रही है किसी के द्वारा। दिस इज़ वन ऑफ़ द
वन ऑफ़ द बेस्ट अ जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग जो
आपको यहां पे मिल रही है हमारे तरफ से एंड
एसओसी एल वन के लिए। तो इसकी थोड़ी आपको
जो है अ मतलब थोड़ी सी इसकी कदर करनी
पड़ेगी आपको एंड आपको आना पड़ेगा क्योंकि
मैं आपके लिए कर रहा हूं तो प्लीज आप
आइएगा तो इट विल बी मच बेटर।
सो फर्स्ट जो क्लास हुई थी संडे की पिछली
बार तो 300 से भी ज्यादा लोग थे। उसके बाद
नेक्स्ट सेशंस में 200 250 लोग थे। अभी
देखो अभी 200 भी नहीं पहुंच पा रहे हैं।
सो इमेजिन करो आप खुद सोचो। संडे का टाइम
है। स्टिल पीपल कुछ भी नहीं होता। संडे को
ऑलमोस्ट छुट्टियां होती हैं। लोग नहीं जॉइ
करते हैं। जिनको एक्चुअली इंटरेस्ट है।
इसका रीज़न सबसे बड़ा यह होता है। एक बहुत
बड़ा रीज़न है वो है कि फ्री की चीजें मिल
जाना। फ्री में जब चीजें मिलती हैं तो
पीपल स्टार्ट टेकिंग दैट फॉर ग्रांटेड।
एंड ऐसा अगर चलता रहा आप में से लोग कई
लोग हैं जो देखना चाहते हैं। कई लोग हैं
जो टेकन फॉर ग्रांटेड लेते हैं। अगर बाद
में वीडियो की फ्रीक्वेंसी कम होने लगी तो
प्लीज डोंट ब्लेम मी। एंड आल्सो अगर आपको
यह वीडियोस बाद में अगर जैसे मुझे लगता है
आपकी तरफ से इंटरेस्ट नहीं आ रहा। फ्री की
चीजों की वैल्यू नहीं हो रही आपको जो कि
क्वालिटी मिल रही है। तो हो सकता है हम
इसको मेंबर ओनली कर दें और हम इसका चार्ज
करने लगे YouTube पे ही। मतलब वीडियोस
आपकी हाइड हो जाएगी सारी। मेंबर ओनली हो
जाएगी। तो जो मेंबर्स होंगे जो पे करेंगे
सिर्फ वही देख पाएंगे। दैट्स इट। तो वो
मजबूरी में करना पड़ेगा। आई डोंट वांट दैट
पर्टिकुलर थिंग। बट आई वांट यू टू अटेंड
यू टू शेयर यू टू इंगेज हियर। राइट? बस
इतना ही।
करेक्ट। करेक्ट। वही चीज हो जाती है। अगर
मैं कंसिस्टेंस
कंसिस्टेंसी दिखा रहा हूं। कंसिस्टेंट हूं
तो मैं एक्सपेक्ट करता हूं कि आप भी
रहेंगे। दैट्स इट। मुझे इससे ज्यादा और
कुछ आपसे नहीं कहना है। चलिए बिफोर वी
स्टार्ट सबसे पहले जो सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट काम
मैं आपको हमेशा बोलता हूं कि आप चैनल पे
लाइव सेक्शन में जब आप आएंगे हमारे
डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी वाले चैनल पे लाइव
सेक्शन पे जब आएंगे तो यहां पे किसी भी
एसओसी की क्लास जब आप उठाएंगे कोई सी भी
एसओसी की क्लास आप ले लीजिए जैसे एसओसी वन
टू या कोई सी भी क्लास इस इस क्लास के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में चले जाइएगा एंड यहां पे
आपको WhatsApp ग्रुप का लिंक मिल जाएगा
एसओसी की प्लीज आप इसको ज्वाइन जरूर कर
लीजिएगा एंड इसी
डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको WhatsApp चैनल का
लिंक मिल जाएगा। आप हमारे WhatsApp चैनल
को भी फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। दोनों ही फ्री ऑफ
कॉस्ट है। कोई पैसा नहीं लग रहा आपका। ना
ही ग्रुप में कोई पैसा लग रहा है जॉइ करने
में। एंड वहां पे आपको सारी अपडेट्स, सारी
चीजें सबसे पहले मिल जाती है। तो, यह
जरूरी है जब आप सर्टिफिकेशंस के लिए हमसे
क्वेरी करेंगे। जब हम सर्टिफिकेशंस के लिए
अनाउंस करेंगे इसी ट्रेनिंग के एंड के
बाद। जैसा कि मैंने आप सबको बताया था। आप
में से अगर सबको पता ही होगा मेरे ख्याल
से कि जब ये ट्रेनिंग खत्म हो जाएगी, वी
आर लाइव नाउ।
कंप्लीटली जॉब ओरिएंटेड हो जाएंगे। आप
कंप्लीटली जॉब ओरिएंटेड स्किल्स गेन कर
चुके होंगे। तो हम सर्टिफिकेशन भी आपको
प्रोवाइड करेंगे। एंड आप चाहे तो वो
सर्टिफिकेशन ले सकते हैं। अदरवाइज छोड़
सकते हैं। वो आपकी मर्जी होगी। टोटली आपके
ऊपर होगी। हमारी तरफ से कुछ ऐसा नहीं
होगा। बट उसकी जो भी अनाउंसमेंट्स हैं,
नोटिफिकेशंस हैं या जो भी व्हाटएवर वो
आपको इन्हीं ग्रुप्स एंड चैनल पे मिलेगा।
तो यह जरूर से जरूर कर लीजिएगा। साथ ही
में यहां पे Lindin पे आप डिफ़्रॉनिक सर्च
कीजिएगा। तो हमारे डिफ़्रॉनिक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी का Lindin पेज आ जाएगा। इसको
आप जरूर फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। यहां हमारे
कंपनी से रिलेटेड जो भी चीजें हैं,
अपडेट्स हैं, वो सब आपको मिलती रहेंगी
यहां पे। एंड दिस इज माय प्रोफाइल ऑफ
Lindin
जो आप यहां पे मुझे फॉलो अप कर सकते हैं
यहां पे आके एंड मुझसे कनेक्ट हो सकते
हैं। ये हमारा डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी
Instagram पेज है डिफ़्रोॉनिक्स का जहां पे
जो इंफॉर्मेशनेशन रील्स एंड कंटेंट्स है
वो आपको मिल जाते हैं। ये हमारी वेबसाइट
है जहां पे ये हमारा हेल्पलाइन नंबर है।
बेसिकली यहां पे आप हमसे कांटेक्ट करके
किसी भी तरह की क्वेरी कर सकते हैं। ये
हमारा एक्स का पेज है। Twitter पेज
डेफोनिक्स एकडमी हैंडल के साथ। दैट्स इट।
चलिए अब ये सारी चीजें हो गई। अब हम
स्टार्ट करते हैं आज की सेशन जो कि काफी
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट होने वाला है। एंड आपको
बिलीव नहीं होगा कि जो मैं चीजें आपके लिए
यहां पे लेकर आ रहा हूं इन सेशंस के थ्रू
वो कोई भी आपको प्रोवाइड नहीं करने वाला
है। पहली बात तो यह है। नोबडी इस गोइंग टू
प्रोवाइड यू अ लाइक दिस जो आपको यहां पे
अभी मिल रही है। इस तरीके से तो आपको
बिल्कुल भी
प्रोवाइड नहीं किया जाएगा। इस बात की मैं
आपको गारंटी देता हूं। ओके।
जस्ट अ सेकंड।
यस।
इस बात की मैं आपको गारंटी देता हूं। अब
यहां पे इस पर्टिकुलर अ आज के सेशन में हम
उन टॉपिक्स को कवर करने वाले हैं। हम उन
चीजों को करने वाले हैं जो हमारी फाउंडेशन
रखती है। बिफोर गोइंग टू द लैब पार्ट।
बिफोर गोइंग टू द अह लैब लैब हम खुद का
प्रिपेयर करें। करें एसओसी के लिए
प्रैक्टिकल्स उस पे परफॉर्मेंस करें। ये
सब चीजों के पहले सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट है
एसओसी के लिए आपका कंसेप्ट एंड थ्यरी।
बिना कांसेप्ट एंड थ्योरी के आप एसओसी एल
एल वन के लिए इंटरव्यू क्रैक नहीं कर
पाएंगे। मैं आपको गारंटी के साथ बोलता हूं
आप एल वन इंटरव्यू नहीं क्रैक कर पाएंगे।
अब देखो ये एक नॉर्मल ट्रेनिंग तो है नहीं
कि मैं आपको बस प्रैक्टिकल प्रैक्टिकल।
अभी मैंने देखा चैट में कुछ लोग बोल रहे
थे हां जा हां हां लाइक का बटन प्रेस कर
दो। लाइक का बटन हिट कर दो। अभी कुछ टाइम
पहले जब स्टार्टिंग में मैंने देखा कुछ
लोग चैट में बोल रहे थे आई होप कि आज
प्रैक्टिकल सेशन होगा। अब मुझे आप बताइए
आप में से सभी लोगों से मैं पूछ रहा हूं
कि आप क्या चाहते हैं कि मैं अपने
अकॉर्डिंग कर रहा हूं एक इंटरव्यू लेवल तक
की प्रिपरेशन कराऊं जिससे कि आप एल1 की
जॉब सिक्योर कर पाएं या आपको ऑलरेडी सब
कुछ आता है। बस आप थोड़े बहुत
प्रैक्टिकल्स देखने आए हैं कि आप सिर्फ
प्रैक्टिकल्स चाहते हैं। मुझे आप आपसे
आंसर चाहिए। आई जस्ट वांट एवरीबॉडी टू
आंसर सो दैट मुझे पता चले कि एग्जैक्टली
आप लोगों का क्या सोचना है। आपको
प्रैक्टिकल्स डेमोंस्ट्रेशनंस ओनली चाहिए
या आपको कॉनंसेप्ट थ्योरी प्लस प्रैक्टिकल
प्लस आपका इंटरव्यू प्रिपरेशन सब कुछ
चाहिए अकॉर्डिंग टू मी जैसा मैं चाहूंगा
वैसा आप मुझे बता दीजिए एक बार ताकि मुझे
एग्जैक्टली आईडिया चल जाए। राइट? मैं अपने
अकॉर्डिंग जाऊं या आप ये मतलब
प्रैक्टिकल्स के लिए जाऊं बस आप बता दो।
थ्योरी और प्रैक्टिकल आपके अकॉर्डिंग जाओ
सर। अकॉर्डिंग टू यू अकॉर्डिंग
टू यू इंटरव्यू लेवल। ठीक है?
ठीक है। अगर आप ऐसा बोल रहे हैं कि मैं
अपने अकॉर्डिंग जाऊं अपने अकॉर्डिंग कराऊं
तो मेरी एक रिक्वेस्ट है कि मैं जैसे करा
रहा हूं ना आंख बंद करके उसको करते जाइए।
बस आप ट्रस्ट कीजिए मेरे के मेरे ऊपर। आप
मेरे ऊपर भरोसा रखिए। मेरे ऊपर भरोसा रखते
हुए ट्रस्ट करते हुए जैसा मैं बता रहा हूं
करते जाइए। आपका बस दो काम है मेजर। एक
पहला काम क्या है कि आप वीडियोस को जो
लाइव सेशन है उसको अटेंड करेंगे। मोस्टली
कोशिश करेंगे अटेंड करने का। एंड दूसरी
चीज़ वीडियो जब लाइव एंड हो जाए तो वीडियो
को दोबारा देखेंगे। कमेंट्स में आके
लिखेंगे वीडियो कंप्लीटेड अपना नाम और की
पॉइंट्स बना के Lindin पे डाल के हमें टैग
करेंगे। ये दो काम बस आपसे चाहिए और कुछ
नहीं। वीडियोस को शेयर तो आप कर ही रहे
हैं। मुझे पता है कई लोग शेयर कर रहे हैं।
मैंने देखा कई जगह पे वीडियोस शेयर किए जा
रहे हैं। मैंने देखा कई ऐसे यूज़र्स हैं आप
में से कई ऐसे लर्नर्स हैं जो हमारे
वीडियोस को बड़े-बड़े Telegram ग्रुप्स
में, चैनल्स में, WhatsApp ग्रुप्स में,
Lindin पे, Facebook पे, Instagram
स्टोरीज पे शेयर कर रहे हैं। एंड आई एम
वेरी ग्रेटफुल फॉर दैट। आई एम रियली
ग्रेटफुल फॉर दैट। मतलब मुझे काफी अच्छा
लगा देख के कि अगर मैं कुछ बोल रहा हूं तो
आप उसको एटलीस्ट सुन रहे हैं एंड वो चीजें
कर रहे हैं। तो इससे मुझे मोटिवेशन भी
मिलती है और हमें लगता है कि हां भाई वी
हैव टू गो ऑन वी हैव टू डू बेटर ऐसा करके।
अब
अब यहां पे चलते हैं। स्टार्ट करते हैं
हमारी आज की मॉड्यूल को। हां याद रखिएगा
ये हमारा डे थ्री है। दिस ट्रेनिंग दिस
मॉड्यूल इज़ हमारा जो आज का सेशन है वो डे
थ्री है। अगर आप आप में से कोई ऐसा है जो
नया आया हुआ है तो मैं आपको बताना चाहता
हूं जस्ट फॉर योर इंफॉर्मेशनेशन कि हमारी
एसओसी की कंप्लीट लाइव फ्री जॉब रेडी
ट्रेनिंग चल रही है। इसकी अनाउंसमेंट
वीडियो यहां पे ऑलरेडी मैंने डाली हुई थी।
इसमें सारी डिटेल्स आपको मिल जाएंगी। लाइव
सेक्शन में आप आएंगे। तो यहां पे क्लास वन
क्लास टू देख सकते हैं। एंड दिस इज क्लास
थ्री दैट इज ऑनगोइंग करेंटली राइट नाउ।
राइट? अब आज की जो क्लास है वो इतनी
इंपॉर्टेंट है क्योंकि क्योंकि देखो अभी
आपको जो टॉपिक्स हैं जो चीजें मैं
समझाऊंगा वो आपको समझनी पड़ेगी। अब देखो
अगर मान लो इंटरव्यू में जाते हो इंटरव्यू
देने जाते हो तो वहां पे इंटरव्यू में कोई
अगर क्वेश्चन करता है इंटरव्यूअर आपसे
किसी तरह का कॉनसेप्चुअल क्वेश्चन कर देता
है। मान लो लेट्स सपोज कोई एक सिनेरियो
बेस्ड क्वेश्चन कर देता है तो आप उससे
क्या बोलोगे? अरे अरे नहीं नहीं मुझे लैब
करवाओ मुझसे प्रैक्टिकल करवाओ मैं कर
दूंगा यह सब कुछ नहीं पता तो इंटरव्यूअर
क्या करेगा बोलेगा भाई साहब मुझे भी आपका
नहीं पता आप भी आप भी चलिए निकलिए अब बहुत
कैंडिडेट है हमारे पास बहुत लाइन लाइन लगी
पड़ी है तो यही तो आपको बनना है ना
यस राइट एसोसिएट इज़ वेरी इंपॉर्टेंट यहीं
तो आपको बनना है ना बस बात खत्म और क्या
मैं कह रहा हूं और कुछ भी नहीं कह रहा हूं
सिंपल तो आज का जो अ टाइटल है आपने देखा
ही होगा सिस्टम अटैक वेक्टर्स एंड
वनेबिलिटीज इसको हम बहुत डिटेल में देखने
वाले हैं, जानने वाले हैं। देयर आर
मल्टीपल थिंग्स टुडे वी आर गोइंग टू कवर।
बहुत कुछ होने वाला है। तो अपना पेपर,
पेन, नोट्स का बंडल जो भी है वो सब उठा के
बैठ के प्रिपेयर रहिए।
सर, आई एम ऑलरेडी वर्किंग एज अ एसोसिएशन
एनालिस्ट एल1 बट मुझे आपकी वीडियो से बहुत
कुछ सीखने मिलेगा जो जॉब में हेल्पफुल
होगा। दैट्स ग्रेट शिवांग त्रिपाठी। अ आई
एम रियली हैप्पी कि जो प्रोफेशनल्स हैं जो
ऑलरेडी जॉब में हैं एल वन कैटेगरी में हैं
एसओसी एल वन एनालिस्ट हैं वो भी इस वीडियो
को इस क्लासेस को देख रहे हैं। आप सोचो
कितना कितनी बड़ी बात है कि जो जॉब में है
वो भी देख रहा है। बट जो लोग फ्रेशर है ना
वो लोग नहीं आ पा रहे हैं यहां पे अटेंड
करने। जस्ट इमेजिन द सिचुएशन क्योंकि फ्री
में अवेलेबल है। रिकॉर्डिंग अवेलेबल है।
अब मान लो मैं कल की रिक कल को
रिकॉर्डिंग्स आपको जो ये YouTube पे मिल
रही है। कल को वो गायब हो जाए। मान लो
लेट्स सपोज कि मैं उसको प्राइवेट कर दूं
प्राइवेट नहीं करूं मेंबर ओनली कर दूं फिर
आप कैसे करोगे उसको हाउ यू विल डू फिर तो
लाइव में ही करना पड़ेगा ना तो इस चीज को
आप थोड़ा इस सिंस इस इस सिंसियरनेस को
समझिए आप कि आपको जब फ्री में कोई इतना
कुछ दे रहा है डिलीवर कर रहा है आपने आपको
नहीं पता बहुत सारे यूटर्स ऐसा करते हैं
जब उनकी कोई सीरीज बहुत पॉपुलर हो जाती है
जैसे हमारी बग बंटी की सीरीज काफी पॉपुलर
है काफी पॉपुलर है अभी भी डेली लोग आते
हैं देखते हैं और उसको बाद में वो लोग
मेंबर ओनली कर देते हैं और उसका चार्ज
करते हैं एंड दे डिर्व दैट उन्होंने फ्री
में जब कराया इतना टाइम दिया 6-छ महीना
साल साल भर फिर भी अगर आप नहीं देख पा रहे
हैं आप लाइव में नहीं जा पा रहे हैं तो ये
आपकी गलती है उसकी उस पर्टिकुलर लोगों की
उनकी तो गलती नहीं है ना
राइट
क्या बात है हिंदुस्तानी सिंगर थैंक्स
बहुत अच्छी बात है प्रशांत
चलिए सो लेट्स स्टार्ट अब देखो एसओसी के
ऑपरेटिंग मॉडल्स के बारे में पहले हम
जानेंगे ये बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है मैं आपको
हर एक चीज जो इंपॉर्टेंट है वो सब चीजें
यहां पे बता रहा हूं। याद रखिएगा हर चीज।
सबसे पहले एसओसी के हम ऑपरेटिंग मॉड जो
मॉडल्स हैं उसके बारे में जानेंगे कि
व्हाट आर द ऑपरेटिंग मॉडल्स? मैं यहां पे
इसका कलर चेंज करने का है ना? हां
हम रेड ही है क्या? और कुछ नहीं है क्या?
ब्लैक है। ब्लैक
ब्लैक तो ब्लैक ही हो जाएगा।
येलो वाली कर लेते हैं।
एसओसी ऑपरेटिंग मॉडल्स। अब एसओसी की
ऑपरेटिंग मॉडल्स जो है तीन तरह के मॉडल्स
होते हैं। एक आपका इन हाउस होता है।
इंटरनल एसओसी मॉडल। ठीक है? दूसरा आपका
आउटसोर्स मैनेज्ड या आउटसोर्स या मैनेज्ड
एसओसी होता है और तीसरा जो आता है आपका वो
हाइब्रिड एसओसी होता है। इन तीनों को हम
समझते हैं पहले। उसके बाद फिर हम आगे
प्रोसीड करेंगे। पहला होता है हमारा इनह
हाउस इंटरनल या इंटरनल एसओसी मॉडल। यह
क्या होता है? एक कंपनी बिल्ड्स एंड रन
इट्स ओन एसओसी इंटरनली यूजिंग इट्स पीपल
टूल्स एंड प्रोसेससेस। इसमें अपनी टीम
होती है एसओसी की एंड पूरा एक टीम बना
होता है और वो टीम ऑपरेट कर रहा होता है।
पूरी एसओसी के ऑपरेशंस को हैंडल कर रहा
होता है। अब ये चीजें क्यों इंपॉर्टेंट
है? अब मान लो तुम जा रहे हो किसी कंपनी
में इंटरव्यू के लिए। तुमने एसओसी की पूरी
कांसेप्ट समझ सब कुछ अब तुम्हें यही नहीं
पता कि एसओसी का टीम स्ट्रक्चर क्या होता
है। एसओसी किस तरीके से ऑपरेट करते हैं?
एसओसी पूरी ऑपरेशन सेंटर एक टीम एज अ कैसे
ऑपरेट करती है ये तुम्हें नहीं पता। वो
बोलेगा कि भाई तुम्हें सब पता चल गया और
तुम्हें ये नहीं पता टीम कैसे ऑपरेट करती
है। तो ये चीजें जाननी जरूरी है। दैट्स
व्हाई दीज़ आर वेरीेंट। थैंक यू ऑफ कोर्ड।
इट्स इट्स फाइन। कोई बात नहीं। चलिए अभी
देखिए अब एसओसी की टीम स्ट्रक्चर कुछ इस
तरीके से काम करती है। पहले सिक्योरिटी
एनालिस्ट्स होते हैं। दूसरे इंसिडेंट
रिसोंडर्स होते हैं। फिर थ्रेट हंटर्स
होते हैं। एसओसी मैनेजर्स होते हैं।
सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर्स होते हैं। ये इस
तरीके से ऑपरेट करते हैं। अब सिक्योरिटी
एनालिस्ट में क्या इनका काम होता है?
मॉनिटर ट्रैक करना। इंसिडेंट एनालिसिस
करना, कोलैबोरेशन करना। इंसिडेंट
रिसोंडर्स का काम क्या होता है? इंसिडेंट
को मैनेज करना, मिटिगेशन करना, रिपोर्ट
करना। थ्रेट हंटर्स का क्या काम होता है?
एडवांस थ्रेट डिटेक्ट करना, वनेबिलिटी
असेसमेंट करना एंड ऑप्टिमाइजेशन
रिकमेंडेशंस करना। जो भी ऑप्टिमाइज करने
का रिकमेंडेशन है वो करना। एसओसी मैनेजर
फिर क्या करता है? स्ट्रेटेजिक प्लानिंग।
वो प्लानिंग करेगा क्योंकि वो मैनेजर है।
थोड़ा सा अ बिनेस लेवल की ये रोल हो गई।
मतलब अ इसको हम टेक्निकल रोल में ज्यादा
नहीं लेकर आएंगे फिलहाल के लिए। टीम
मैनेजमेंट करना एंड इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस
कोऑर्डिनेशन करना, कोऑर्डिनेट वगैरह करना
ये सब चीजें करना। एंड लास्ट में आता है
सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर जो टूल्स के लिए होते
हैं। सिक्योरिटी टूल मैनेजमेंट जो आपके
एसआईएम टूल हो गए या कोई भी टूल्स जो आप
यूज कर रहे हैं अपने एसओसी के लिए उन
टूल्स को उनके उन टूल्स का मैनेजमेंट
सिक्योरिटी कंट्रोल्स इंप्लीमेंट मतलब
सिक्योरिटी कंट्रोल्स रूल्स ये सब
इंप्लीमेंट करना कोलैबोरेट करना आईटी
टीम्स के साथ जो भी फर्दर आईटी टीम्स हैं
उनके साथ कोलैबोरेट करना ये पूरा का पूरा
चलता है इन हाउस इंटरनल एसओसी मॉडल के
अंदर में। ठीक है? दूसरा आता है
वो है आपका आउटसोर्स या मैनेज्ड एसओसी
जिसको हम एमएसपी या एमएसएसपी एसओसी भी
बोलते हैं। अब एमएसपी और एमएसएसपी क्या
होता है? देखो एमएसपी होता है मैनेज्ड
सर्विस प्रोवाइडर्स एंड एमएस एम डबल होता
है मैनेज्ड सिक्योरिटी सर्विस प्रोवाइडर।
दोनों में बस यही अंतर है। ये एक सिंपल
सर्विस प्रोवाइडर है मैनेज्ड और ये एक
सिक्योरिटी सर्विस प्रोवाइडर है। अब दोनों
में डिफरेंसेस क्या है? यहां पे आपको
लेफ्ट साइड में की डिफरेंसेस दिख रहे
होंगे कि जब एमएसपी होती है वो नॉर्मल
आईटी ऑपरेशंस को देखती है। बट एमएसएसपी जो
होती है वो आईटी सिक्योरिटी ऑपरेशंस को
देखती है। जो एमएसपी होती है वो नेटवर्क
या सिस्टम हेल्थ मॉनिटरिंग करती है। बट
एमएसएसपी जो होती है वो सिक्योरिटी
मॉनिटरिंग या डिफेंस का काम करती है। आपकी
एमएसपी मैनेजमेंट का काम करती है जिसमें
कि नेटवर्क सिस्टम्स आर मैनेज्ड, अपडेटेड
एंड मेंटेन ऐसा होता है। एंड ये भी मैनेज
करती है। बट इसमें क्या होता है?
सिक्योरिटी सिस्टम्स आर मॉनिटर्ड
कॉन्सेंटली टू बी सिक्योर एज पॉसिबल। यह
उसका काम करती है। अब इसमें आता है एमएसपी
में नेटवर्क के अंदर में प्रोएक्टिवली
मैनेज एंड मेंटेन इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर एंड
सॉलशंस। बट इसमें क्या होता है?
प्रोएक्टिवली मॉनिटर्स एंड डिफेंड अगेंस्ट
साइबर अटैक्स। मतलब इसका मतलब है कि जो
एमएसपी है वो जनरिक रोल में आती है। ठीक
है? जैसे मॉनिटर करना, सब कुछ सही से काम
कर रहा है नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर उसको
देखना, आईटी ऑपरेशंस जो है उसको मैनेज
करना या आपकी सर्विज एंड ऑपरेशंस है उसको
मैनेज करना। बट वही एमएसएसपी जो होती हैं
जो कि होती है मैनेज्ड सिक्योरिटी सर्विस
प्रोवाइडर। ये एक थर्ड पार्टी प्रोवाइडर्स
होते हैं। मेरी कंपनी छोटी है। मैं एक
छोटा कंपनी हूं। ठीक है? पीपीटी
ओके ग्रेट। पीपीटी ऑफ़ द सेकंड डे। ऑफकोर्ड
आप ग्रुप में नहीं है क्या? अगर आप ग्रुप
में होंगे तो आपको पता होगा कि ऑलरेडी
पीपीटी जो है सेकंड डे की शेयर कर चुकी जा
चुकी है। मतलब ग्रुप में ही WhatsApp
ग्रुप में किया जा चुका है। ठीक है? एंड
प्लीज डोंट स्पैम एवरीवन प्लीज।
अब जैसे मान लो मेरी कंपनी छोटी है। मैं
एक छोटा मतलब एक मिड लेवल की मिड साइज
कंपनी हूं। तो मैं एसओसी का पूरा टीम तो
अपने पास नहीं कर एक अपनी टीम सेटअप नहीं
कर सकता ना। बहुत खर्चा आएगा। बहुत सारी
प्रॉब्लम्स हैं। तो मैं क्या करूंगा? एमएस
एम डबलs मैनेज सिक्योरिटी सर्विस
प्रोवाइडर भी ले सकता हूं और एमएसपी दोनों
ले सकता हूं या तो सिर्फ एम डबलs भी ले
सकता हूं। एंड फिर ये मेरे लिए क्या होगा
कि एक अलग से डैशबोर्ड टूल टाइप का
डैशबोर्ड मिल जाएगा। कनेक्टिविटी मिल
जाएगी उनके उनसे हमारा नेटवर्क कनेक्ट हो
जाएगा और हमारी जो भी अलर्ट ट्राई और जो
भी चीजें एसओसी की काम है वो इनके द्वारा
किया जाएगा। तो हमारे लिए खर्चा थोड़ा कम
आएगा। तो ये मिडल साइज कंपनीज़ के लिए होते
हैं हमारे सेकंड जो ऑपरेटिंग मॉडल है
आउटसोर्स या मैनेज्ड एसओसी। तीसरा हमारा
एंड लास्ट जो आता है वो आता है हाइब्रिड
एसओसी। अब ये हाइब्रिड एसओसी क्या होता
है? इसको कोमैनेज्ड एसओसी भी कहा जाता है।
और शेयरर्ड रिस्पांसिबिलिटी मॉडल बिटवीन
इंटरनल एसओसी एंड एक्सटर्नल एम डबल एसपी।
ये हाइब्रिड होता है। सिंपल सा इंटरनल लोग
भी काम कर रहे हैं। मतलब एंड आउटसोर्स जो
आपने किया है अलग से जो सर्विस आप यूज़ कर
रहे हो एसओसी के लिए उसका भी यूज़ होता है।
अब ऐसा क्यों होता है? अब जैसे कोई ऐसी
कंपनी है जिनको पूरा एसओसी का पूरा टीम
सेटअप नहीं कर सकते। वो कंप्लीट टीम सेटअप
करना पॉसिबल नहीं है। उनके बस की बात नहीं
है। तो क्या करते हैं कि कुछ टीम मेंबर्स
को सेटअप कर लिया। जैसे एसओसी का L1, L2,
L3 उनको वहां पे हायर कर लिया। उनको वहां
पे बैठा दिया और बाकी जो काम है जो जो भी
बाकी के काम है वो सब एमएसएसपी से ले रहे
हैं। एमएसएसपी से करवा रहे हैं। जैसे आप
डायग्राम में यहां पे क्लियर आप इस
डायग्राम में देख सकते हो यहां पे। यू कैन
सी द डायग्राम। यहां पे आप देखो यहां पे
ये टिए वन का एक एंप्लई टिए टू का एंप्लई
टिए थ्री का एंप्लई ये क्या करेंगे?
मॉनिटर एनालाइज डिसाइड रिसोंड एस्केलेट
रिपोर्ट ये करते हैं। उसके बाद एसआईएम टूल
जो जो कहां पे ये एसआईएम टूल किसका है ये?
ये एमएसएसपी का है जो मैनेज सर्विस
प्रोवाइडर है और बाकी का काम ये कर देते
हैं जैसे रॉ आपके लॉग्स से आपके जो भी
नेटवर्क डिवाइसेस हैं वहां से लॉग्स निकल
के आता है वो इस एमएसएसपी सर्विस
प्रोवाइडर जो है उनके पास मान लो प्रेजेंट
रहता है ऐसा करके या तो ऐसा कर सकते हैं
कि आप ये एसआईएम टूल तो यूज़ कर रहे हैं।
यू आर यूजिंग द एसआईएम टूल। आपके पास
एसआईएम के टूल है। बट आपने टियर वन, L1,
L2, L3 की जो सर्विस है वह एमएसएसपी के
थ्रू ले लिया है। या तो आप एसआईएम टूल को
एमएसएसपी के थ्रू ले रहे हैं और तीन लोगों
को आपने सेटअप करके रखा है अपने कंपनी के
अंदर में। ये भी चीजें हो सकती है। तो
दोनों चीजें जो है बाय डायरेक्शनल पॉसिबल
है कि आपने एक टीम सेटअप किया और
सॉफ्टवेयर्स के लिए आप किसी और पे डिपेंड
हो गए। मतलब उस पे काम करने के लिए। या तो
आपने सॉफ्टवेयर सेटअप कर लिया और टीम के
लिए आप किसी और पे डिपेंड हो गए। तो इस
तरीके से ये दोनों जो है क्रॉस
प्लेटफॉर्म्स की तरह काम करते हैं। एक
दूसरे से इंटरेक्ट करके काम करते हैं। एंड
दिस इज व्हाट कॉल्ड द एसओसी का हाइब्रिड
मॉडल। अब इसमें एक पूछ रहे हैं कोई
हां सर रिपीट प्रीवियस पॉइंट। ठीक है। मैं
अभी बता देता हूं।
हां। एमएसएसपी कोई भी एक ऑर्गेनाइजेशन कोई
भी एक एक सर्विस प्रोवाइडर हो सकती है।
कोई भी आप भी अपना एमएसएसपी का सर्विस
सर्विस एज अ सर्विस दे सकते हैं। ठीक है
ना? तो आप आप अपना सर्विस शुरू कर सकते
हैं। आप छोटी कंपनीज़ को जैसे कंपनीज़ को
क्या हुआ? मेरी अगर मान लो एमएसएसपी की
सर्विस मैं प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं। तो मैं
मिड लेवल की कंपनीज़ को अप्रोच करूंगा। मैं
उनको बोलूंगा कि आपके कंपनी में एसओसी की
पूरी टीम तो आप नहीं सेटअप कर सकते
क्योंकि उतना बजट नहीं होगा। तो आप हमारी
एमएसएसपी की सर्विस यूज़ कीजिए। हम आपको
सारी चीजें प्रोवाइड करेंगे। दैट्स इट। हम
आपसे एक मंथली या इयरली रेंटल लेंगे और
आपका सारा काम हो जाएगा। जो भी आपकी एसओसी
की जो भी सिक्योरिटी की काम है वो सब हम
हैंडल कर लेंगे। तो इस तरीके से होती है।
तो इसमें सिंपल तीनों चीज मैंने बताई। एक
तो इंटरनल एसओसी इन हाउस है। कुछ एक बंदे
ने पूछा कि सर तीनों में से अच्छा कौन है?
अच्छा कोई सा भी नहीं है यार। ये डिपेंड
करता है किस टाइप की कंपनी है। कंपनी बड़ी
है तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है वो इंटरनल इन
हाउस एसओसी टीम रखेगी ताकि किसी भी तरह का
इंटीग्रिटी इशू ना आए। किसी भी तरह का
कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी इशू ना आए। अपनी टीम
होगी अपने तरीके से काम करेगी। किसी तरह
का ब्रीच होने का कुछ भी होने का डर या
खतरा नहीं रहेगा। राइट? उसके बाद ये हमारा
आउटसोर्स है मिड लेवल कंपनीज़ के लिए। कहीं
और से हाय कहीं और से मतलब रेंट पे हमने
ले लिया आउटसोर्स कर लिया और काम कर रहे
हैं। और ये है दोनों का कंबाइंड हाइब्रिड
कि मतलब ऐसी कंपनीज़ जो चाहती है कि कुछ
हमारे एंप्लाइजज़ भी काम करें और टूल कहीं
और से या तो टूल हमारा हो। ऐसा भी होता है
कि टूल हमारा हो। टूल हम अपना यूज़ कर
लेंगे। बट जो एंप्लाइजज़ हैं जो टियर वन,
टियर टू, टियर थ्री, L1, L2, L3 है वो हम
कहीं और से उनका काम हम एमएसएसपी के थ्रू
ही करवा लें। दैट्स इट। आई थिंक ये क्लियर
हो गया होगा। हां थर्ड पार्टी में रिस्क
ज्यादा होता है। बिल्कुल। थर्ड पार्टी का
आप यूज़ कर रहे हैं तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है
कि आप अपने नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को
एक्सपोज कर रहे हैं थर्ड पार्टी को। थर्ड
पार्टी को इंटीग्रेट कर रहे हैं उसमें। तो
वहां पे रिस्क थोड़ा ज्यादा होगा ही होगा।
तो इट्स ऑलवेज बेटर कि आप पहला एसओसी
इंटरनल इन हाउस टीम ही रखें। ज्यादा बेटर
है एज अ कंपनी। बट कंपनी हर कंपनी बड़ी
नहीं होती है कि इतना बजट होगा तो
एमएसएसपी के लिए जाया जा सकता है। कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। ठीक है? एवरीवन
अंडरस्टुड? प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस। आप सबको
यहां तक समझ में आया?
अभी इन क्लासेस के बाद अभी जब आज के सेशन
में ही एक लैब का हम क्वेश्चन भी सॉल्व
करेंगे। जब मैं आपको सारी चीजें बता दूंगा
तो हम साथ में सॉल्व करेंगे। देखते हैं कि
आप में से कितने लोग जो हैं वह सही आंसर
कर पाएंगे। वह हम देखेंगे। सो लेट्स वी
विल सी दैट गॉट इट एवरीवन सभी लोग आंसर
नहीं कर रहे हैं। लाइक सब ने ठोक दिया
वैसे तो
ओके चलिए अब आते हैं यहां पे मेन हमारा जो
पॉइंट है सिस्टम एज अटैक वेक्टर्स वो
पॉइंट मैंने देखो हमारा टॉपिक था सिस्टम
एज अटैक वेक्टर्स बट मैंने पहले आपको ये
चीजें बताई इसका भी बहुत बड़ा रीज़न मैं
कोई भी चीज बता रहा हूं उसका बहुत बड़ा
रीज़न है जब मैं आपको ये ट्रेनिंग डिलीवर
कर रहा हूं एंड
एंड मुझे बहुत दुख होगा अगर आप ऐसी
ट्रेनिंग को भी नहीं कर रहे हैं लाइव आके
लिटरली मुझे बहुत दुख होगा एंड इट विल बी
वेरी हर्ट हार्टफुल क्योंकि अगर आप बहाने
मार रहे हैं कि अरे सर मैं कोई काम से
बिजी था मैं 7:00 बजे ये सब बहाने हैं। आप
दिन भर कल से लेके आज दिन भर फ्री थे। सब
कुछ छुट्टियां होती हैं। आपको जो काम करने
होते हैं वो 7:00 बजे से पहले कर सकते
हैं। और आपका 2 घंटा ही तो मांग रहे हो
मैक्सिमम वो भी हो सकता है 1ढ़ घंटे में
खत्म हो जाए। अगर आप वो भी नहीं निकाल पा
रहे हैं अपने उस स्किल को एनहांस करने के
लिए आप स्किल करने के लिए तो आई डोंट थिंक
कि आप बहुत ज्यादा सिंसियर हैं उस चीज के
लिए। बाकी जितने लोग सिंसियर हैं वो आते
हैं एंड मुझे लगता है कि वो हमेशा आएंगे।
आई होप सो।
[हंसी]
ठीक है? चलिए अब आते हैं सिस्टम एज अटैक
वेक्टर्स। सिस्टम एज अटैक वेक्टर्स। अब ये
क्या होता है? पहले उसको हम समझते हैं। इफ
यू अंडरस्टैंड सिस्टम्स एज अटैक वेक्टर्स,
यू स्टॉप बीइंग अ बिगिनर एंड स्टार्ट
थिंकिंग लाइक एन एनालिस्ट। अगर आप सिस्टम
एज अटैक वेक्टर्स को समझ लिया आपने तो आप
एक तरफ से एक तरह से बिगिनर से अपर लेवल
पर जा चुके हैं। एंड अब जो है आप एक
एनालिस्ट की तरह ज्यादा सोचेंगे अगर आपने
इस चीज को समझ लिया। इट्स सोेंट
इन एसओसी वी डोंट जस्ट प्रोटेक्ट यूज़र्स
और डेटा। हमें सिर्फ यूज़र्स और डेटा को
प्रोटेक्ट नहीं करना होता एसओसी में। वी
प्रोटेक्ट सिस्टम्स। हम सिस्टम्स को भी
प्रोटेक्ट करते हैं। बिकॉज़ एव्री सिस्टम
कैन बी अब्यूज्ड एज एन अटैक वेक्टर।
क्योंकि हर सिस्टम को अब्यूज किया जा सकता
है। यह एक बहुत बड़ी चीज है। हर सिस्टम को
अब्यूज किया अब्यूज किया जा सकता है। अब अ
सिस्टम बिकम्स एन अटैक वेक्टर व्हेन एन
अटैकर यूज़ेस इट टू। कब एक सिस्टम अटैक
वेक्टर बन जाता है? जब एक अटैकर उस सिस्टम
का यूज़ किस लिए करता है? इनिशियल एक्सेस
गेन के लिए। लैटरल मूवमेंट के लिए। लैटरल
मूवमेंट मतलब एक नेटवर्क डिवाइस से दूसरे
नेटवर्क डिवाइस में चले जाना। मतलब जब
नेटवर्क सेगमेंटेशन नहीं होती ना प्रॉपर
इसको हम बोलते हैं नेटवर्क सेगमेंटेशन का
लैक होना। नेटवर्क सेगमेंटेशन का मतलब है
कि अगर किसी इन नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर
में किसी कंपनी में मान लो नेटवर्क
सेगमेंट सेगमेंटेशन नहीं है प्रॉपर। इसका
मतलब है
कि एक ही नेटवर्क से मल्टीपल डिवाइसेस
कनेक्टेड हैं। तो अगर एक डिवाइस के
फर्मवेयर को एक डिवाइस के सॉफ्टवेयर को
मलिशियसली एक्सप्लइट कर लिया गया या उसके
अंदर एंट्री कर ली गई प्रिविलेज एस्केलेट
कर लिया गया तो उसके थ्रू दूसरे डिवाइसेस
तक अटैकर पहुंच जाते हैं। सोलर विंड्स
अटैक आपने सुना होगा। यह उसी का एक
एग्जांपल है जहां पे एक मैलवेयर एक डिवाइस
में घुसती है और उसके थ्रू जितने सिस्टम्स
हैं सब में ट्रैवल कर जाती है एंड इसका
पता भी जल्दी नहीं लग पाता है। इसका जल्दी
पता भी नहीं लगता है। हालांकि उस पे हम
बाद में आएंगे।
कोई बात नहीं एसके गेमिंग आई होप कि आप
रेगुलर रहेंगे। फिर मेंटेन पर्सिस्टेंस।
पर्सिस्टेंस मेंटेन करने के लिए उस सिस्टम
का यूज़ करते हैं कि सिस्टम रिबूूट करो।
सिस्टम को जब भी रिस्टार्ट भी करो तभी वो
कनेक्शन बनी रहती है। एक्सफिल्ट्रेट डेटा
डेटा को चुराने के लिए किया जाता है। एंड
लॉन्च फर्दर अटैक्स दूसरे और अटैक्स को
लॉन्च करने के लिए किया जाता है। ये अगर
इन चीजों का यूज़ हो रहा है। ठीक है?
सिस्टम्स का यूज़ करके सिस्टम का यूज़ इन
चीजों को करने के लिए किया जा रहा है तो
वो सिस्टम एक अटैक वेक्टर कहलाएगा। दैट्स
इट। तो हमें सिर्फ यूजर एंड डेटा ही नहीं
बचानी। हमें सिस्टम्स को भी बचाना है। एज
एन एसओसी। एसओसी का बहुत बड़ा रोल है। अ
वेरी वेरीरी बिग रोल। आप इमेजिन नहीं कर
सकते कि एसओसी क्या-क्या चीजें करता है।
अभी तो आगे चीजें आएंगी तो आपका दिमाग और
खराब होगा। अभी लगेगा कि यार ये क्या है।
मैं आपको गारंटी देता हूं जो लोग
स्टार्टिंग से देख रहे हैं ना वीडियोस और
जो लोग रेगुलर देख रहे हैं लाइव में आके
उनको आगे चलके भी बहुत इजी लगेगा। लेकिन
जो जिन्होंने बीच में स्किप मारा जो छोड़
दे रहे हैं फिर बाद में आके देख रहे हैं
उनको कुछ नहीं समझ में आएगा। और वो भूल
जाओ जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग। एंड मैं आपको
गारंटी देता हूं। आई एम गिविंग यू अ
गारंटी। मैं आज ही बता देता हूं कि जब ये
ट्रेनिंग कंप्लीट हो जाएगी, जब ये
ट्रेनिंग खत्म हो जाएगी तो ये सारी
वीडियोस मेंबर ओनली हो जाएंगी। एंड वहां
पे बाकी जो नए व्यूअर्स आएंगे जो अभी लाइव
में नहीं आ पाते, कभी बाद में आएंगे उनको
पता चलेगा। उनको वो पे करके देखना पड़ेगा।
वो अलग बात है कि वो 400 ₹500 ही होंगे
पेमेंट के। बट स्टिल उनको पे करके देखना
पड़ेगा। बट अभी ये कोई ऐसी लाइव ओनली मतलब
मेंबर ओनली नहीं होगी। अभी आप लोगों के
लिए फ्री ही रहेगी। तो आप लोग लाइव में ही
आइए। इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट। मैं आपको बार-बार
बोल रहा हूं। तो इस बात को समझिए। इस बात
के सिंसियरनेस को समझिए। ठीक है? दैट्स
इट।
चलिए यहां पे आपने देख लिया होगा। अब यहां
पे आते हैं नेक्स्ट पे। सिस्टम एज अटैक
वेक्टर्स को आप समझ गए होंगे कि अगर कोई
सिस्टम इन चीजों के लिए यूज़ किया जा रहा
है तो वो एक अटैक वेक्टर कहलाएगा।
अब आते हैं ह्यूमन ओरिएंटेड अटैक्स। अब
इसमें अलग-अलग अटैक्स होते हैं। ह्यूमन
ओरिएंटेड अटैक्स होते हैं। सप्लाई चेन
अटैक्स होते हैं। फिर वनेबिलिटीज की बात
आती है। देन सॉफ्टवेयर वबिलिटी अलग-अलग
चीजें होती हैं। तो सिस्टम एज अटैक
वेक्टर्स में सबसे पहले हम ह्यूमन
ओरिएंटेड अटैक्स को देखेंगे कि ह्यूमन
ओरिएंटेड अटैक्स क्या होते हैं? देखो
यूज़र्स आर दोज़ हु स्टार्ट अटैक मोस्टली।
बिफोर एक्सटर्नल फैक्टर्स यूज़र्स आर
रिस्पांसिबल फॉर दैट। सिंपल सा फंडा है।
पता है किसी भी सिस्टम के ऊपर, किसी भी
नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के ऊपर सबसे पहला
अटैक कौन करता है? पता है आपको? सबसे पहला
अटैक उसके खुद के यूज़र्स करते हैं। अब ये
सोचोगे तो आपका दिमाग हिलेगा। उसके जो खुद
का यूजर होता है ना, जो यूजर उस नेटवर्क
को यूज़ कर रहा है, जो यूजर डेली वो
कंप्यूटर को यूज़ कर रहा है, दो वो नेटवर्क
डिवाइसेस को यूज़ कर रहा है, राउटर को यूज़
कर रहा है, फायरवल को कॉन्फ़िगर कर रहा है,
वही अटैक करता है। सबसे पहला। अब सोच के
अजीब लगेगा कि अरे सर ऐसा कैसे हो सकता
है? है ना? ऐसा कैसे होगा? हाउ दिस इज़
पॉसिबल? दिस इज़ पॉसिबल। बिकॉज़ एज अ
एंप्लई, एज अ वर्कर, एज अ यूजर, आप क्या
करते हो? आप क्या करते हो? कोई भी USB
किसी भी कंप्यूटर में घुसा देते हो। क्या
करते हो? किसी भी तरह का सॉफ्टवेयर
पायलेटेड जगह से डाउनलोड करके एग्जीक्यूट
कर देते हो। क्या करते हो? बार-बार वीक
पासवर्ड को यूज़ करते हो। ये सब चीजें आप
ही तो करते हो। और कौन करता है? एज अ
एंप्लई मतलब एज अ एंप्लई समझना भाई। एज अ
एंप्लई समझना।
एज अ एंप्लई हां इंसाइडर थ्रेट राइट इट्स
करेक्ट हां इंसाइडर थ्रेट होती है। अब एक
चीज जान के हैरानी होगी कि 81% ऑफ ब्रीचेस
इनवॉल्व स्टोलेन और ब्रीज्ड पासवर्ड्स
मतलब 80 पर 81% जो डेटा ब्रीचेस होते हैं
वो पता है उसमें क्या होता है? स्टोलेन या
ब्रीच्ड पासवर्ड्स होते हैं। बताओ 81%
बहुत बड़ा नंबर है भाई ये कोई 10 20% की
बात नहीं है। कितना ह्यूज है ये पूरा का
पूरा सिस्टम। किस तरीके की चीजें होती
हैं। अब क्या है? इसका एग्जांपल क्या है?
अब रबर डकी। अब आपने जो USB लगाया वो रबर
डकी निकला। क्या कर रहा है? ऑटोमेटेड
टास्क कर रहा है। रबर डकी एक ऐसी डिवाइस
होती है USB डिवाइस। बेसिकली आप भी बना
सकते हैं। इजी टू मेक होता है। उसके उसके
अंदर एक डकी स्क्रिप्ट्स चलती हैं। तो
ऑटोमेट करती है चीजों को। जैसे ही कोई
पेनड्राइव लगाएगा अ जो भी स्टर्ड पासवर्ड
है उसके अंदर आ जाएगी और डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट
जो भी फंक्शनैलिटीज होंगी वो सब वो
परफॉर्म करता है एंड सामने यूजर को जल्दी
पता नहीं चलता है तो अगर कोई एंप्लई है
उसने लगा दिया अब क्या हुआ सारे डेटाबेस
पासवर्ड्स जो भी स्ट पासवर्ड ब्राउज़र
पासवर्ड सब निकल के आ गए खत्म कहानी खत्म
है ना
अब देखो
या की लॉगर्स बाइंडेड विद लेजिटमेट
सॉफ्टवेयर
अब भैया ने क्या किया कि एक पाइरेटेड
सोर्स से सॉफ्टवेयर डाउनलोड कर लिया। ये
सोच के कि हम तो फ्री में यूज़ करेंगे।
क्रैक वर्जन है। डन टना अब उसमें एक की
लॉगर बाइंडेड था। एक फ्रोजन बाइंडेड था।
हो गई फिर लग गई फिर लंका। बात हो गई
खत्म। क्लिकिंग ऑन सस्िशियस लिंक्स।
लिंक्स पे तो ऐसे क्लिक करते हैं जैसे कुछ
है ही नहीं। हमें कोई अननोन लिंक भेज
देगा। हम हम ये करते हैं। देख देखते हैं
कि क्लिक करके देखते तो हैं क्या है। अरे
आईपी गैबिंग का भी लिंक हो सकता है। अदर
देयर आर मल्टीपल डेटा लीकेज थ्रू लिंक्स
वो हो सकती है। किसी भी तरह का एक्सप्लइट
डाउनलोड हो सकता है। बहुत सारी चीजें हो
सकती है। तो ये करते हैं। ओपनिंग एनी ईमेल
और सेंड अटैचमेंट्स। ईमेल में अटैचमेंट
आता है। पीडीएफ डॉक्यूमेंट कुछ भी क्लिक
या फट से ओपन कर दिया। अरे भाई ऐसा थोड़ी
ना है। ये मजाक चल रहा है यार। आप इतने
बड़े नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को हैंडल कर
रहे हो। आप ऐसे काम नहीं कर सकते। आप एज अ
यूजर यूजर कौन होता है? एसोसिए एनालिस्ट
भी यूजर ही है। याद रखिएगा। एसोसिए
एनालिस्ट भी यूजर ही है। आप सोचो जस्ट
इमेजिन
एक ऐसा केस कि एक एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट एल1 है
और उसने किसी
किसी भी एक अटैचमेंट को जस्ट सिंपली ओपन
कर लिया डाउनलोड करके और उससे पूरा
नेटवर्क इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर जो है वो
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो जाता है। तो जस्ट इमेजिन
ये किस तरह का किस तरह की चीज है यार।
अजीब नहीं लग रहा कि एसओसी एनालिस्ट होके
और तुम खुद ही अपनी नेटवर्क की बैंड बजा
रहे हो। काहे की एनालिस्ट? तो यह चीज़
जानकारी होनी चाहिए आपको। बस इतना ही मुझे
पता है। आपको ये चीजें जानकारी होनी
चाहिए।
बिल्कुल।
एसओसी में स्टडी करने के लिए किस तरह की
तैयारी करनी होगी? बस वीडियोस देखो। जो
मैं बोलूं वो करो। यही तैयारी है। कुछ और
तैयारी तुम्हें नहीं करनी है। वीडियोस
देखो और जो मैं बोलूं उसको एकदम ऑनेस्टली
डेडिकेशन के साथ फॉलो करते जाओ। आंखें बंद
कर लो और फॉलो करो। बीच-बीच में आंखें खोल
देना। नहीं तो फिर दिखेगी नहीं आपको।
स्टोरिंग पासवर्ड्स एट अनसिक्योर
पोर्टल्स। अब कहीं भी पासवर्ड स्टोर करने
लगे जहां ईजीली कोई और एक्सेस कर सकता है
या पोर्टल ज्यादा सिक्योर नहीं है। यह काम
भी नहीं करना है। ट्रस्टिंग सून। ट्रस्ट
बहुत जल्दी बना लेना। भैया ट्रस्ट नहीं
करना। यू डोंट हैव टू ट्रस्ट।
यू डोंट हैव टू ट्रस्ट एनीबॉडी। पता है
ना? एक टर्म है जीरो ट्रस्ट। अभी साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में जीरो ट्रस्ट सिक्योरिटी जो
बोलते हैं या जीरो ट्रस्ट उसका बहुत
ज्यादा चलन है। अभी जीरो ट्रस्ट ट्रस्ट को
इंप्लीमेंट किया जा रहा है। मतलब कि एक
कोई पर्टिकुलर यूजर एक नेटवर्क में जब
घुसता है तो पहले क्या होता था? अगर वो एक
बार ऑथेंटिकेट कर लेता है तो वो क्या है
कि अब वो किसी भी डिवाइस को एक्सेस मतलब
नेटवर्क में घुस गया तो वो पूरी नेटवर्क
उसकी है। एक बार ऑथेंटिकेट हो गया तो अब
ऐसा नहीं होता। अब आपको बार-बार ऑथेंटिकेट
करना पड़ेगा। अदरवाइज जब दूसरे डिवाइस के
पास जाओगे तो वो बोलेगा ना आई डोंट ट्रस्ट
यू कि यू आर ऑथेंटिकेटेड है। ये बोलेगा
अरे मैं तो ऑथेंटिक अरे मैं नहीं जानता
यार। हट चलो निकलो भागो। ये होती है बात।
तो ट्रस्ट नहीं करना। यूजिंग आउटडेटेड या
पायरेटेड सॉफ्टवेयर वही है। कहीं भी गए
सॉफ्टवेयर फ्री में मिल रहा है भाई उठा के
डाल लो। अब एसआईएम की कोई टूल है फ्री में
क्रैक्ड मिल गई उठा के डाल लिया। पता चले
कि एसआईएम टूल खुद ही मैलवेयर इनफेक्टेड
है। जिसका यूज़ करके तुम मैलवेयर्स और
सिक्योरिटी को देखोगे वो खुद ही इनफेक्टेड
है मैलवेयर से। क्या फायदा भाई आपके एसओ
सीएल वन होने का? ये भी तो सीखना है ना।
राइट? समझ में आ गया? चलिए
अब आते हैं सप्लाई चेन अटैक्स।
अब आते हैं सप्लाई चेन अटैक। यह जो
टॉपिक्स मैं आपको बता रहा हूं गाइस सप्लाई
चेन या जो भी यह जो अभी टॉपिक सप्लाई चेन
बता रहा हूं ह्यूमर ओरिएंटेड है ये सबका
कनेक्शन है आने वाली क्लासेस से। याद
रखिएगा अगर आप ये सोच रहे हैं कि मैं बस
ऐसे ही बता रहा हूं ये ऐसे ही कि हां भाई
कुछ थ्योरी टॉपिक बता दे रहा हूं तो ये
आपकी बहुत बड़ी गलतफहमी है। ऑल दिस
टॉपिक्स विल बी लिंक्ड फर्दर। जब हम आगे
क्लास के आगे की तरफ बढ़ेंगे और थोड़ा
एडवांस की तरफ बढ़ेंगे तो सब आपको समझ में
आ जाएगा कि हां ये सब लिंक्ड है। तो याद
रखिएगा।
चलो। योर पीसी इज सॉरी।
योर पीसी इज होम टू 100्स ऑफ एप्स
इंक्लूडिंग वेब ब्राउज़र्स, मैसेंजर्स,
डेवलपमेंट एंड एंटरटेनमेंट सॉफ्टवेयर्स।
एव्री ऐप डिपेंड्स ऑन थाउजेंड्स ऑफ़
लाइब्रेरीज़। अब आपके पीसी में बहुत सारे
एप्स होते हैं, सॉफ्टवेयर्स होते हैं, सब
होते हैं। अब उन सब वो जो ऐप सॉफ्टवेयर्स
हैं ना वो बहुत से लाइब्रेरीज पे डिपेंड
करते हैं। इफ थ्रेट एक्टर्स मैनेज टू
ब्रीच वन ऑफ़ द ऐप और लाइब्रेरीज एंड पुश
एन अपडेट टू ऑल इट्स यूजर ऑल ऑफ देम विल
बी कॉम्प्रोमाइज। अगर किसी अटैकर ने एक
लाइब्रेरी को कुछ लाइब्रेरीज को या कुछ एक
ऐप को कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लिया। मान लो। एंड
उसके बाद उसमें उसने एक मलिशियस अपडेट पुश
कर दिया। तो जितने भी बाकी के यूज़र्स हैं
जितने भी बाकी के यूज़र्स जो उसको यूज़ कर
रहे हैं उन सॉफ्टवेयर्स को, उन एप्स को वो
सब इनफेक्ट हो जाएंगे। दिस टेक्न टेक्निक
इज़ आल्सो कॉल्ड अ सप्लाई चेन अटैक। इसी को
हम सप्लाई चेन अटैक बोलते हैं। दीज़ आर द
वेरीेंट टॉपिक्स ऑफ टॉप सर्टिफिकेशंस इन
साइबर सिक्योरिटीज़। जितने भी टॉप
सर्टिफिकेशन साइबर सिक्योरिटी के हैं
एथिकल हैकिंग के उन सब में ये सारे सप्लाई
चेन अटैक्स और ये सब चीजें जो हैं आपकी
पूछी जाती हैं। तो थोड़ा ध्यान दीजिएगा
अभी। द मोस्ट फेमस एग्जांपल्स आर सोलार
विंड्स एंड 3CX ब्रिचेस व्हिच अफेक्टेड
थाउजेंड्स ऑफ कंपनीज़। इनमें ऐसे ही हुआ था
सोलार विंड्स एंड 3CX के केसेस में जब यह
ब्रिज मतलब 3CX ब्रिज जो हुआ था और सोलार
विंड्स जो जिसके थ्रू थाउजेंड्स ऑफ
कंप्यूटरटर्स जो है वो इनफेक्ट हुए थे
उसमें यही हुआ था कि एक लाइब्रेरी के थ्रू
एक लाइब्रेरी को कॉम्प्रोमाइज करके उसमें
एक अपडेट डाला गया था एंड जब वो अपडेट
दूसरे सिस्टम्स पे इंस्टॉल हुई अपडेट
सिस्टम अपडेट्स के थ्रू तो ऑटोमेटिकली वो
सिस्टम्स जो है वो इनफेक्ट हो गए ये आपको
याद होगा राइट आपने सोलर विंड्स से का
सुना होगा न्यूज़ कि उसने जितने भी टॉप के
कंपनीज़ हैं सबको अफेक्ट किया था। मैं आपको
दिखा भी देना चाहता हूं।
मैं आपको यहां पे दिखाता हूं। आप देखो
सोलार
विंड्स
अफेक्टेड
कंपनी। नहीं सोलर विंड्स अफेक्टेड कंपनीज़
में जब आप आओगे ये देखो यहां पे लिखा
रहेगा यहां पे 48 का आपको यहां पे मिल भी
जाएगा कि सोलर विंड्स साइबर अटैक जो कि
क्या है एक एक ऐसा सोलर एक ऐसा अटैक जो कि
सप्लाई चेन अटैक है। आपको यहां पे कहीं ना
कहीं अ सप्लाई चेन का नाम भी मिल जाएगा
लिखा हुआ। ये देखिए। द सोलार विंड्स
असॉल्ट वाज़ अ टिपिकल सप्लाई चेन अटैक। इन
दीज़ काइंड ऑफ़ हैक्स द अटैकर्स डोंट गो
आफ्टर देयर विक्टिम्स नेटवर्क डायरेक्टली।
इंस्टेड दे पेनिट्रेट द सिस्टम ऑफ अ थर्ड
पार्टी सप्लायर विद द एक्सेस टू देयर
टारगेट्स नेटवर्क एसेट्स। इन दिस केस द
थर्ड पार्टी सप्लायर वाज़ सोलर विंड्स। तो
अटैकर ने सोलर विंड के ही पूरी एक
लाइब्रेरी को अफेक्ट किया। एंड जितने भी
सोलर विंड्स के कस्टमर्स थे वो सब इसके
विक्टिम बने गए थे। अब मैं यहां पे अगर
आपको ये दिखाऊं तो आप देखो यहां पे
गवर्नमेंट एजेंसीज में डिपार्टमेंट ऑफ
होमलैंड सिक्योरिटी डिपार्टमेंट ऑफ ऑफ
स्टेट ट्रेजरी डिपार्टमेंट डिपार्टमेंट ऑफ
कॉमर्स नेशनल नेशनल न्यूक्लियर सिक्योरिटी
एडमिनिस्ट्रेशन एंड ये सारी चीजें
टेक्नोलॉजी की मैं बात करूं तो Intel
sisco fireआई बेलकिन वीएमवेयर ये सब अगर
मैं अदर ऑर्गेनाशंस की बात करूं तो
डेलवाइट कॉक्स कम्युनिकेशन कैलिफोर्निया
डिपार्टमेंट ऑफ़ स्टेट हॉस्पिटल कट स्टेट
यूनिवर्सिटी ये सब एप्रोक्सिममेटली 18,000
यूज़र्स जो है ना इन्होंने इस मलेशियस
अपडेट को इंस्टॉल किया था। एंड हैकर्स ने
उसके बाद बैकडोर क्रिएट किया था उनके
नेटवर्क के अंदर में। तो कोई भी ऐसी मेजर
कंपनी नहीं थी जो कि इस अटैक से बचा हुआ
हो। ऐसा कोई भी मेजर कंपनी नहीं था। सोचो
व्हाट काइंड ऑफ़ डेंजरस अटैक इट माइट बी
सप्लाई चेन अटैक। द मोस्ट फेमस एग्जांपल्स
आर सोलार विंड्स। ठीक है? तो वही है। इट
इज़ हार्ड टू प्रोटेक्ट फ्रॉम सप्लाई चेन
अटैक। सिंस यू कांट ऑलवेज कंट्रोल ऑल
सॉफ्टवेयर प्रेजेंस ऑन योर लैपटॉप सर्वर्स
और वेब एप्लीकेशन।
अब ऐसे अटैक्स से ना बचाना सिस्टम को,
नेटवर्क को थोड़ा सा टफ हो जाता है बाकी
अटैक्स के मुकाबले। क्योंकि अब आप एक
सर्वर के अंदर यार हजारों लाइब्रेरीज,
सॉफ्टवेयर्स, एप्लीकेशनेशंस चलते हैं। हर
को कैसे मॉनिटर करोगे? हाउ यू कैन मॉनिटर?
बट अगर आप एसओसी हो अगर आप एसओसी एल वन हो
एंड ऑटोमेशन
के थ्रू सॉफ्टवेयर्स के थ्रू टूल्स के
थ्रू सिक्योरिटी टूल्स के थ्रू आप ये काम
कर सकते हो। ये है पावर आपकी दिस इज द
पावर ऑफ यूज़ बीइंग एन एसओसी।
गॉट इट? ये है। तो ये जो चीजें हैं आप
करोगे। तो अभी अभी तो ये बहुत छोटे लेवल
अभी तो चलो ये बस पढ़ रहे हैं हम। जब हम
इसको एग्जीक्यूट करेंगे, जब हम एसआईएम
टूल्स के अंदर देखेंगे अलग-अलग तरह के
अटैक्स को रोकने की कोशिश, लैब के अंदर
जाएंगे, सब चीजें करेंगे। हम वर्चुअल लैब
भी सेटअप करेंगे। जैसे वर्चुअल मशीन,
वीएमवेयर इन सब का यूज़ करेंगे। सब कुछ
करेंगे तो आपको और मजा आएगा। तब आपको
प्रैक्ट वो चीजें जो है ना समझ में आएगी
कि कितनी बड़ी चीजें हैं ये। राइट? अब आते
हैं वलेबिलिटीज के ऊपर में। तो
वोलेबिलिटीज एक ऐसा टॉपिक है जिसके बारे
में आई थिंक आप में से मैक्सिमम लोग जानते
होंगे क्योंकि जितने लोग यहां देख रहे हैं
अ उनमें से कई लोग जो हैं
वो अ वो ऑलरेडी वनेबिलिटीज के बारे में
पढ़ चुके हैं हमारे बग बाउंट की क्लासेस
भी देखा उन्होंने क्योंकि वो तो
वनेबिलिटीज को ही डिस्कस करती हैं पूरी की
पूरी राइट
एआई का सर एआई का यूज़ सिखाओगे क्या
बिल्कुल मैं आपको उसका
जो इंटरेक्शन है, जो चीजें हैं वो सब
बताऊंगा। बिल्कुल बेफिक्र रहिए। सर वीक
में कम से कम चार क्लास लीजिए। वीक में
चार क्लास। चलो देखते हैं वो तो डिपेंड
करता है। अगर आप आते रहोगे रेगुलर आप
ज्यादा अटेंटिव रहोगे, रेगुलर रहोगे तो
क्लासेस ज्यादा होंगी ही होंगी। इस बात की
मैं आपको गारंटी देता हूं। तो आप बेफिक्र
रहिए उसके लिए।
देखो, एव्री पीस ऑफ सॉफ्टवेयर हैव
सिक्योरिटी फ्लो। हर सॉफ्टवेयर के अंदर ना
सिक्योरिटी इश्यूज सिक्योरिटी फ्लो होता
ही होता है। कोई भी ऐसा सॉफ्टवेयर नहीं है
जो फुल्ली पैच्ज हो हमेशा से। सिक्योरिटी
फ्लॉ जिसमें ना हो। सिक्योरिटी वनेबिलिटी
जिसमें ना हो। 2024 में 4000 से भी ज्यादा
सॉफ्टवेयर वनेबिलिटीज को फाइंड किया गया
था। जिसमें से 300 से भी ज्यादा वो
एक्सप्लइट किए गए थे। बहुत बड़े-बड़े
अटैक्स के अंदर में। सोचो 400 से भी
ज्यादा वनेबिलिटीज़ को फाइंड किया गया था।
300 से भी ज्यादा वनेबिलिटीज़ को यूज़ करके
मेजर मेजर अटैक्स जो है वो प्लान किए गए
थे। अब ये मेजर अटैक्स कैसे प्लान किए गए
थे? ये वनेबिलिटीज़ जो एक्सप्लइट किए गए
ऐसी वनेबिलिटी जिनका पैच नहीं आया था
जिसको हम जीरो डे वनेबिलिटीज़ बोलते हैं।
उसका यूज़ करके जीरो डे को यूज़ करके ये
चीजें की गई थी। राइट? तो यह सारी चीजें
वनेबिलिटीज के अंदर में यह वनेबिलिटीज
होती है। अब मैं आपको यहां पर एक चार्ट
दिखाता हूं। वो चार्ट आप देखिएगा। ठीक है?
द वनेबिलिटीज
एडेड बाय सीआईएसए। सीआईएसए एक संस्था है
टू इट्स कैटलॉग इन 2022 इंपैक्टेड अ वाइड
रेंज ऑफ़ प्रोडक्ट्स बट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स
एंड आईओटी अकाउंटेड फॉर द हाईएस्ट
परसेंटेज। अब ये आप देखिए 2022 का एक डाटा
है जिसमें आप देखते हैं ये वनेबिलिटीज हैं
जिसमें डेस्कटॉप एप्लीकेशनेशंस में 67
वनेबिलिटीज फॉर्मवेयर्स में 48 वनेबिलिटीज
आईसीएस या आईओटी डिवाइसेस में 46
वनेबिलिटीज़ आईओएमटी 33 वनेबिलिटीज़ आईओटी
जो है आपका 109 वनेबिलिटीज़ मोबाइल
वलेबिलिटी 32 ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम अह इज़
वलेबिलिटीज़ में 212 वनेबिलिटीज़ यस 212
वलेबिलिटीज़ ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के अंदर में
ये आपको मिला था। सर्वर सॉफ्टवेयर्स में
24 वनेबिलिटीज़, वेब ब्राउज़र के अंदर में
आपकी 58 वनेबिलिटीज़, वेब फ्रेमवर्क में 12
एंड अनसाइंड मतलब जो जिनका कोई असाइनमेंट
नहीं हुआ था उसमें 149। इसमें सबसे ज्यादा
वबिलिटीज़ ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम में फाइंड की गई
थी। एंड देन आई ओटी डिवाइसेस में फाइंड की
गई थी। और उसके बाद वेब ब्राउज़र्स में
आपकी फाइंड की गई थी। देन हम डेस्कटॉप
एप्लीकेशन एंड फॉर्मवेयर भी है। ये सारी
चीजें हैं। तो इतनी वनेबिलिटीज़ फाइंड की
जा रही है। सोचो और उनको एक्सप्लइट किया
जा रहा है। सो व्हाट वी नो अबाउट
वनेबिलिटीज़। अ वनेबिलिटी इज़ अ वीकनेस इन अ
सिस्टम सॉफ्टवेयर, हार्डवेयर और
प्रोसेससेस दैट कैन बी एक्सप्लइटेड बाय एन
अटैकर टू गेन एक्सेस, एस्केलेट प्रिविलेज,
एग्जीक्यूट कोड, स्टील डेटा, डिसेप्ट
सर्विसेस एंड मेनी मोर। दैट्स इट। यह
वनेबिलिटी है। अगर कोई आपसे वनेबिलिटी का
डेफिनेशन पूछे नॉर्मली आप यह बोल सकते हो
कि वनेबिलिटी किसी भी एक सिस्टम सॉफ्टवेयर
या हार्डवेयर या प्रोसेस में एक वीकनेस
है। एक कमजोरी है। उस क्यों? क्या होता है
उससे? उसको एक्सप्लइट किया जा सकता है बाय
ए हैकर एन अटैकर। किस लिए एक्सप्लइट किया
जा सकता है? एक्सेस गेन करने के लिए।
प्रिविलेज को एस्केलेट करने के लिए। मतलब
नॉर्मल यूजर को रूट यूजर, एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
यूजर बना देना। गेन एक्सेस गेन करना। मतलब
कि किसी भी तरह के अनअथराइज्ड एक्सेस को
गेन करना, कोड एग्जीक्यूट करना, किसी भी
तरह का आर्बिटरी या मलिशियस कोड को सर्वर
पे एग्जीक्यूट कर देना जो नहीं होना चाहिए
या डेटा को चुरा लेना या उस सर्वर की
सर्विसेस को डिसररप्ट कर देना या धड़ामधुम
कर देना पूरा। मतलब सही से फिर सर् सर्वर
सर्विस अपनी नहीं दे रहा। यह सारी चीजें
वनेबिलिटीज जो होती हैं इस कहलाती हैं।
लेकिन अगर आपसे अगर आपसे प्लीज प्लीज डोंट
स्पैम ऑफ कोड प्लीज आप एक मैसेज बार-बार
मत कीजिए ऑफ कोड। प्लीज इधर ध्यान दीजिए।
इधर ध्यान दीजिए आप। ठीक है? अब एक
वलेबिलिटी का अगर आपसे डेफिनेशन कोई
इंटरव्यूअर पूछता है। इफ सम टेक्निकल टाइप
से अगर आपको आंसर करना है तो उसका सबसे
अच्छा आंसर जो है वो मैं आपको बता दे बता
देता हूं। अवेलेबिलिटी इज अ फ्लो और
वीकनेस इन अ सिस्टम दैट कैन बी
एक्सप्लइटेड टू टू कॉम्प्रोमाइज
कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी, इंटीग्रिटी और
अवेलेबिलिटी। दिस इज़ कॉल्ड सीआईए ट्रैड जो
आपने शायद पढ़ा होगा कहीं ना कहीं या जानते
होंगे अगर आप बगं की भी क्लासेस करते हैं
या हैकिंग की या हमारे कोर्सेज करते हैं
डीसीजीएसपी वगैरह करके रखे हैं तो आपको
पता होगा सीआई ट्राइड क्या होता है। राइट?
तो यह एक मोर टेक्निकल आंसर हो गया
इंटरव्यू लेवल के इंटरव्यू वाले लेवल पर।
इंटरव्यू में आप यह आंसर करोगे। देखो ये
भी आंसर सही है और ये भी आंसर सही है
वनेबिलिटी का। ये भी इसका सही है
डेफिनेशन। बट ये डेफिनेशन जो सेकंड वाला
है ये ज्यादा इंटरव्यू फ्रेंडली है।
ज्यादा टेक्निकल है। ज्यादा अच्छा है। ये
डिफरेंसेस होते हैं। ठीक है? इस तरीके से
इंटरव्यू समझ में आ आपको समझ में आ रहा
है? कुछ बच्चे इंटरव्यू क्लियर कर लेते
हैं। कुछ नहीं कर पाते। इसका रीज़न आपको
समझ में आ रहा है? आप जाओगे एक और बंदा
जाएगा। दोनों से सेम क्वेश्चन करेगा। अब
वो आंसर मैच करेगा। अगर दोनों ने आंसर कर
दिया है तो अब देखिएगा किसका आंसर ज्यादा
परफेक्ट था एंड उसको वो सेलेक्ट करते हैं।
यही तो होता है इंटरव्यू की साइड। दैट्स
व्हाट यू हैव टू लर्न।
बस तो कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी, इंटीग्रिटी और
अवेलेबिलिटी को कॉम्प्रोमाइज
अगर कोई करता है अटैकर किसी भी सिक्योरिटी
किसी भी तरह के फ्लॉ को एक्सप्लइट करके तो
वो वलेबिलिटी कहलाता है। एंड इसी सीआई
कॉन्फिडेंशियल इंटीग्रिटी अवेलेबिलिटी को
हम सीआईए बोलते हैं। सीआईए ट्रायड बोलते
हैं। दैट्स इट। राइट?
अब वलेबिलिटीज़ कहां-कहां एक्सिस्ट कर सकती
हैं? सॉफ्टवेयर्स में, ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स
में, एप्लीकेशनेशंस में, नेटवर्क डिवाइसेस
में, फर्मवेस्ट में, क्लाउड सर्विसेस में
एंड इवन सिक्योरिटी सॉफ्टवेयर सॉलशंस में।
इवन जो सॉफ्टवेयर सॉलशंस है सिक्योरिटी
सॉफ्टवेयर्स हैं उसमें भी वनेबिलिटीज़ जो
है वो अराइज़ कर सकती हैं। दिस इज़ द थिंग
वनेबिलिटीज़। उसमें भी आ सकती हैं। जस्ट
इमेजिन।
अब आते हैं यहां पे सॉफ्टवेयर वनेबिलिटीज़
पे। नाउ वी आर कमिंग टू सॉफ्टवेयर
वबिलिटीज़। बिफोर वी स्टार्ट लेट मी हैव सम
वाटर।
थैंक्स फॉर कवरिंग द कोर बेसिक्स। यू आर
वेलकम गाइस। यू आर यू आर वेलकम ब्रदर। कोर
बेसिक्स तो कवर करना ही है।
My वगैरह पढ़ेंगे। ऑफकोर्ड पढ़ेंगे अभी उसको
पढ़ेंगे। अभी My वगैरह पढ़ेंगे। डीएनएस का
अभी कोई अभी डीएनएस वगैरह के कांसेप्ट्स
को समझेंगे। सब चीज़ समझेंगे। वेलकम।
देखो कोर कांसेप्ट्स तो कवर मैं करूंगा ही
करूंगा क्योंकि यह जो ट्रेनिंग है यह
ट्रेनिंग बना ही है उसी के लिए या दी ही
जा रही है उसके लिए जो बिगिनर्स हैं न्यू
कमर्स एंड जो फ्रेशर्स हैं स्पेशली उनके
लिए डिलीवर कर रहा हूं मैं एक्सपीरियंस
प्रोफेशनल्स के लिए जिनको ऑलरेडी नॉलेज है
उनके लिए ट्रेनिंग मैं डिलीवर नहीं कर रहा
क्योंकि मुझे मतलब फ्रेशर्स से है पहले जो
न्यू कमर्स से हैं जिनको मैं एक लेवल पे
लेकर जा सकूं एक फ्री ट्रेनिंग की अहमियत
सिखा सकूं एक फ्री कंटेंट में भी इतनी
क्वालिटी हो सकती है यह उनको समझा सकूं और
अगर पॉसिबल हो और अगर हमारे कारण उनकी जॉब
लग जाती है तो इससे बड़ी चीज मेरे लिए
शायद नहीं होगी कुछ भी राइट हमने अपने
डीसीएपीटी लास्ट बैच से भी जॉब दिया
बच्चों को 10 बच्चों की प्लेसमेंट हुई जो
वो तो पेड ट्रेनिंग है हमारी वीएपीटी की
एंड मैं इससे भी उसी तरीके के कुछ जो है
चाहता हूं आउटकम ठीक है
लेट्स सी
ओके फॉर स्कूल 82 थैंक्स ब्रदर फॉर द सुपर
चैट सुपर चैट के लिए धन्यवाद थैंक्स एंड
सर कीप इट फ्री सर अभी तो फ्री ही रहेगा
अभी तो कोई पेड नहीं हो रहा है ये फ्री ही
रहेगी ठीक है
अभी बहुत सारी ट्रेनिंग्स आएंगी यार फ्री
फ्री वाली फ्री फ्री वाली ट्रेनिंग्स मैं
और भी लेकर आऊंगा और भी आपके ट्रेनर्स
लेकर आएंगे उसके लिए बेफिक्र रहिए
डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी एक ऐसा हब बन जाएगा कि
आप एक बार डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी पे आएंगे और
आप साइबर सिक्योरिटी की सारी बेसिक्स टू
इंटरमीडिएट कांसेप्ट्स एंड चीजों को सीख
के कर चले जाएंगे। उसके लिए कहीं भी आपको
कोई पैसा देने की जरूरत नहीं पड़ेगी। हां
अब एडवांस चीजें सीखनी है थोड़ा एडवांस
लेवल पे जाना है तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है
उसके लिए पेड ट्रेनिंग्स वगैरह होती है।
हमारी भी होती है। वो अलग बात है। लेकिन
सोचो ना बेसिक के लिए भी लोग कैसे कितना
पैसा देके जाते हैं। कई जगह पे स्कैम हो
जाता है उनके पास। इंटरमीडिएट लेवल तक की
स्टडी और वो क्वालिटी भी नहीं मिलती। वो
उस तरह का कंसेप्ट कंटेंट ही नहीं मिल
पाता। दिक्कत ये है इस वजह से ये है।
ओके ओके ठीक है ऑफकोर्ड।
थैंक यू। आपका नाम बता दीजिए एक बार ताकि
मुझे भी पता चल जाए। चलिए अब आ जाते हैं
सॉफ्टवेयर वनेबिलिटीज़ के ऊपर में। ठीक है?
एव्री पीस ऑफ़ सॉफ्टवेयर हैज़ फ्लॉज़। सारे
सॉफ्टवेयर में फ्लॉज़ हैं। बट सम टेक्स
इयर्स टू बी डिस्कवर्ड। बट कुछ सॉफ्टवेयर
फ्लॉस को सालों लग जाते हैं डिस्कवर होने
में। अब देखो फॉर एग्जांपल शेल शॉक शेल
शॉक जो है ये एक मेजर लinक्स वनेबिलिटी
था। ये कब से था पता है? 1992 से। ये एक
ऐसी वनेबिलिटी थी जीरो डे यू कैन से जो
1992 से थी। बट इसको डिस्कवर कब किया गया
था? 2014 में। मतलब 8 साल उधर ले लो और 14
साल इधर ले लो।
लगभग मतलब सोचो कितना बड़ा टाइम लाइन।
सोचो कितना बड़ा टाइम लाइन 20 प्लस इयर्स
का टाइम लाइन इसको सिर्फ डिटेक्ट करने के
लिए। समझ में आ रहा है आपको?
इन द वर्स्ट केस सिनेरियो अटैकर्स डिस्कवर
द वबिलिटी बिफोर एनीवन एल्स। कभी-कभी या
कई केसेस में ऐसा होता है कि एक वलेबिलिटी
को अटैकर ही पहले डिस्कवर कर लेता है देन
द वेंडर इटसेल्फ देन द सिक्योरिटी
रिसर्चरर्स। जो सिक्योरिटी रिस्चर्स हैं
उनके पहले और जो वेंडर्स हैं जिन्होंने उस
सॉफ्टवेयर को या उस पर्टिकुलर प्रोग्राम
को बनाया है उनसे कोई गलती हुई है और वो
वनेबिलिटी उसमें आ गई। अब उस वलेबिलिटी को
उनकी अपनी टेस्टिंग टीम या अपनी
सिक्योरिटी टीम से भी पहले या दूसरे
रिसर्चर से भी पहले कई बार हैकर्स ही
डिस्कवर कर लेते हैं। एंड इसी को ज़ीरो डे
कहा जाता है। एंड ओनली योर एसोसिएट स्किल
कैन डिटरमाइन वेदर इट्स गेट डिटेक्टेड इन
टाइम। एंड आपकी एसोसिएट स्किल ऐसे जीरो
डेज को भी पकड़ने में सक्षम है। कैपेबल
है। वो आपके स्किल्स डिफाइन करेंगे। वो
आपके स्किल्स बताएंगे कि आप कर सकते हैं
कि नहीं कर सकते हैं। राइट?
अब जीरो डे के ऊपर मैं डिटेल में थोड़ी
बात करूंगा कुछ टाइम में ताकि आपको समझ
में और अच्छे से आ जाए। जीरो डे का मतलब
सिंपल है कि एक ऐसी वलेबिलिटी जिसका कोई
पैच नहीं है। जिसकी कोई अभी मिटिगेशन नहीं
है। जिसके बारे में जिन्होंने
वलेबिलिटी निका जिन जिनके सॉफ्टवेयर में
वलेबिलिटी है उनको ही नहीं पता है। दूसरे
सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर्स को नहीं पता बट
हैकर्स को पता चल गया।
दैट्स [हंसी] द थिंग। दैट्स द मेन थिंग।
सर मैं अभी अरे भाई फर्जी जगह मत पढ़ो यार।
फर्जी जगह पे मत पढ़ा करो। मैं आपसे
रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं। थोड़ा थोड़ा पैसों को
अच्छी जगह लगाओ यार। इन्वेस्ट योर मनी एट
गुड प्लेसेस। गुड गुड इंस्टट्यूट्स
नहीं तो फिर क्या मैं बोलूं ज्यादा नहीं
बोलूंगा समझने वाले समझ जाएंगे बाकी तो
क्या ही बोलूं मैं
यस यूडेडमी में यस यूडेडमी में भी बेसिक
बताते हैं बिल्कुल सही बोला
बिल्कुल यहां पे द यहां पे एक बोल रहे हैं
कौन है राकेश सर थ्यरी के साथ-साथ थोड़ा
प्रैक्टिकल सेशन भी डाल दिया जाए तो सर
क्लास क्लास तो क्लास करने में थोड़ा और
मजा आ जाता। नहीं आपके लिए फिर राकेश यह
क्लास नहीं है। आप क्लास को लीव कर दीजिए
क्योंकि अगर आप यह बोल रहे हैं कि थ्यरी
के साथ-साथ प्रैक्टिकल डाल देने से क्लास
में आपको मजा आएगा तो फिर इस मजे के लिए
मैं क्लास नहीं ले रहा और इस मजे के लिए
मैं ये क्लास प्रोवाइड भी नहीं कर रहा।
इट्स एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी फॉर दैट। आपको अगर
बुरा लगा तो सॉरी। बट उसके लिए मैं यह
क्लास नहीं ले रहा। आप और आप इस क्लास को
छोड़ भी सकते हैं अगर आप चाहें तो। बिकॉज़
आई डोंट वांट एनीबडी एनी लर्नर्स लाइक दैट
कि जिनको प्रैक्टिकल्स को घुसाने का
जबरदस्ती हो कि सर प्रैक्टिकल लाओ
प्रैक्टिकल लाओ। अगर थ्योरी की कांसेप्ट
कंसेप्चुअल चीजें कांसेप्ट्स ही अगर
क्लियर नहीं हो रही हैं आपकी तो
प्रैक्टिकल ला के मैं क्या करूंगा? मैं बस
क्लासेस को जल्दी-जल्दी भगा दूंगा। यही तो
करूंगा। तो आपके लिए वो बढ़िया नहीं
रहेगा। और आपके लिए अगर बढ़िया नहीं रहेगा
तो मैं वो काम अभी फिलहाल तो नहीं कर सकता
क्योंकि ये जॉब ओरिएंटेड ट्रेनिंग मैंने
नाम दे दिया है। तो इसको उसी तरीके से
कराना पड़ेगा। नहीं तो बाद में आप ही लोग
बोलेंगे कि सर आपने तो जॉब ओरिएंटेड बोला
था और बाकी नॉर्मल ट्रेनिंग्स की तरह आपने
ट्रेनिंग डिलीवर कर दिया। राइट? तो बाद
में यू विल बी द थिंग यू विल बी द वन हु
इज़ गोइंग टू ब्लेम मी ओनली हु इज़ गोइंग टू
ब्लेम डिफ़्रॉनिक्स ओनली। आप ही हैं। जैसे
यूजर करता है ना यूजर ही गलती करता है।
यूजर ही अटैक करता है सिस्टम पे। वैसे ही
आप खुद जो लर्नर है वही अटैक करने लगेंगे।
तो इसलिए ये ये चीजें मैं नहीं करूंगा।
सर टिल यू कंप्लीट द होल कोर्स नीडेड फॉर
फ्रेशर एसोसएल वन दिस लेक्चर्स विल बी
फ्री। बिल्कुल फ्री रहेगा। जब तक मैं ये
कोर्स पूरी कंप्लीट करता हूं ये बिल्कुल
फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट ही रहेगा। जब ये पूरी
कंप्लीट हो जाएगी इंटरव्यू प्रिपरेशन वाली
मॉड्यूल कंप्लीट हो जाएगी तब ये लेक्चर्स
को मैं मेंबर ओनली कर सकता हूं। मैं
करूंगा कि नहीं ये पता नहीं है मुझे। बट
मैं कर सकता हूं। इट टोटली अप टू मी। मेरा
दिमाग खिसका तो मैंने कर मैं कर दूंगा।
दिमाग अगर नहीं खिसका तो रहेगा ऐसे ही
फ्री में रहेगा। तो इट्स टोटली अप टू यू
अप टू मी राइट
नहीं मैं नहीं जानता मैं नहीं जानता फटम
हैकर मैं नहीं जानता आई डोंट नो अ सच पीपल
मुझे नहीं पता ऐसे लोगों के बारे में
किसके बारे में बोल रहे हो बस मुझे यह पता
है कि गलती जगह पे पढ़ाई कर रहे हो गलत
जगह पे चीजें चले गए हो वो क्योंकि मेरे
को मेरे पास बहुत सारी कंप्लेंट्स आई है
उस जगह की बहुत सारे स्टूडेंट्स की
कंप्लेंट आई है तो समझ जाओ आप ज्यादा अगर
अगर अगर फिर भी नहीं समझ पा रहे हो तो
थैंक यू ब्रदर थैंक यू
ओके अब यहां पे है वंस अ वलेबिलिटी इज़ मेड
पब्लिक अब यहां पे ध्यान दीजिएगा आप लोग
सभी लोग यहां पे ध्यान दीजिएगा प्लीज इट्स
अ रिक्वेस्ट
वंस अ वलेबिलिटी इज़ मेड पब्लिक इट इज़
असाइन अ कॉमन वलेबिलिटीज़ एंड एक्सपोज़र
नंबर इसको एक सीवी नंबर मिल जाता है। जब
कोई वनेबिलिटी को पब्लिक कर दिया जाता है
तो इट गॉट इट गेट्स अ सीवीई नंबर। यह
नॉर्मल चीज है। यह सीवी नंबर मिल जाती है।
फॉर दैट फ्रॉम दैट मोमेंट इट्स अ रेस।
उसके बाद से ये एक रेस की तरह होता है।
क्या? अटैकर्स जो है एक्सप्लइट डेवलप करने
में लग जाते हैं। एक्सप्लइट्स को डेवलप
करते हैं। एंड डिफेंडर्स जो है वो अपडेट
करने के चक्कर में पड़ जाते हैं। पैच करने
के चक्कर में पड़ जाते हैं। ये चीजें होती
हैं। तो जैसे ही कोई वनेबिलिटी को पब्लिक
किया जाता है। जैसे मान लो कोई एक जीरो डे
वनेबिलिटी है। उसको पब्लिक कर दिया गया।
अरे ये Jio डे वनेबिलिटी इसमें आई है। अब
दो चीजें होती है। एक तरफ अटैकर भागते
हैं, एक तरफ जो है डिफेंडर्स भागते हैं।
अटैकर क्या करते हैं? उस वनेबिलिटी का यूज़
करके एक्सप्लइट्स डेवलप करते हैं। जो कि
मतलब वन क्लिक में कोई वनेबिलिटी को
एक्सप्लइट किया जा किया जा सके नॉर्मल
यूजर की तरफ से और उस वनेबिलिटी का पूरा
यूज़ किया जा सके। अब जैसे कोई वलेबिलिटी
एक वलेबिलिटी
है रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन का। मान लो जहां
पे आप किसी सर्वर पे कॉम्प्रोमाइज सर्वर
पे किसी भी तरह का कमांड एग्जीक्यूट कर
सकते हो आप अपने पसंद की और उसके थ्रू फिर
पूरे सर्वर को कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर सकते हो।
तो अब रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन की कोई
वलेबिलिटी निकलती है तो वनेबिलिटी जब
निकलेगी तो वो क्यों आई है रिमोट कोड
एग्जीक्यूशन? वो जो एग्जीक्यूशन वलेबिलिटी
है व्हाई दैट एक्चुअली केम? व्हाई दैट
एक्चुअली एकिस्ट? क्यों आई है?
उस बेसिस पे एक एक्सप्लइट तैयार किया जाता
है। पीस ऑफ कोड लिखा जाता है। वो
एक्सप्लइट किसी भी लैंग्वेज में हो सकती
है। C में हो सकती है, पython में हो सकती
है, जावा में हो सकती है, रूबी में हो
सकती है, पोइल में हो सकती है। व्हाटएवर।
एंड उस एक्सप्लइट को जब क्रिएट कर दिया
जाता है तो फिर वो जो है पब्लिक उस
एक्सप्लइट को यूज़ करती है एंड वहां पे जो
है एक्सप्लइट को यूज़ करके वो उस वलेबिलिटी
को एग्जीक्यूट करती है। अगर ऐसे ही
एक्सप्लइट अ आपको डेटाबेस का देखना है तो
देयर इज़ अ एक्सप्लइट डीबी वेबसाइट कई
लोगों को शायद पता होगा। कई लोगों को नहीं
पता होगा। ये एक एक्सप्लइय डीबी वेबसाइट
है जहां पे डिफरेंट टाइप्स ऑफ़ एक्सप्लइट्स
आर लिस्टेड। कुछ वेरीिफाइड एक्सप्लइट्स
होते हैं, कुछ नॉन वेरीिफाइड होते हैं,
कुछ अंडर प्रोसेस होते हैं वेरिफिकेशन
में। एंड यहां पे बहुत सारे पड़े रहते
हैं। इन एक्सप्लइट्स को आप यूज कर सकते हो
अकॉर्डिंग टू व्हाटएवर यूज केसेस इज़ देयर
फॉर यू। तो इस तरीके की चीजें होती है।
चलिए
अब देखिए,
एन आंसर टू अ सीवी इज़ ऑलवेज अ पैच। सीवी
का आंसर क्या है? पैच है। एक सीवी जब आती
है जब एक वलेबिलिटी को कॉमन वलेबिलिटी एंड
एक्सपोज़र नंबर दे दिया जाता है। ऐसी
वेलेबिलिटी जो जीरो डे वालेबिलिटी है
जिसका पैच अभी तक नहीं आया है। जिसके बारे
में सिर्फ हैकर लोग को पता है। तो उसके
मिटिगेशन में उसके काउंटर मेजर में क्या
किया जाता है? सीवी के काउंटर मेजर में एक
पैच लाया जाता है। पैच का मतलब उसको फिक्स
करने का। उस वलेबिलिटी को एन अपडेट
सप्लाइड बाय द सॉफ्टवेयर वेंडर। जो
सॉफ्टवेयर का वेंडर है यानी जो सॉफ्टवेयर
जिसने बनाया है जिसने सॉफ्टवेयर प्रोवाइड
करा है उसके द्वारा एक पैच लाया जाता है।
इवन फॉर जीरो डेज यू विल हैव टू वेट फॉर
पैच विजिलेंटली मॉनिटर फॉर एक्सप्लइटेशन
ट्रेसेस एंड ट्राई टू सर्वाइव द
स्ट्रेसफुल पीरियड बिफोर द पैच इज़
रिलीज़्ड। मतलब पैच रिलीज़ से पहले आपको वेट
करना पड़ेगा। जैसे मान लो कि कोई Microsoft
की कोई सर्विस जो है उसका एक्सप्लइट आ
चुका है। मान लो ऐसा होता है कई बार
Microsoft के एक्सप्लइट्स आते हैं
निकल-निकल के। राइट? अब जब वो एक्सप्लइट
आया तो आपको पता चला। अब आपके पास क्या
ऑप्शन है? कुछ नहीं। आप बस वेट कीजिए
क्योंकि वो सर्विसेंट है। आप उस सर्विस को
बंद भी नहीं कर सकते, हटा भी नहीं सकते।
अब वेट कीजिए। Microsoft पैच रिलीज़ करेगी।
उसका नेक्स्ट जो भी पैच अपडेट आएगा जो कि
सिक्योरिटी अपडेट्स बोलते हैं जिसको
सिक्योरिटी पैच अपडेट्स बोलते हैं एंड देन
आप अपडेट कर लोगे हो जाएगी वो वोलेबिलिटी
रॉल्व हो जाएगी ये चीजें होती हैं कंपनीज़
करती हैं जैसे आपको आते हैं ना सिक्योरिटी
अपडेट्स आते रहते हैं आपके फोन में भी आते
हैं आपके लैपटॉप आपके Windows में भी
सिक्योरिटी अपडेट आता है MacB Mac OS अगर
आप यूज़ करते हैं तो आपके MacBook में भी
सिक्योरिटी अपडेट्स आते हैं। तो वो
सिक्योरिटी अपडेट्स इसी के लिए होते हैं
कि नॉन वनेबिलिटीज जो अभी रिसेंटली नॉन
वनेबिलिटीज आई हैं उनके नजर में आई हैं
उनको वो पैच करते हैं ताकि कोई मलिशियस
एक्टर हैकर या अटैकर जो है उसको वाइडली जो
है बड़े लेवल पे एक्सप्लइट करके एंड बैंड
ना बजा दे उस कंपनी की। दैट्स द मेन थिंग।
राइट? चलिए।
या। अब यहां पे आते हैं एग्ज़ांपल के लिए।
रेस्ट्रिक्टिंग एक्सेस टू द सिस्टम टू
ओनली ट्रस्टेड आईपीस। तो पैच में किस
तरीके की चीजें होती हैं? रेस्ट्रिक्टिंग
एक्सेस टू द सिस्टम टू ओनली ट्रस्टेड
आईपीस। अपाइंग टेंपरेरी मेजर्स प्रोवाइडेड
बाय द वेंडर ब्लॉकिंग नॉन अटैक पैटर्न्स
ऑन आईपीएस और वैफ। तो मतलब ये जो स्टेप्स
हैं ये आपको बेसिकली करने चाहिए। अगर कोई
ऐसी सीवी है, कोई ऐसा वनेबिलिटी अराइज़ हुआ
है, आपको पता चला है, तो आपको सबसे पहले
ये चीजें करनी चाहिए। आपको क्या करना
चाहिए कि सिर्फ ट्रस्टेड आईपीस ही उन
सिस्टम्स को एक्सेस कर कर सके। ऐसा रूल
सिक्योरिटी रूल सेटअप करना चाहिए। एंड
टेंपरेरी मेजर कोई है वेंडर की तरफ से कोई
टेंपरेरी अपडेट या कोई टेंपरेरी एक फाइल
दी गई है वेंडर की तरफ से कि आप इसको
एग्जीक्यूट कर लीजिए। टेंपरेरी सॉल्यूशन
हो जाएगा। तो वो करना चाहिए। एंड नॉन अटैक
पैटर्न्स जो हैं जो आपको लगता है कि सबसे
ज्यादा ये अटैक पैटर्न्स जो है ज्यादा यूज़
हो रही है ज्यादा मलिशियस हो सकती हैं तो
उसको आप ब्लॉक कर दीजिएगा आपके VF पे वेब
एप्लीकेशन फायर वाल पे या वो आईपीएस
इंट्रोशन प्रिवेंशन सिस्टम पे दैट्स इट।
दिस इज़ द थिंग। अब सॉफ्टवेयर वनेबिलिटीज
के एग्जांपल की बात करें तो सॉफ्टवेयर
वनेबिलिटीज में एग्जांपल में जैसे आपने
पढ़ा ही होगा एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन, कमांड
इंजेक्शन, बफर ओवरफ्लो, क्रॉस सेट
स्क्रिप्टिंग, रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन ये
सारी वलेबिलिटीज़ ऑलमोस्ट मैंने हमारी बग
बाउंट की सीरीज में कवर करी हुई है। बग
बाउंट की सीरीज में कवर की हुई है। अब आप
में से
आईपीएस का फुल फॉर्म है इंट्रोसेंट
प्रिवेंशन सिस्टम। एक होती है आईडीएस
इंट्रोसेंट डिटेक्शन सिस्टम। एक आईपीएस
इंट्रोसन इंट्रोजन या इंट्रोसन बोलो या
इंट्रोजन बोलो कुछ भी बोल सकते हो
प्रिवेंशन सिस्टम ठीक है डिटेक्ट करता है
एक और एक प्रिवेंट करता है ठीक है
ओके सो देयर इज़ अ देयर इज़ अ क्वेश्चन ऑफ़
देयर इज़ अ मैसेज फ्रॉम बीजोए अह
चंद्रकर्माकर आई एम अ एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट
एंड आई वांट एंड आई वांट एडवाइस टु द
फ्रेशर्स दैट अंडरस्टैंड थ्यरी एंड
कॉनंसेप्ट टू क्रैक इंटरव्यूज़। योर
स्किल्स विल बी यूज़्ड आफ्टर यू गेट द जॉब।
बट टू गेट इट यू विल डेफिनेटली नीड थ्यरी।
बिल्कुल सही बोला। एब्सोलुटली करेक्ट
वर्ड्स बाय बिज़ोए। तो बिजोए इज़ आल्सो
एसोसिए एनालिस्ट। इनका यह खुद ही एक
एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट है। मैं इनका कमेंट पिन
भी कर देता हूं। पिन होता है क्या?
अच्छा मैं पिन नहीं कर सकता क्या?
ओके। यहां तो पिन नहीं कर पा रहा हूं मैं।
मैं यहां से पिन कर देता हूं ताकि आप
लोगों को ना चीजें थोड़ी ध्यान आए। मतलब
आप लोगों आप लोग थोड़ा समझते नहीं हो ना?
अ
लेट मी पिन फर्स्ट।
जस्ट अ सेकंड।
कुछ ज्यादा ही फ़ास्ट यह जा रही है। यह
क्या हो रहा है यार?
ओके ये पहले थोड़ा वो था। ओल्ड चैट्स आ गई
थी। दैट्स व्हाई।
हां जी। तो अब मिल चुके हैं यहां पे। मैं
ये पिन कर देता हूं। आप इसको पढ़ लीजिएगा।
ये हिज़ व्हाटएवर ही हैज़ रिटेन। इट्स टोटली
करेक्ट। सो, मैं यहां पे पिन मैसेज कर
देता हूं बिजोए का। ठीक है? यू कैन सी द
मैसेज।
सो ही इज ही इज करली एसोसिए एनालिस्ट।
आपको अगर ऐसा लग रहा है कि मैं सिर्फ बोल
रहा हूं तो वो खुद ही एक प्रोफेशनल है।
एंड ही इज़ सेइंग द करेक्ट थिंग कि आप जब
इंटरव्यू में जाएंगे तो इंटरव्यू में आपसे
एसआईएम टूल्स पे काम करवा के इंटरव्यू
नहीं लेंगे आपका कि आपको बिठा देंगे टूल
पे और बोलेंगे कि चलो ये अलर्ट करके वो
करके दिखाओ ये करके दिखाओ। नहीं वो आपसे
थ्यरिटिकल और कॉनसेप्चुअल क्वेश्चंस
करेंगे। आपको फंसाने वाले क्वेश्चंस
करेंगे। मैनपुलेटिव क्वेश्चंस करेंगे। एक
चीज को दूसरी चीज से मिक्स करके उसमें से
चूज़ करने को बोलेंगे। चार ऑप्शंस देंगे।
चारों आपको सही लगेगा। बोलेंगे बताओ क्या
होगा? मतलब स्किल बेस्ड क्वेश्चंस होते
हैं। एंड उसके लिए अगर आपको थ्यरी और
कांसेप्ट नहीं पता तो मैं गारंटी बोल रहा
हूं आप नहीं निकाल पाएंगे। क्रैक नहीं कर
पाएंगे। गारंटी बोल रहा हूं। और इतने लोग
अगर वीडियोस देख रहे हैं और अगर आप
एलिजिबल हैं एसओसी एल वन रोल के लिए मतलब
जॉब अप्लाई करने के लिए अगर इनमें से
मात्र चारप लोगों की सिर्फ प्लेसमेंट होती
है तो ये आपकी गलती होगी। मैं आपको गारंटी
देके बोलता हूं क्योंकि आपने थ्यरी और
कांसेप्ट वाले टाइम पे फोकस ही नहीं करा
होगा। तो अभी जितने लोग फोकस कर रहे हैं।
अभी मैं तो मैं तो बोलता हूं 20020 लोग
हैं यहां पे। अगर 20020 लोग भी अगर फोकस
करके करें ना तो मैक्सिमम लोगों की
प्लेसमेंट हो सकती है। अगर यू आर कॉलेज
फ्रेश आउट या अगर आप एलिजिबल हैं
बैकग्राउंड ऐसा है तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है।
या करेक्ट
ओके सो प्लीज चैट में आप लोग इधर इधर आप
लोग ध्यान दीजिए अब अब वापस से स्क्रीन पर
आ जाइए चैट को छोड़ देते हैं राइट कम ऑन द
स्क्रीन
चलिए सो सॉफ्टवेयर वैलेबिलिटीज में ये
सारे जो वनेबिलिटीज हैं ये ऑलरेडी कवर्ड
है। अगर आपको नहीं पता तो बग बंटी की
हमारी सीरीज चलती है। एंड हां बग बंटी की
सीरीज आप लोगों में से कुछ लोग पूछते हैं
लाइक सम पीपल आस्क कि सर मैं बग बंटी की
जो सीरीज है क्या वो भी देख सकता हूं?
इट्स टोटली अप टू यू। आप यहां पे लाइव
सेक्शन में जाएंगे तो आप देखेंगे यहां पे
बग बंटी की प्लेलिस्ट यहां पे देखेंगे। या
तो आप प्लेलिस्ट में जाइएगा एंड प्लेलिस्ट
में जाएंगे तो आपको बग बंटी की यहां पे
व्यू फुल प्लेलिस्ट मिल जाएगी हमारी
क्लासेस की। अभी तक इस पूरे प्लेलिस्ट में
टोटल 66 वीडियोस हैं एंड कुछ रैंडम
वीडियोस भी हैं। 59 क्लासेस तक हुई हैं।
आप इन क्लासेस को पैरेली एसओसी के साथ देख
सकते हैं। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है।
डेफिनेटली यू कैन सी बट एसओसी पे ज्यादा
फोकस रखिएगा। मैं यही बोलूंगा। उनको बस
नॉलेज के लिए आप देख सकते हैं। कोई ऐसा
मैंडेटरी नहीं है या कोई प्रीरिक्विज़िट
नहीं है कि आप नहीं देखेंगे तो आपको एसओसी
समझ नहीं आएगा। ऐसा कुछ नहीं है। लेकिन आप
चाहें आपके पास टाइम हो मैनेज हो रहा हो
तो बिल्कुल देख सकते हैं।
अब ये वलेबिलिटीज के सॉफ्टवेयर वबिलिटीज
के लिए एसओसी डिटेशंस में किस तरीके की
चीजें होती हैं? जब एसओसी डिटेक्शन होगा
तो क्या होगा? वेफ अलर्ट आएंगे। वेब सर्वर
लॉग्स जो है उसमें आपको पता चलेगा। उसके
थ्रू पता चलेगा आपके। अनयूजुअल पोस्ट
रिक्वेस्ट्स आपको दिखेंगे। एडीआर अलर्ट्स
आएंगे सर्वर्स के ऊपर। ये एसओसी के
डिटेक्शंस में ये सारी चीजें आएंगी आपकी।
जब कोई सॉफ्टवेयर वनेबिलिटीज़ ट्रिगर होगा।
ये आपको समझना है। ये आपसे इंटरव्यू में
पूछा जा सकता है कि अगर सॉफ्टवेयर ऐसा
पूछा जा सकता है कि इफ देयर इज़ अ
सॉफ्टवेयर वनेबिलिटी व्हाट काइंड ऑफ़
अलॉट्स और डिटेक्शंस कैन वी एक्सपेक्ट
फ्रॉम द एसआईएम या फ्रॉम द व्हाटएवर टूल
यू आर यूज़िंग। तो ये आप पॉइंट्स बोल सकते
हो। इस तरह के पॉइंट्स आप बोल के कर सकते
हो। देखो साथ-साथ में इंटरव्यू में कैसे
क्या होता है वो भी मैं आपको बताता चल रहा
हूं। अलग से भी सेशंस होंगे तो उसके लिए
बेफिक्र रहिए।
अब आइए अब यहां पे आते हैं बफर ओवरफ्लो।
अभी एक बंदा पूछ रहा है सर यू कैन यू
एक्सप्लेन इन शॉर्ट बफर ओवरफ्लो। बफर
ओवरफ्लो का मैं एक शॉर्ट में एक्सप्लेन
करूं। सिंपल मतलब है ग्लास
एक देखो मतलब क्या है? मैं बताता हूं। ये
बोतल है। पानी की बोतल है। ठीक है? 1 लीटर
की बोतल है। अब 1 लीटर की इस बोतल में
स्टोरेज मेरी 1 लीटर की होगी। अब इस 1
लीटर की बोतल में मैं 1 लीटर से ज्यादा
जैसे ही 1.1 लीटर 1 01 लीटर, 1.5 लीटर, 2
लीटर ऐसे जब मैं पानी डालूंगा तो क्या
होगा पानी का? पानी इसके बाहर से गिरने
लगेगी। यही होगा ना? पानी विल गेट
ओवरफ्लो। यही होगी। उसी तरीके से
प्रोसेससेस जो होते हैं उनका एक मेमोरी
यूनिट डिफाइंड होता है। एक प्रोसेससेस की
मेमोरी एलोकेशन होती है। एंड जब
प्रोसेससेस उस मेमोरी एलोकेशनेशंस
से बाहर ऑपरेट करने लगते हैं। मतलब उसकी
मेमोरी जब पूरी जो उसको स्पेस मिला है उस
स्पेस से ज्यादा जब वो यूटिलाइज करने लगते
हैं तो उसमें क्या होता है? उसमें लीकेज
होती है। उसमें लीकेज होती है। ड्यू टू
सेवरल फैक्टर्स। देयर आर डिफरेंट
फैक्टर्स। तो वो एडजेसेंट जो प्रोसेससेस
है उसके से जाके एंड कोलाइड करते हैं। मैं
बहुत नॉर्मल लैंग्वेज में समझाने की कोशिश
कर रहा हूं। देयर इज़ सम रियली दिस इज़ अ टफ
टॉपिक यू कैन से। टफ तो नहीं बोलूंगा
लेकिन थोड़ा कॉम्प्लेक्स होता है। कई
लोगों को अगर हम टेक्निकली समझे तो एंड वो
फिर उस प्रोसेस की की बैंड बजाते हैं।
मतलब बैंड बजाते हैं सिस्टम की। सिस्टम
आपका क्रैश कर जाता है। कई बार ऐसा भी
होता है। Windows का ब्लू स्क्रीन ऑफ डेथ
जो Windows में आपको आती है ना ब्लू
स्क्रीन ऑफ डेथ कई बार आ जाती है। एकदम
ब्लू ब्लू हो जाता है। स्क्रीन रीस्टार्ट
सिस्टम ऑटोमेटिक रीस्टार्ट वो बफर और फ्लो
का ही एक
एग्जांपल आप बोल सकते हो।
राइट? हां हां DOS की तरह यू कैन सी यस।
राइट?
अब आते हैं ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम वालेबिलिटीज़
के ऊपर में। ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम वलेबिलिटीज़
में जैसे Windows की वैलेबिलिटीज़, Linux
की वलेबिलिटीज़, Mac OS की वलेबिलिटीज़ यह
सारे ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के अवेलेबिलिटीज़
होते हैं। कहलाते हैं। जैसे कि प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन के वलेबिलिटीज़ हो गए। एसएमबी के
वलेबिलिटीज़ हो गए। एसएमबी सर्वे मैसेज
ब्लॉक जो होता है जैसे इंटरनल ब्लू कर्नल
के एक्सप्लइट्स हो गए। ये सारे ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम्स के वलेबिलिटीज़ आते हैं। मतलब ऐसे
वलेबिलिटीज़ जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स को
इंपैक्ट करते हो। दोज़ आर कॉल्ड
दोज़ आर कॉल्ड ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
वालेबिलिटीज़। तो जो भी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स
हैं अवेलेबल उन सबके वलेबिलिटीज़ को हम
बोलेंगे। इसमें क्या होगा? सडन प्रिविलेज
चेंजज़। आपको एसओसी डिटेक्शन में क्या
आएगा? सडन कोई प्रिविलेज चेंज हो गई।
एक्सप्लइट बिहेवियर इन ईडीआर। ईडीआर के
अंदर एक्सप्लइट बिहेवियर आपको दिखने लगे
कि अरे भैया कुछ एक्सप्लइट हो रहा है
क्या? कुछ इस तरीके की एक्सप्लइटेशन हो
रही है क्या? कर्नल ड्राइविंग लोडिंग
अलर्ट्स आ रहे हैं। कर्नल की ड्राइवर जो
है अलग-अलग डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ ड्राइवर्स को
लोड किया जा रहा है। कर्नल के ड्राइवर्स
जो ड्राइवर्स लोड नहीं होने चाहिए या जो
ड्राइवर्स आपके पास नहीं होने चाहिए
सिस्टम में वो लोड किया जा रहा है। इस तरह
की चीजें आ रही है तो एसोसिएट डिटेक्शन
में ये चीजें आप एक्सपेक्ट कर सकते हो जब
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम वालेबिलिटीज की हम बात
करें। समझ में आ रहा है?
आर यू अंडरस्टैंडिंग गाइस?
गाइस? प्लीज लेट मी नो। आर यू
अंडरस्टैंडिंग?
ऑफकोड प्लीज डोंट स्पैम अगर आप स्पैम अगर
इसके बाद भी करेंगे तो आपको मजबूरी में
मुझे टाइम आउट करना पड़ जाएगा लॉन्ग लॉन्ग
ड्यूरेशन के लिए तो प्लीज मैं आपसे
रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं
समझ में आ रहा है सबको आ रहा है वेरी गुड
वेरी गुड बताओ आप लोग बोलते हो 2 घंटे की
क्लास लेने के लिए अभी 1 घंटा ही हुआ है
और यहां पे 200 250 से 200 पे आ गए हैं
लोग मजा इंटरेस्ट ही नहीं है लोगों में
यार पता नहीं कैसे हाउ हाउ पीपल विल
अंडरस्टैंड देंस ऑफ दी थिंग्स? आई डोंट
नो। बहुत मुश्किल है ऐसी चीजों को समझाना,
लोगों को कन्विंस करना। इट्स वेरी हार्ड
थिंग। आप लोगों को बस फालतू चीजें अच्छी
लगेंगी। जहां पे आपका पैसा
आपका पैसा आपको पैसे लेके ठग दिया जा रहा
है। आपको
रबिश कंटेंट दिया जा रहा है। फालतू के
कंटेंट सिखा दिए जा रहे हैं। पैसे लेके
टाइम वेस्ट कर दिया जा रहा है। यू लाइक
दोज़ थिंग्स। बहुत लोगों को यह चीज़ पसंद
है। आई नो बहुत लोगों को यह चीज़ पसंद है।
आई नो। अह खैर, ठीक है। हम आगे बढ़ते हैं।
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम वालेबिलिटीज़ हमने ये समझ
लिया। दिस इज़ सिंपल ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
वलेबिलिटीज़। ठीक है? अब देखिए अब आते हैं
नेटवर्क वैलेबिलिटीज़ के ऊपर में। नेटवर्क
में कैसी वलेबिलिटीज़ हो सकती है? तो ओपन
पोर्ट्स हो सकता है। पोर्ट ओपन हो जाए।
वीक प्रोटोकॉल्स मतलब नॉट सिक्यर्ड
प्रोटोकॉल्स यूज़ हो गए। अनपैच्ज्ड राउटर
या फेयरवल। ऐसी राउटर या फेयरवल जो पैड्स
ना हो उसको यूज़ कर रहे हैं हम। उसी पे सब
कुछ कर रहे हैं। एक्सपोज्ड एडमिन
इंटरफ़ेससेस। एडमिन इंटरफ़ेस को एक्सपोज़ कर
रहे हैं। जिससे कि ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक्स इस
तरह की चीजें हो सकती है। ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
किया जा सकता है। तो ये नेटवर्क
वनेबिलिटीज़ के अंदर में आ जाती है। अभी ये
टॉपिक्स मैं बहुत शॉर्ट-शोर्ट में मतलब एक
एवरेज शॉर्ट ड्यूरेशन में आपको करा रहा
हूं। एक कॉन्सेप्चुअल बेसिस पे। हम आगे जब
बढ़ेंगे, तो एक-एक चीज़ को बहुत डिटेल में
समझने वाले हैं। तो अगर आपका यह कॉन्सेप्ट
नहीं सही है, तो आगे आपको कुछ नहीं समझ
में आएगा। मैं आपको गारंटी आपको देता हूं।
बस
अब एसओसी डिटेक्शन में किस तरह की चीजें
आएंगी? आईडीएस या आईपीएस का अलर्ट आएगा कि
भैया ये नेटवर्क वालेज हैं। फायरवल के
लॉग्स में आपको दिखेंगे चीजें एंड
एक्सेसिव ऑथेंटिकेशन फेलर्स आएगा। बार-बार
ऑथेंटिकेशन फेलर्स आएंगे कि अरे भैया ये
यूजर ट्राई कर रहा है बार-बार ऑथेंटिकेट
करने का। एडमिन इंटरफ़ेस पे जब ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
अटैक होगा तो क्या होगा कि ऑथेंटिकेशन
फेलर का प्रॉब्लम आएगा। बार-बार
ऑथेंटिकेशन फेलर होंगे। बार-बार दिक्कतें
होंगी। यही चीजें होंगी। तो ये एसोसिएट
डिटेशंस में आपके आएंगे। तो मतलब मैं आपको
वलेबिलिटीज़ भी बता रहा हूं और उसके
रिलेटेड जो भी डिटेक्शंस में किस तरह की
चीजें आ सकती है वो भी मैं आपको बता रहा
हूं।
करेक्ट।
एब्सोलुटली करेक्ट। यू विल आल्सो हैव टू
फाइंड द करेक्ट लॉग्स। जब हम एसओसी का काम
करते हैं तो हम फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स को साइड
हमेशा करते हैं। लाइक फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स को
हम आइडेंटिफाई करने की कोशिश करते हैं।
आपको कहीं से कोई भी लॉग मिल रहा है, कुछ
भी लॉग मिल रहा है। आपका सबसे पहला ही काम
होता है कि फॉल्स पॉजिटिव्स को आइडेंटिफाई
करना। एंड फिर जो ट्रू पॉजिटिव है यानी कि
जो वैलिड चीजें हैं उसको आइडेंटिफाई करना
एंड आपको डॉक्यूमेंट फेयर करना पड़ता है
और उसी के अकॉर्डिंग फिर आगे प्रोसेस होती
है। तो हर जगह पे आपको ध्यान से देना है।
ध्यान से रखना। अब कोई मान लो आपको
इंटरव्यू में पूछ ले कि आप जब नेटवर्क
वैलेबिलिटीज़ को चेक कर रहे हैं तो फायरवल
लॉग्स का कोई रोल है या नहीं है? है तो
कैसे है? तो आप बताएंगे बिल्कुल है फायर
लॉग्स का हम वी हैव टू कलेक्ट द फायर
लॉग्स। फिर आप अगर उतना ही बोल देंगे छोड़
देंगे तो यह मजेदार आंसर नहीं रहा। फिर
आपको आगे की प्रोसेससेस बताने हैं। किस
तरीके से हम अ कैप्चर करेंगे। एक फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव्स को हम फ़्टर आउट करेंगे। ट्रू
पॉजिटिव्स को हम लेकर जाएंगे। फिर
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन करेंगे। फॉल्स पॉजिटिव है
तो उसका क्या रीज़न है? क्यों फॉल्स
पॉजिटिव आपको लग रहा है? किस तरीके से?
एस्केलेट करना चाहिए कि नहीं करना चाहिए?
किस तरीके की सीवियरिटी है? सब कुछ आपको
बताना होता है। एवरीथिंग।
ठीक है? चलिए
अब आते हैं ऑथेंटिकेशन एंड ऑथराइजेशन
वलेबिलिटीज़। ऑथेंटिकेशन एंड ऑथराइजेशन
वलेबिलिटीज क्या होती हैं? तो इसमें आपका
वीक पासवर्ड आ गया। नो मल्टीफैक्ट
ऑथेंटिकेशन या टू फैक्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन आ गया।
ब्रोकन एक्सेस कंट्रोल जैसे आईडीओ आर जैसी
वलेबिलिटी जहां पे वो कंटेंट वो पाथ को या
वो कंटेंट को एक्सेस करना जो उस पर्टिकुलर
यूजर के लिए इंटेंडेडेंट नहीं है। उसका
लेवल ऑफ़ एक्सेस नहीं है। उसको भी एक्सेस
कर लेना वो ब्रोकन एक्सेस कंट्रोल में आ
जाता है। प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशंस पाथ
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन अगर हो पा रही है।
उसका पाथ जो है वो भी आपका इसी के अंदर
में आ जाता है। अब एसोसिएट डिटेक्शन में
क्या आएगा? आईएएम अलर्ट्स आएंगे। जैसे अगर
आप कोई मेनली क्लाउड सर्विज इस तरह की
चीजें या आइडेंटिटी एक्सेस मैनेजमेंट इसका
मतलब होता है आइडेंटिटी एंड एक्सेस
मैनेजमेंट। तो आपकी आइडेंटिटी एंड एक्सेस
को मैनेज करने के लिए ये इस तरह के जो
सर्विज हैं वो यूज़ में आते हैं। तो उसका
अलर्ट अगर आता है तो वो आप समझ लीजिए कि
ऑथेंटिकेशन या ऑथोराइजेशन अवेलेबिलिटीज़
ओरिजनेट हो रही है आपकी। एक्सेस लॉग्स को
आप चेक करके इसका पता लगा सकते हैं। एंड
रोल चेंज इवेंट्स कोई रोल चेंज हो रही है
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन कोई नॉर्मल यूजर को
ज्यादा ज्यादा प्रिविलेज मिल जा रहा है।
ज्यादा चीजें वो कर पा रहा है। सो दैट
आल्सो फॉल्स अंडर ऑथेंटिकेशन एंड
ऑथराइजेशन वनेबिलिटी
या करेक्ट करेक्ट।
ठीक है? समझ में आया गाइस? आर यू गेटिंग
प्लीज फोकस हियर। समझ में आया आपको?
बताइए
ओके
ठीक है ओके गुड
बहुत अच्छी बात है चलिए
सॉरी अब हम आते हैं कॉन्फ़िगरेशन डिपेंडेंट
वलेबिलिटीज़ अब कुछ वलेबिलिटीज़ होते हैं जो
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन डिपेंडेंट होते हैं।
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन डिपेंडेंट होता और आप लोग खुद
के नोट्स बनाते हैं कि नहीं बनाते हैं? यह
मुझे बताइए जरा। हां, एक इंपॉर्टेंट चीज
तो पूछना ही मैं भूल गया। आप लोग खुद के
नोट्स बनाते हैं कि नहीं बनाते हैं या
सिर्फ हमारे नोट्स पे डिपेंड करते हैं।
क्योंकि क्योंकि अगर आप हमारे नोट्स पे
सिर्फ डिपेंड करते हैं या जो मैं अभी आपको
नोट्स बता रहा हूं वो अगर उस पे डिपेंड
करते हैं तो ये नोट्स मैं कभी भी भेजना
बंद कर सकता हूं। याद रखिएगा। जरूरी नहीं
है कि मैं आपको हर नोट्स प्रोवाइड करता रह
जाऊंगा लास्ट तक। इट्स नॉटेंट। तो आपके
नोट्स ही आपके काम आएंगे। याद रखिएगा
जो चीजें बताई जा रही हैं उसके नोट्स
बनाने ही बनाने हैं। लाइव में अगर आप
सिर्फ समझ रहे हैं आप ये अप्रोच भी कर
सकते हैं कि लाइव में आप सिर्फ समझ रहे
हैं कांसेप्ट्स को गैब कर रहे हैं दिमाग
में फिट कर रहे हैं तो वापस से रिकॉर्डिंग
को वापस से देखिए और नोट्स बनाइए।
रिकॉर्डिंग देखिए। नोट्स बनाने के लिए
लाइव में आइए। कांसेप्ट को लाइव समझने के
लिए एक अलग जोश एक अलग लेवल से इन चीजों
को सीखने के लिए।
सर ऐसा पाप मत करो। अच्छा पाप है ये। आपको
सेल्फ कैपेबल बनाना पाप है तो ऐसी पाप
मंजूर है। अगर आपको सेल्फ कैपेबल बनाना
अगर पाप है तो पाप है भाई। ठीक है? पाप ही
चलेगा।
हां कुछ लोग मीडियम पे भी नोट्स डाल रहे
हैं। बहुत अच्छी बात है। Lindin पे डालते
हैं। दैट्स वेरी गुड। Google ड्राइव के
लिंक्स भेजते हैं। दैट्स गुड।
चलिए। अब कॉन्फ़िगरेशन डिपेंडेंट
वलेबिलिटीज़ में क्या-क्या आते हैं? इसमें
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन डिपेंडेंट वनेबिलिटीज में
आपके डीबग मोड मोड इनेबल्ड अगर है,
डिफॉल्ट क्रेडेंशियल्स हैं, एक्सेसिव
परमिशंस हैं। ठीक है? इस तरीके की चीज़। अब
डीबग मोड इनेबल्ड है तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है
कि कोई भी अटैकर जो है डीबग डीबगिंग का
यूज़ करके बहुत सारी चीजें क्रॉस वेरीफाई,
क्रॉस एग्जामिन कर सकता है। वो डीबगिंग इज़
अ फीचर। डीबगिंग क्या होता है? जिससे कि
आप यह पता लगाते हो। जैसे मान लो कोई एक
प्रॉब्लम आपके मोबाइल फोन में आता है।
किसी तरह का कोई इशू आता है। किसी भी तरह
की कोई भी प्रॉब्लम आती है। ओरिजिनेट होती
है आपके लैपटॉप में आपके कंप्यूटर आपके
कंप्यूटर में आपके मोबाइल में। तो तो हम
उस प्रॉब्लम को जब डीबगिंग करते हैं ना तो
हमें एग्जैक्ट रूट कॉज पता चल जाता है कि
एग्जैक्टली क्यों ये प्रॉब्लम है। तो उसका
यूज़ ना गलत मलिशियस पर्पस के लिए भी किया
जा सकता है। तो डिबगिंग मोड जनरली इनेबल
नहीं होना चाहिए। नहीं करना चाहिए।
डिफ़ॉल्ट क्रिटिसिस तो बिल्कुल यूज़ मत करो
और एक्सेसिव परमिशन फालतू का मत दो।
प्लीज डोंट स्पैम अलबिरूनी सर मैं मीडियम
पर नोट्स पब्लिश करता हूं और आपको कुल
एक्स पर मेंशन करते हैं। अच्छा वाओ ग्रेट
आई विल सी आई विल सी मैं देखूंगा। बहुत
अच्छी चीज है अगर आप ऐसा करते हैं।
अब एसोसिस डिटेक्शन में किस तरीके की
चीजें हैं? एडमिन पैनल एक्सपोज्ड का आएगा
आपका। डिफॉल्ट क्रेडेंशियल्स अनचेंज्ड का
है एंड सिस्टम टेकओवर का। ये एसोसिएट
डिटेक्शंस की आ गई आपकी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
डिपेंडेंट वलेबिलिटीज़ में। तो मतलब सिंपल
सा यही चीज़ है जो यहां पे वलेबिलिटीज़ है
उसी का है कि एडमिन पैनल एक्सपोज्ड आपको
हो सकता है। डिफ़ॉल्ट क्रेडेंशियल्स
अनचेंज्ड के कारण आपकी अलर्ट आ सकती है या
चीजें हो सकती हैं, दिक्कतें आ सकती हैं।
एंड सिस्टम आपका टेकओवर होगा। उसका भी
आपका जो है अलर्ट आ सकता है। ये चीजें
आपकी आ सकती हैं कॉन्फ़िगरेशन डिपेंडेंट
वलेबिलिटीज़ में। अब आते हैं ज़ीरो डे
वनेबिलिटीज़ को थोड़ा इन डेप्थ डिस्कस करते
हैं। अब ये सबसे बड़ी
चीज़ है। सबसे इंटरेस्टिंग चीज़ है ज़ीरो डे
वबिलिटी। इसकी नॉलेज होना बहुत जरूरी है।
बहुत जरूरी है।
देखो अ वनेबिलिटी व्हिच पैच डज़ नॉट
एकज़िस्ट येट एज इट इट्स अननोन टू द वेंडर
येट एंड आर यूज़्ड बाय मलशियस एक्टर्स लाइक
हैकर्स। यह होती है ज़ीरो लेवल।
सिंपल। एक ऐसी वलेबिलिटी जिसका पैच अभी तक
नहीं है। एंड ये अभी तक वेंडर यानी कि जिस
सॉफ्टवेयर में जिस प्रोग्राम में ये
वलेबिलिटी आई है उसके ओनर या उसके उस
प्रोग्राम के डेवलपर को या उसके टीम को ही
नहीं पता। उस कंपनी को ही नहीं पता कि
इसमें वोलेबिलिटी है। एंड इसका यूज़ हैकर्स
कर रहे हैं। दैट्स इट। ये होती है जीरो
डेवलबिलिटी। एसओसी डिटेक्शन में क्या
आएगी? एब्नॉर्मल प्रोसेससेस होंगे।
सस्िशियस नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक आपको देखने को
मिलेगा। मतलब अलर्ट्स जो भी हैं लेटरल
मूवमेंट एसओसी डिटेशंस में किस तरह की
चीजें आएंगी लेटरल मूवमेंट आएगी सस्िशियस
नेटवर्क ट्रैफिक आएगा एबनॉर्मल प्रोसेससेस
आएंगे एब्नॉर्मल प्रोसेससेस आपको दिख रहे
हैं बहुत खतरनाक है सस्िशियस नेटवर्क
ट्रैफिक जो आप एक्सपेक्ट नहीं कर रहे हैं
उस तरह की ट्रैफिक आपको देखने को मिल रहा
है लैटरल मूवमेंट मतलब एक डिवाइस से दूसरे
डिवाइस में कोई ट्रैवल कर रहा है कोई अट
हैकर एक नेटवर्क के अंदर में दैट इज़ कॉल्ड
लैटरल मूवमेंट अब यहां पे कुछ चीजें मैं
आपको समझाना चाहता हूं। वनेबिलिटी
का मतलब होता है वीकनेसेस जो एक्सिस्ट
करते हैं। एक्सप्लइट का मतलब होता है
वनेबिलिटी जिसको हम एक्सप्लइट करते हैं।
जिसको हम अब्यूज कर देते हैं। जिसको हम
यूज़ कर रहे हैं, अब्यूज कर रहे हैं। और
इंसिडेंट का मतलब होता है डैमेज और
कॉम्प्रोमाइज जो अकर होते हैं। जो डैमेजेस
और जो कॉम्प्रोमाइजज़ अकर होते हैं वो
इंसिडेंट होते हैं। तो इंसिडेंट
रेस्पॉन्डिंग का मतलब वनेबिलिटी या
एक्सप्लइट नहीं होता है। इंसिडेंट
रिस्पॉन्डिंग का मतलब होता है वनेबिलिटी
या एक्सप्लइट को वो फिक्स करना नहीं होता।
उसका मतलब होता है जो डैमेजेस और
कॉम्प्रोमाइजज़ हुए हैं उसको रिसोंड करना।
ये मेन डिफरेंसेस है जो आपको समझना चाहिए।
यस दैट्स व्हाई पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स आर
हायर्ड। बिल्कुल सही बात है। पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टर्स इसीलिए एक्सिस्ट करते हैं एसओसी
के अलावा भी।
अब यहां पे समझते हैं लाइफ साइकिल जीरो डे
वनेबिलिटी का। इसका लाइफ साइकिल क्या होता
है? मतलब ये किस तरीके से काम करता है?
जीरो डे वबिलिटी? हाउ इट वर्क्स? तो देखिए
सबसे पहले तो होता है क्या? अ न्यू
वनेबिलिटी इज़ डिस्कवर्ड। एक नई वनेबिलिटी
डिस्कवर की जाती है। उसके बाद क्या होता
है? अ मेथड टू एक्सप्लइट द वनेबिलिटी
डिस्कवर। एक मेथड डिस्कवर किया जाता है
जिससे कि उस वनेबिलिटी को एक्सप्लइट किया
जा सकता है। साइबर क्रिमिनल्स लेवरेज।
उसके बाद स्टेप क्या होता है? लेवरेज द
वनेबिलिटी टू कॉज डैमेज। अब जो साइबर
क्रिमिनल्स हैं, अटैकर्स हैं, ब्लैक
अटैकर्स हैं या हैकर्स हैं, उन वबिलिटीज
को यूज करके डैमेजेस कॉज करते हैं कंपनीज़
को जो भी कंपनी जिसको भी है वो करना
चाहें। वलेबिलिटी डिस्कवर्ड बाय द
सॉफ्टवेयर वेंडर्स। जब ये सब हो जाता है
तब सॉफ्टवेयर वेंडर्स जो ओरिजिनल वेंडर्स
हैं जिनके सॉफ्टवेयर में प्रोग्राम में ये
वलेबिलिटी है। वो वनेबिलिटीज जो हैं वो
वनेबिलिटीज़ को डिस्कवर करते हैं सॉफ्टवेयर
वेंडर्स। अब यहां पे प्रशांत श्रीवास्तव
इज़ सेइंग सर वन शाउट आउट टू द पीपीटी मेकर
वेल ऑर्गेनाइज्ड शाउट आउट दूं तो शाउट आउट
टू टू मिस्टर नितेश फाउंडर एंड डायरेक्टर
ऑफ डेफ्रॉनिक्स एंड होस्ट ऑफ दिस ट्रेनिंग
आपके लिए ये पीपीटी मैंने ही बनाई है भाई
पीपीटी मैं ही बनाता हूं। मैं पीपीटी किसी
और से नहीं बनवाता हूं। आई डोंट ट्रस्ट
एनीबॉडी टू क्रिएट कंटेंट और क्रिएट
पीपीटी एंड उसमें कुछ भी डाल दे और मैं जब
यहां पर खोलूं तो मुझे दिखे हां ये क्या
है और मैं अब मैं पागल बन जाऊं ये मैंने
काम नहीं करता ये मैं किसी भी अपने टीम
मेंबर से किसी भी उसके लिए मैं यह पीपीटी
वपीटी नहीं बनवाता जनरली मैं खुद ही बनाता
हूं। आई ओनली मेक मायसेल्फ। वह अलग बात है
कि टाइम की थोड़ी सी दिक्कत आती है मुझे।
बट आई मैनेज सम हाउ एंड क्रिएट पीपीटीस।
तो वो चाहे रात को 2:00 बजे तक बनानी पड़
जाए, 3:00 बजे तक बनानी पड़ जाए सुबह के।
वो मैं बना लेता हूं जब बनानी होती है। और
आपके लिए बनानी है तो मैं लेकर आ जाता
हूं। सिंपल पीपीटीस के मैं ऐसे भी आपको
बिना पीपीटी कभी बता सकता हूं। समझा सकता
हूं। बट आई डोंट प्रेफर दैट वे टू टीच अ
बिगिनर और अ जो न्यू कमर्स है इससे
विजुअलाइज होता है तो चीजों को तो ज्यादा
अच्छे से समझ में आती है राइट
हां तो मैं दूसरों पे ट्रस्ट नहीं कर सकता
भाई कि कुछ भी डाल दे आके इसमें तो ये
चौथा स्टेप है कि अब जो है वेंडर्स ने
डिटेक्ट किया पहले क्या किया वलेबिलिटी
डिस्कवर हुई दूसरे पे एक्सप्लइट का जो
मेथड है वो आ गया अब साइबर क्रिमिनल उसको
एक्सप्लइट को यूज़ करके मस्त एक्सप्लइट कर
रहे हैं। बैंड बजा रहे हैं सबकी। अब
वलेबिलिटी डिस्कवर हुई है भाई उस
सॉफ्टवेयर वेंडर से। उस कंपनी का उस कंपनी
के द्वारा की गई। जैसे Microsoft
एक्सप्लइट है तो Microsoft ने डिटेक्ट
किया। VMware या ब्रॉडकॉम है तो ब्रॉडकॉम
ने डिटेक्ट किया। इस तरीके से और तब जाके
बेचारे पैच रिलीज़ करते हैं लास्ट पांचवें
स्टेप पे। ये पैच रिलीज़ करते हैं। देन
रिलीज़ द पैच टू फिक्स द वबिलिटी। ये पूरी
लाइफ साइकिल है ज़ीरो डेवलबिलिटी का। अब
इसी लाइफ साइकिल को हम और डिटेल वे में
अगर हम थोड़ा सा समझे थोड़ा और डिटेल वे
में पढ़े तो मैं आपको वो डिटेल वे भी बता
देता हूं। सबसे पहला जो फर्स्ट चीज है
इसको मैं थोड़ा डिटेल में बता रहा हूं और
कुछ भी नहीं है। सेम चीजें हैं बट डिटेल
में पांचों चीजों को हम समझते हैं। अ
सॉफ्टवेयर प्रोग्राम विद एन इनहेरेंट
सिक्योरिटी वीकनेस और फ्लॉ इज रिलीज्ड।
मतलब कि एक ऐसा सॉफ्टवेयर जो डेवलपर बनाता
है। अब क्या है? डेवलपर भी बेचारा इंसान
है। क्या कर सकता है वो? अब उसको वो कोई
भाई तोप थोड़ी ना है कहीं का। वो भी तो एक
इंसान है। बेचारा कोड ही तो कर रहा है।
टाइप कर रहा है। उंगलियां चला रहा है।
कहीं गलती से चल गई कुछ और उंगलियां कहीं
और सिंटेक्स कहीं और कुछ और घुस गया। कुछ
लग गया। कुछ और नहीं लगाना था वहां लगा
दिया। तो बेचारे से गलती हो गई। तो अब उस
गलती के कारण एक अनइंटेंडेड
एक इनहेरेंट सिक्योरिटी वीकनेस जो है वो
रिलीज कर दी जाती है उस सॉफ्टवेयर के अंदर
में। दिस डिफेक्ट इज़ अननोन टू डेवलपर्स एट
द टाइम ऑफ़ लॉन्च। लॉन्च के समय जो है
डेवलपर्स को इसके बारे में कोई आईडिया
नहीं होता है। डेवलपर्स को कुछ ज्यादा पता
नहीं होता है। डेवलपर्स तो बेचारा मासूम
सा एक
एंटिटी होता है। एक मासूम इंसान एक मासूम
लोग लोग होते हैं डेवलपर्स। उन मासूम
लोगों को यह नहीं पता होता उस टाइम पे। अब
क्या होता है? एन अटैकर डिस्कवर्स द
वनेबिलिटी इन द सॉफ्टवेयर प्रोग्राम। अब
एक हैकर आता है और बोलता है कि डेवलपर
भैया हमने तो आपकी निकाल ली है यहां से
वनेबिलिटी का जुगाड़। तो उन्होंने एक
वबिलिटी उसमें उसकी वो वनेबिलिटी फाइंड कर
ली अटैकर्स ने। अब क्या करता है? द अटैकर
टेक्स एडवांटेज ऑफ़ द वनेबिलिटी एंड
रिलीजेस अ मैलवेयर इंटू द सॉफ्टवेयर थ्रू
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग टेक्निक्स और फिशिंग। अब
अटैकर ऐसा भी कर सकता है कि उसने इस
एडवांटेज लिया इस पर्टिकुलर वनेबिलिटी का।
अब वो एक एक्सप्लइट क्रिएट करके एक्सप्लइट
के थ्रू एक मैलवेयर को इंसर्ट कर देता है।
उस पर्टिकुलर सॉफ्टवेयर के अंदर में किसी
भी तरीके से मैलवेयर को इंसर्ट कर दिया।
याद रखिएगा सप्लाई चेन अटैक में ऐसा ही
कुछ होता है। सप्लाई चेन अटैक में कुछ इसी
तरीके से काम करती है। किसी भी तरह का
टेक्निक से उसने कर दिया अटैक। अंदर घुसा
दिया। द अटैकर यूसेस दिस ओपोरर्चुनिटी टू
स्टील डेटा फ्रॉम द इनफेक्टेड सिस्टम्स और
मे इंस्टॉल स्पाईवेयर और अ बैक डोर टू
इनेबल फ्यूचर अटैक्स। जैसे सप्लाई चेन
अटैक में होता है। अब अटैकर क्या कर सकता
है? इस पर्टिकुलर चीज़ का यूज़ करके उस
सिस्टम से डेटा चुरा सकता है या उस सिस्टम
के अंदर में बैक डोर इंस्टॉल कर देगा
जिससे कि वो बाद में भी उस सिस्टम को
एक्सेस कर सके और अभी तक डेवलपर या किसी
को पता ही नहीं है भाई।
कुछ पता ही नहीं है। अच्छा लगा ज्ञान सिंह
इफ यू आर एंजॉयंग।
ये होती है। लास्ट में है वंस द अटैक इज़
लॉन्च्ड द डेवलपर्स डिटेक्ट इट एंड क्रिएट
अ पैच टू मिटिगेट इट। अब जब ल्च एक बार
स्टार्ट हो जाता है, जब एक बार अटैक
स्टार्ट हो जाता है, तब डेवलपर को पता
चलता है ये तो बड़ा खतरनाक है यार। हमें
पता ही नहीं था। और फिर जो आज आपकी फिर जो
होती है क्या आपकी जो है अ पैच रिलीज कर
दी जाती है। दिस इज ऑल जीरो डे।
सर लॉन्च करने से पहले पेन टेस्ट क्यों
नहीं करते? होती है भाई। होती है। लॉन्च
करने से पहले भी टेस्टिंग होती है। लॉन्च
करने से पहले भी चीजें होती है। बट कई बार
वो डिटेक्ट नहीं होती है। कई बार अपनी इनह
हाउस पे टेस्टिंग टीम ही उसको डिटेक्ट
नहीं कर पाती है। तो फिर वो बाद में जो है
डिटेक्शन में किसी अटैकर के द्वारा किया
जाता है। तो ऐसा होता है। राइट?
एंजॉयंग दिस सेशन। थैंक यू रोहन। इफ यू आर
एंजॉयंग दैट्स ग्रेट।
आप आप एंजॉय कर रहे हैं तो हम भी एंजॉय कर
रहे हैं।
ठीक है? या नो यस डेवलपमेंट मोड पर
डेवलपमेंट लेवल पर या कंपनी के इंटरनल
पेंटेस्टिंग टीम के लेवल पर कई बार कई ऐसी
अवेलेबिलिटीज है जो डिटेक्ट नहीं होती है
जो बाद में डिटेक्ट होती है।
अच्छा वो छोड़ो
लीव बिहाइंड ऑल दिस। तुम्हें क्या लगता
है? Microsoft,
Google ये कंपनीज़ पेंटेस्टिंग टीम हायर
करके नहीं रखती होंगी। इनका तो एक एक
सेपरेट एक
मतलब एक्सक्लूसिव पेंटेस्टिंग टीम ये रखते
हैं अलग-अलग चीजों के लिए। फिर भी
Microsoft के एक्सप्लइट्स मतलब अ जीरो डेज
आ जाते हैं। सोचो इमेजिन करो ना। तो कुछ
चीजें होती हैं जो नहीं आती है उस टाइम
पे। राइट? राइट?
हम
या
ठीक है आप आइए लाइव में आइए। चलिए अब यहां
पे आते हैं मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस पे। अब ये तो
हमारी जो चीजें थी ये वनेबिलिटीज़ की बात
हो गई जो हमने अभी तक करी है। जिसमें हमने
वनेबिलिटीज़ में अगर हमने देखा तो हमने
क्या किया? वनेबिलिटीज़ में कवर किया।
सॉफ्टवेयर वनेबिलिटीज़, ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
वलेबिलिटीज़, नेटवर्क वलेबिलिटीज़,
ऑथेंटिकेशन एंड ऑथराइज़ेशन वलेबिलिटीज़,
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन डिपेंडेंट वनेबिलिटीज़ एंड
ज़ीरो डेबिलिटीज़। ये हमने पूरा कवर किया।
अब यहां पे आ जाते हैं कॉन्फ़िगरेशन या
सॉरी मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन वनेबिलिटी।
मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशन जो कॉमन मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशंस
होते हैं हम उस पे आ जाते हैं। व्हाट आर
दिस कॉमन मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशन? ठीक है? क्या
करना है बताओ? आगे पढ़ना है या यहीं पे
क्लास एंड करना है कि थक गए या आगे अभी
मैं कंटिन्यू करूं? मुझे बताओ। थोड़ी सी
चीजें और हैं। मतलब थोड़ी और हैं। मतलब
मुझे लगता है आधे घंटे और लगेंगे आपके।
बताइए आप ही से पूछ लेते हैं क्योंकि कई
लोग यहां पर बेचारे लीव करके जा चुके हैं।
पता नहीं क्यों यार समझ नहीं आता मुझे यार
इतनी अच्छी चीजें मिल रही हैं आपको।
व्हाट कैन आई से?
कंटिन्यू करूं।
ठीक है। हाफ एन आवर और अगर आप रहेंगे तभी
मैं कंटिन्यू करूंगा।
ठीक है। ठीक है। चलिए कंटिन्यू करते हैं।
ओके।
ठीक है। आज संडे है यार। पढ़ लो मजे से।
कॉमन मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस फॉर एसओसी। तो
मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशन क्या होता है? पहले हम
इसको समझते हैं। देखो मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशंस
मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशंस
इज़ नॉट अ बग इन द सॉफ्टवेयर बट अ मिस्टेक
इन हाउ द सिस्टम वाज़ सेट अप। मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन एक बग नहीं होता है। इट्स नॉट
अ बग। यह एक मिस्टेक होती है। यह गलती
होती है कि कैसे एक सिस्टम को सेटअप किया
जा रहा है। तो याद रखिएगा कि मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस
जो होती हैं उसको पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स जो
है ना पैच नहीं करते।
क्योंकि वह वनेबिलिटी या बग नहीं है। वह
एक मिस्टेक है। गलती है। सिस्टम को सेटअप
करने में गलती होती है। वह गलती है। तो
दोनों में आप डिफरेंस समझिएगा। वनेबिलिटी
एंड मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन में डिफरेंस है। आई
होप यू आर गेटिंग।
ऑफेन बाय द आईटी टीम। आईटी टीम की तरफ से
मोस्टली ये गलतियां हो जाती है। दीज़ एरर्स
हैपेंस फ्रीक्वेंटली यूजुअली टू मेक
थिंग्स सिंपलर। चीजों को सिंपल बनाने में
यह एरर आ जाती हैं। जैसे 1 1 का यूज कर
लिए इंस्टेड ऑफ टाइपिंग अ लॉन्ग पासवर्ड
ए्री टाइम। अब किसी कंपनी में कोई आईटी
टीम है। अब वो बार-बार सोच रही है कि अरे
इंटरनल चीजें पे काम कर रहे हैं। हम अपना
ऐसे कर रहे हैं। तो
पासवर्ड ऐसे क्यू डब्ल्यू ई आर टी वाई
क्वाटी रख लेते हैं। 1 2 3 4 5 पासवर्ड रख
देते हैं। 1 पासवर्ड रखते हैं। ऐसे
बार-बार ना चेंज नहीं करना पड़ेगा।
बार-बार याद नहीं करना पड़ेगा। मेमोराइज
नहीं करें। और यही पासवर्ड्स हर जगह पे
सेटअप कर देते हैं। अरे ठीक है चलेगा। ये
कौन इतना टेंशन ले? एडमिन 1 2 3 पासवर्ड
कर देते हैं। एडमिन 1 2 3 से तो कई लोग
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हुए हैं। कई सारे डिवाइसेस
ये चीजें होती हैं।
ये चीजें होती है। तो ये होती है
मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशंस। मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशंस का मतलब
है कि इट इज़ नॉट अ बग। ये कोई बग
यालेबिलिटी नहीं है सॉफ्टवेयर में। यह एक
गलती है जो सिस्टम को सेटअप करने में किया
जा सकता है। कोई सिस्टम सेटअप हो रहा है,
कोई एक इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर सेटअप हो रहा है,
सिस्टम सेटअप हो रहा है, नेटवर्क सिस्टम
सेटअप हो रहा है। उसमें गलतियां कर देते
हैं या किसी भी तरह की कोई गलती। मान लो
आप कॉन्फ़िगरेशन बेस्ड कोई मिस्टेक आप कर
रहे हैं। क्लाउड के अंदर कोई मिस्टेक कर
रहे हैं। पासवर्ड डालने में कोई मिस्टेक
कर रहे हैं। अब एक ही पासवर्ड हर जगह डाल
दे रहे हैं आप। एक ही आई अह पाथ सेम तरीके
की पाथ को आप फॉलो कर रहे हैं हर जगह पे।
नेटवर्क के नेटवर्क के अंदर में। यह सारी
चीजें एक ही तरह का फायर वाल रूल आप हर
जगह सेटअप कर दे रहे हैं हर तरह की सर्विज
के लिए। तो, यह एक मिस्टेक है। दिस आर द
मिस्टेक्स।
ठीक है?
रिपीट कर दिया भाई। आई थिंक गॉट इट। आपको
मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन का मतलब समझ में आया? सभी
लोग बताइए मुझे। एवरीवन प्लीज लेट मी नो।
डिड यू गेट द मीनिंग ऑफ़ मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन?
जल्दी बताइए।
चलिए अब इसमें हम सबसे पहले क्लाउड मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन को समझते हैं। क्लाउड मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन क्या होती है? पहले हम उसको
समझते हैं। व्हाट इज द क्लाउड मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन? देखो अब क्लाउड मिस
कॉकफ़िगरेशन मतलब कोई भी क्लाउड सर्विस यूज़
करें जैसे आपका AWS हो गया Azure हो गया
या GCP Google क्लाउड हो गई। ये सब कुछ
यूज़ करें तो उसमें किस तरीके से होती है
चीजें? पब्लिक S3 बकेट्स माने S3 बकेट जो
एक स्टोरेज बकेट होती है। अब ये चीजें
आपको स्टोरेज और यह सब चीजें बग बंटी की
क्लासेस अगर आप लेते हैं या ले रहे होंगे
या लेंगे तो आपको ये चीजें सब वहां पे भी
देखने को सीखने को मिलेगी। ये चीजें बहुत
आपको ईज़ली मिलेगा। फिलहाल के लिए मैं बता
देता हूं। S3 बकेट्स Amazon AWS का S3 जो
है एक सर्विस होता है स्टोरेज की जहां पे
आप डेटा को स्टोर कर सकते हैं। ठीक है? के
और उसको डेटाबेस से कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं।
तो ये जो स्टोरेज है इसको हम बकेट्स बोलते
हैं। अब वो जो बकेट्स हैं वो पब्लिक नहीं
होने चाहिए। नहीं तो पब्लिक होंगे ना तो
उसके यूआरएल से कोई भी आपके बकेट को
एक्सेस कर लेगा। उसमें जो डेटा स्टोर है
वो एक्सेस कर लेगा। तो अगर पब्लिक S3
बकेट्स हैं तो ये एक मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशन है।
ओपन Azure ब्लॉब स्टोरेज। उसी तरीके से
aur का ब्लॉब स्टोरेज होता है। अगर यह भी
ओपन है तो यहां से भी डेटा एक्सेस किया जा
सकता है। ओवरपरमिसिव आईएएम रोल्स मतलब
आईएम आइडेंटिटी एंड एक्सेस मैनेजमेंट जहां
से आपकी आइडेंटिटी और एक्सेस को मैनेज
किया जाता है। अगर उस में आपने बहुत
ज्यादा परमिशंस दे रखे हैं जो आपको
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है तो वो भी एक क्लाउड
मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन का ही पार्ट होता है।
एक्सपोज्ड एक्सेस की एक्सेस कीज़ को
एक्सपोज कर देना। जैसे एडब्ल्यूएस की कोई
एक्सेस की है जहां से आप एक्सेस की
सीक्रेट आईडी का यूज करके उस एडब्ल्यूएस
बकेट को एक्सेस कर सकते हैं। उसके अंदर
पड़ी हुई डेटा को एक्सेस कर सकते हैं। तो
वो भी एक क्लाउड मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन के अंदर
में आ जाता है। दैट इज़ आल्सो कॉल्ड क्लाउड
मिस कॉन्क़िगरेशन।
दैट्स द थिंग। लाइक ठोक दिया सबने क्या?
लाइक नहीं ठोका सबने। अरे ठोका यार। बहुत
लोगों ने ठोका है। क्या बात है? कमाल है।
अब एसओसी एग्जांपल में क्या है? S3 बकेट
पब्लिक हुआ। सेंसिटिव डेटा सर्च इंजन ने
इंडेक्स कर लिया और डेटा ब्रीच हो गई या
किसी अटैकर ने सेंसिटिव डेटा निकाल लिया
और डेटा ब्रीच हो गई। दैट्स इट। मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन हेल्प्स वनेबिलिटीज़ टू
एक्सप्लइट दे आर सपोर्ट सपोर्टिव एक्टर्स।
हां कह सकते हैं या यू कैन से कि
मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशंस जो है वो सपोर्टिव एक्टर
हो सकते हैं वलेबिलिटीज़ के लिए। मतलब इस
तरह के मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस वनेबिलिटीज़ को
जन्म दे सकते हैं। ये नहीं बोलूंगा देंगे
ही देंगे बट पॉसिबल है। यह है क्लाउड
मिसफ़िगरेशन।
अब देखिए नेटवर्क मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन।
नेटवर्क मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन में क्या-क्या
चीजें आती है। फायर वाल एक ऐसा फायर वाल
जो सारे ट्रैफिक रूल को अलऊ करता हो।
ट्रैफिक मतलब फायर वाल ट्रैफिक के जो
इनबाउंड आउटबाउंड जो कनेक्शन जो जो आपके
नेटवर्क के अंदर ट्रैफिक आ रही हो नेटवर्क
के बाहर आ रही है। उन रूल्स सभी रूल्स में
अलाउ अलाउ कर दिया हो। इंटरनल सर्विज
एक्सपोज एक्सटर्नली। इंटरनल कोई नेटवर्क
का सर्विस है उसको आप बाहर आपने बाहर में
एक्सपोज कर दिया है। नो नेटवर्क
सेगमेंटेशन नेटवर्क सेगमेंटेशन आपने नहीं
करा है। नेटवर्क सेगमेंटेशन का मतलब होता
है कि आपने एक नेटवर्क में सेम नेटवर्क
में सारे डिवाइसेस को डाल के रखा हुआ है।
अलग-अलग डिवाइसेस के लिए अलग-अलग सेगमेंट
नेटवर्क का नहीं बना के रखा है। तो उस केस
में अगर एक डिवाइस कॉम्प्रोमाइज होती है
तो लैटरल मूवमेंट शुरू हो जाता है अटैकर
का। एंड वहां पे फिर लैटरल मूवमेंट करते
हुए अटैकर जो है वो मल्टीपल डिवाइसेस को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लेता है।
दैट्स द मेन थिंग। तो ये है होती है
नेटवर्क मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन। अब इसमें कैसे
होता है? इंटरनल डेटाबेस का पोर्ट एक्सपोज
हो सकता है। कोई इंटरनल डेटाबेस है उसका
पोर्ट एक्सपोज हो जाएगा। हो सकता है उस
पोर्ट पे कोई वनेबिलिटी एक्सप्लइट हो के
एंड आपका पूरा डेटाबेस कंप्रोमाइज हो
जाएगा। इंटरनल एक्सटर्नल स्कैन फाइंड्स
इट। कोई भी एक्सटर्नल जो स्कैन है वो इसको
फाइंड कर सकता है और डेटाबेस को एक्सेस कर
सकता है। ये चीज़ हो सकती है। दिस इज़ कॉल्ड
नेटवर्क मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन। देन आती है आपकी
आइडेंटिटी मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन।
अब ये आइडेंटिटी मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशन का मतलब
होता है कि जैसे कि आपकी आइडेंटिटी से
रिलेटेड कोई मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशन। जैसे कि टू
फैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन या मल्टीफैक्ट
ऑथेंटिकेशन। एमएफए मल्टीफैक्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन
कहलाता है। टू फैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन जो ओटीपी
वगैरह आप यूज़ करते हैं। एक्सेसिव ग्रुप
मेंबरशिप। अब कोई एक ग्रुप में मल्टीपल
यूज़र्स हैं। अब आपने उस पूरे ग्रुप को
फालतू के परमिशंस दे दिए। फालतू के मतलब
एक्सेसिव उसके अ मेंबर्स बना दिए।
एक्सेसिव परमिशंस दे दिए। ये भी गलत है।
ये भी आइडेंटिटी मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन में आती
है कि नंबर ऑफ़ मोर नंबर ऑफ़ ग्रुप ऑफ पीपल
हैव गॉट एक्सेस परमिशंस। एंड फिर वो
ज्यादा चीजें कर पाएंगे जो नहीं करनी
चाहिए सबको। तो दैट इज़ आल्सो नॉट करेक्ट।
दैट इज़ आल्सो नॉट राइट। शेयरर्ड एडमिन
अकाउंट्स। एडमिन अकाउंट को भी शेयरर्ड बना
दिया। भाई ऐसा कौन करता है कि एडमिन
अकाउंट्स को शेयर कर रहा है। भाई जो एडमिन
अकाउंट है वो तो सोल सिक्योरिटी पैरामीटर
है आपका। एंड वो सिर्फ एडमिन के पास एक
बंदा जो एडमिन कंसोल को मैनेज कर रहा है।
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव राइट पे है। बस उसके पास
होना चाहिए। मल्टीपल लोगों के पास शेयरर्ड
नहीं होनी चाहिए। दिस इज द मेन थिंग।
हां, कर सकते हो। रिमोट जॉब कर सकते हो।
रिमोट जॉब यू कैन डू या
करेक्ट। अ एग्जांपल क्या है?
कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड यूजर होता है। देन यूजर
ऑलरेडी हैज़ एडमिन प्रिविलेज। नो एस्क्लेशन
नीडेड। ऐसा होता है कि एक कॉम्प्रोमाइज
यूजर ऐसा यूजर कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो चुका है
जिसके पास ऑलरेडी एडमिन प्रिविलेज है। अब
सोचो कोई प्रिविलेज एस्क्लेशन की जरूरत
नहीं है अटैकर के लिए। अटैकर के लिए काम
आसान हो जाएगा। एक छोटी सी नेटवर्क मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन हुई। एक ऐसे यूजर को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लिया गया जिसके पास
ऑलरेडी एडमिन रोल है। कुछ करना ही नहीं है
अटैकर को। अटैकर एकदम मस्त मजे में पूरी
एंजॉय करेगा एडमिन ऑथेंटिकेशन को।
ये थी हमारी नेटवर्क मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन। अब
आती है हमारी लास्ट एंड पॉइंट मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन। एंड पॉइंट का मतलब है जैसे
कि एंटीवायरस डिसेबल्ड होना। एंड पॉइंट का
मतलब है आपका डेस्कटॉप, आपका लैपटॉप, आपका
वर्चुअल डेस्कटॉप इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर। ये
सारे एंड पॉइंट्स कहलाते हैं। तो
एंटीवायरस डिसेबल होना, लोकल एडमिन एक्सेस
हो जाना, यूएसबी हर जगह अलऊ करके रखना,
ऑटो प्ले अलाउ करके रखना ये सब क्या है?
एंड पॉइंट मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन है। ये नहीं
होने चाहिए आपके में। जैसे एंटीवायर
डिसेबल्ड है अच्छी चीज नहीं है। फायरवल
डिसेबल्ड है नॉट अ गै गुड थिंग। लोकल
एडमिन एक्सेस आपने दे रखा है। लोकल मतलब
ऐसी लोकली यूज़र्स को एडमिन एक्सेस दे रखा
है। वो भी सही नहीं है। जैसे लोकल यूजर को
एडमिन एक्सेस नहीं देना चाहिए। जैसे आप
काली वगैरह में यूज़ करते हो तो देखते हो
कि लोकल एक एक नॉर्मल यूजर बनता है। एक
अनप्रिविलज्ड यूजर होता है और एक होती है
रूट यूजर। तो अनप्रिविलज यूजर को परमानेंट
अब एक्सेस नहीं देना चाहिए एडमिन का।
दैट्स नॉट अ राइट अप्रोच। दैट्स थिंग।
होगा क्या? एक मैलवेयर एग्जीक्यूट होगा।
कोई ईडीआर नहीं है क्योंकि एंटीवायरस
डिसेबल है। डीआर डिसेबल है। तो मलवेयर
एग्जीक्यूट हो गया। अब पर्सिस्टेंस
इस्टैब्लिश हो जाता है। पर्सिस्टेंस जो है
वो क्रिएट कर ली जाती है। जब-जब आपका
सिस्टम ऑन होगा। जबजब आपका सिस्टम रिबूट
होगा तब भी मैर एग्जीक्यूट होता रहेगा।
सिस्टम आपका कॉम्प्रोमाइज होता रहेगा।
दैट्स द थिंग। हां, ऑटो रन भी नहीं होना
चाहिए। अब एक चीज मैं यहां पे बोलना
चाहूंगा। मोस्ट ब्रीचेस डोंट हैपन बिकॉज़
ऑफ़ ज़ीरो डज़। याद रखिएगा ये चीज़। गोल्डन
वर्ड्स हैं। दे हैपन बिकॉज़ ऑफ़ मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस एंड अनपैच्ड वनेबिलिटीज़।
तो मोस्ट जो
डेटा ब्रीचेज हैं या ब्रीचेज हैं या
अटैक्स हैं वो जीरो डेज की वजह से नहीं
होते हैं। वो होते हैं मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस
की वजह से एंड अनपैच्ड वनेबिलिटीज़ की वजह
से जो पैच नहीं हुए जैसे जीरो डे वबिलिटीज़
या मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशंस की वजह से मोस्टली या
मैक्सिमम अटैक्स होते हैं। ये बात एकदम
याद रखिएगा।
इसमें एक और पॉइंट आप जोड़ सकते हैं कि
लेस अवेयरनेस ऑफ द एंप्लई। एंप्लई के लेस
अवेयरनेस से जिससे कि सोशल इंजीनियरिंग
टेक्निक्स एग्जीक्यूट होती है, फिशिंग
टेक्निक्स एग्जीक्यूट होती हैं और अटैक्स
होते हैं। ऐसा भी यह भी एक हो सकता है।
अवेयरनेस होना चाहिए। आईटी आईटी टीम को
अवेयरनेस होनी चाहिए। उनके लिए अवेयरनेस
सेशंस होने चाहिए। उनके लिए अपडेटेड सेशंस
कॉर्पोरेट ट्रेनिंग में दिए जाते हैं।
कॉर्पोरेट ट्रेनिंग के थ्रू ऐसी
ट्रेनिंग्स ही प्रोवाइड किए जाते हैं।
उनको अपडेट किया जाता है। उनको अपडेट रखा
जाता है। ये सारी चीज़ दैट्स द थिंग। ठीक
है?
सर रेड टीमिंग नॉलेज जरूरी है क्या इस
कोर्स के लिए? कोई जरूरत नहीं है। रेड
टीमिंग के लिए। रेड टीमिंग की नॉलेज की
अभी कोई जरूरत नहीं है। जो जरूरत होगी जो
जैसा होगा मैं बता दूंगा। अभी फिलहाल नॉट
रिक्वायर्ड। तो ये थी एंड पॉइंट मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस। अब यहां पे अब यहां पे मेजर
सिस्टम कैटेगरीज़ यूज्ड एज अटैक वेक्टर्स।
अब यहां पे देखते हैं मेजर सिस्टम
कैटेगरीज़ यूज्ड एज अटैक वेक्टर्स। इसको हम
समझते हैं।
कुछ ऐसे सिस्टम कैटेगरी जिनको अटैक
वेक्टर्स की तरह यूज़ किया जाता है। पहले
आपने देखा अटैक सिस्टम अटैक वेक्टर्स जो
देखा था ह्यूमन लेड ह्यूमन की ह्यूमन की
वजह से जो हुआ वबिलिटीज हो गई। ये सारी
चीजें हो जाती हैं। अब यहां पे हम देख रहे
हैं कि मेजर सिस्टम के कैटेगरीज कौन-कौन
से हैं जिनको अटैक वेक्टर्स की तरह यूज़
किया जा सकता है। तो सबसे पहले आती है एंड
पॉइंट। एंड पॉइंट का मतलब है यूज़र्स मशीन।
कौन-कौन सी चीजें होती हैं? एंड पॉइंट में
लैपटॉप्स हो गया। डेस्कटॉप हो गया,
वर्चुअल डेस्कटॉप इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर हो गई,
वीडीआई वर्क स्टेशंस हो गई। यह एंड
पॉइंट्स कहलाते हैं जो मेजर एंड पॉइंट्स
मतलब मेजर जो बेसिकली यूज़ किए जाते हैं
सिस्टम सिस्टम कैटेगरीज जिसमें अटैक
वेक्टर्स की तरह जो ज्यादातर यूज़ होते
हैं। मतलब ये अटैक वेक्टर्स हैं। इन पे
अटैक किया जा सकता है। इनका यूज़ करके जो
अटैकर हैकर है वो अटैक करते हैं। व्हाट इज़
एंड पॉइंट सिक्योरिटी? अगर आपको जानना है
कि एंड पॉइंट सिक्योरिटी क्या होती है? तो
देखो द पॉलिसीज प्रोसेससेस एंड टेक्नोलॉजी
कंट्रोल्स यूज्ड टू प्रोटेक्ट द
कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी इंटीग्रिटी एंड
अवेलेबिलिटी ऑफ एन एंड पॉइंट सिस्टम। इसको
हम एंड पॉइंट सिक्योरिटी बोलते हैं। ऐसी
पॉलिसी, ऐसी प्रोसेससेस, ऐसी टेक्नोलॉजी
टेक्नोलॉजी कंट्रोल्स यूज्ड टू प्रोटेक्ट
द कॉन्फिडेंस। ऐसी टेक्नोलॉजी, ऐसी
प्रोसेससेस, ऐसी पॉलिसी जिसका यूज किया
जाता है किसी भी एक एंड पॉइंट सिस्टम के
कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी को, इंटीग्रिटी को एंड
अवेलेबिलिटी को प्रोटेक्ट करने के लिए
उसको हम एंड पॉइंट सिक्योरिटी बोलते हैं।
मतलब सीआईए को प्रोटेक्ट करने के लिए
सीआईए ट्रायड जो है कॉन्फिडेंशियलिटी
इंटीग्रिटी एंड अवेलेबिलिटी इसको
प्रोटेक्ट करने के लिए जो पॉलिसी जो
प्रोसेस जो टेक्नोलॉजी यूज़ में ली जाती है
उस पर्टिकुलर एंड पॉइंट सिस्टम को
प्रोटेक्ट करने के लिए एंड पॉइंट सिस्टम
के सीआईए को प्रोटेक्ट करने के लिए उसको
हम एंड पॉइंट सिक्योरिटी बोलते हैं। अब
एंड पॉइंट सिस्टम्स कौन-कौन से हैं?
लैपटॉप्स हैं, डेस्कटॉप है, वर्क स्टेशन
है, वीडीआई है। इन सबको प्रोटेक्ट करने के
लिए जो भी पॉलिसी टेक्नोलॉजी और प्रोसेस
यूज़ किए जाते हैं इनकी सीआईए को सेफगार्ड
करने के लिए वो एंड पॉइंट सिक्योरिटी है।
करेक्ट।
समझ में आ गया? बहुत ईजी समझ में आ गया
होगा। अब एंड पॉइंट सिक्योरिटी में एंटी
मैलवेयर होते हैं। एंड पॉइंट सिक्योरिटी
कंट्रोल्स होते हैं। डेटा सिक्योरिटी होती
है। एप्लीकेशन सिक्योरिटी होती है। आईएम
आइडेंटिटी एंड एक्सेस मैनेजमेंट
सिक्योरिटी होता है। एक्सेप्टेबल यूज़
पॉलिसीज होती हैं। कॉन्फ़िगरेशन मैनेजमेंट
होती है। सिस्टम मॉनिटरिंग होती है। ये सब
एंड पॉइंट सिक्योरिटी में आपका होता है।
तो एंड पॉइंट्स में ये चीजें होती हैं।
अटैकर्स कैसे यूज़ करते हैं? फिशिंग ईमेल
से मलिश सेस अटैचमेंट्स भेजते हैं। एंड
पॉइंट सिक्योरिटी जब मैं एंड पॉइंट्स की
बात करता हूं। मैं एंड पॉइंट की बात कर
रहा हूं। तो इसमें एंड पॉइंट्स पहले क्या
होते हैं? ये मैंने बताया। अब अटैकर्स
कैसे यूज़ करते हैं? तो अटैकर्स इनका यूज़
करके फिशिंग ईमेल्स, मलिशियस अटैचमेंट्स
भेजते हैं। ड्राइव बाय डाउनलोड्स मतलब
मलिशस डाउनलोड्स वो करवाते हैं। आपको
इंसिस्ट करके किसी भी तरीके से किसी भी
अलग-अलग मेथड से आपको
डाउनलोड्स करवाएंगे।
USB बेस्ड मैलवेयर। USB के थ्रू मलवेयर
प्रोपगेट करवाएंगे। एक्सप्लॉयटिंग अनपैच
सॉफ्टवेयर। अनपैड सॉफ्टवेयर अगर आप यूज़ कर
रहे हैं तो उसको एक्सप्लइट करने की कोशिश
करेंगे। एंड व्हाई एंड पॉइंट्स आर डेंजरस?
बिकॉज़ यूज़र्स के पास एक्सेस होती है सारी
चीजों की। यूज़र्स थिंग्स चीजों को क्लिक
कर देता है और सबसे वीक सिक्योरिटी पॉइंट
आपका यूजर ही होता है। क्योंकि यूजर जो है
जो लैपटॉप चला रहा है, जो डेस्कटॉप ऑपरेट
कर रहा है, जो इस वर्चुअल डेस्कटॉप
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर को यूज़ कर रहा है, जो
वर्क स्टेशन को यूज़ कर रहा है, वही तो
सबसे ज्यादा खतरनाक वीकनेस है एक। सबसे
बड़ी वीकनेस तो यूजर खुद ही है एक एक पूरे
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के अंदर में। उसी को यह
एक्सप्लइट करने की कोशिश करते हैं एंड
पॉइंट एक्सप्लॉयटेशन में। अब यहां पे आते
हैं हमारी दूसरी अटैक वेक्टर जिसको यूज़
किया जाता है वो है सर्वर्स जिसमें कि
एप्लीकेशन, डेटाबेस, फाइल्स ये सब चीजें
आती है। अब इसमें वेब सर्वर आते हैं। वेब
सर्वर्स जो वेबसाइट्स या वेब वेब
एप्लीकेशनेशंस, ऐप सर्वर्स आ गई, डेटाबेस
सर्वर्स आ गई, फाइल सर्व आ गई। यह सारी
चीजें
ये सारी चीजें आती हैं इसमें। अब अटैकर्स
इसका कैसे यूज़ करते हैं? कैसे इसको अब्यूज
करते हैं? एक्सप्लइटिंग करते हैं इसको।
जैसे लॉग फोर जे का यूज़ करके एक्सप्लइट
किया गया था। एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन जैसी
वनेबिलिटीज़ को यूज़ करके एक्सप्लइट किया
जाता है। आरसी रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन
वलेबिलिटीज़ का यूज़ करके एक्सप्लइट किया
जाता है। वीक एडमिन क्रेडेंशियल्स का
ब्रूट फ़ोर्स उसको करके उसको अब्यूज किया
जाता है। एक्सप्लइट किया जाता है। और कोई
एक्सपोज सर्विज है उसको भी एक्सप्लइट करके
इसको अब्यूज किया जाता है। यह सारी चीजें
काफी मजा आ रहा है। चलिए अच्छी बात है।
सर डेवोप्स
ओके
ओके डेव सेक ऑफ्स एंड क्लाउड सिक्योरिटी
रोड मैप भी प्रोवाइड करिए प्लीज सर डेवलप
ओके देखते हैं कर देंगे अगर कोशिश करूंगा
अगर हो पाए। फिलहाल एसओसी पे ध्यान दीजिए
आप। एसओसी पे हम लेके चलेंगे फिलहाल। सर
फॉरेन कंट्रीज में जॉब के लिए कैसे अप्लाई
कर सकते हैं? एसओसी एनालिस्ट एल2 के लिए
आफ्टर हैविंग वन ईयर ऑफ़ एक्सपीरियंस।
Lindin के थ्रू आप कर सकते हैं। Lindin के
थ्रू दे आर रीचेबल।
व्हाई सी व्हाई सर्व्सर्स आर हाई वैल्यू?
सर्वर्स इतनी हाई वैल्यू क्यों होती है?
क्योंकि सर्वर्स पे ही सारे क्रिटिकल एप्स
चलते हैं। सर्वर्स पे ही डेटा स्टोर होते
हैं। सर्वर्स जो है इंटरनली ट्रस्टेड एक
एंटिटी माने जाते हैं। सर्वर्स को
ट्रस्टेड माना जाता है। क्योंकि सर्वर पे
सारा कुछ कॉन्फ़िगरेशन, सारा डेटा सब कुछ
होता है। तो सर्वर को कॉम्प्रोमाइज नहीं
किया जा रहा है। सर्वर में कॉम्प्रोमाइज
होगा तो फिर दिक्कत आएगी ना। तो अगर सर्वर
अगर सर्वर एज ए अटैक वेक्टर यूज़ कर रहा है
कोई अटैकर सर्वर पे इसका मतलब है सर्वर पे
अटैक कर रहा है। अगर देखो मैं यहां पे बात
कर रहा हूं ऐसे सिस्टम कैटेगरीज की जिसको
अटैक वेक्टर्स की तरह यूज़ किया जाता है।
जिसमें सबसे पहला है एंड पॉइंट जिसमें कि
लैपटॉप, डेस्कटॉप इन सबको यूज़ किया जा रहा
है अटैकर के द्वारा अटैक करने के लिए। देन
सर्वर्स को यूज़ किया जा रहा है अटैक करने
के लिए। सो दिस इज़ वेरी सेंसिटिव थिंग कि
सर्वर को ही अटैक कर लिया जा रहा है अटैकर
के द्वारा। तो सब कुछ कॉम्प्रोमाइज़ हो गया
ना? डेटा से लेके डेटाबसेस से लेके हर
पॉलिसी सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसी हर चीज
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो गई। सो इट्स अ वेरी
डेंजरस थिंग। वी हैव टू वी हैव टू काइंड
ऑफ
स्टॉप एज एसओसी। आपको स्टॉप करना पड़ेगा।
दैट्स द थिंग।
चलिए
अब आते हैं दूसरी जो आपकी अटैक वेक्टर है
वो है नेटवर्क डिवाइसेस। यह भी अटैक
वेक्टर की तरह यूज़ में लिए जाते हैं आपके
अटैकर के द्वारा। इस पे भी अटैक किया जाता
है जिसमें कि राउटर्स, फायरवॉल्स, वीपीएंस
यह सारी चीज़ आ जाती है। अब इसमें डिवाइसेस
में राउटर्स आ गए, फायरवॉल्स आ गए, वीपीएन
गेटवेज आ गए, लोड बैलेंस आ गए। अब अटैकर
क्या करते हैं? डिफ़ॉल्ट डिफ़ॉल्ट क्रेडेंस
चुराते हैं। वीpएन की वैलबिलिटीज़ को
एक्सप्लइट करते हैं। मिस कॉन्फ़िगरर्ड जो
फायरवॉल रूल्स हैं, उसको यूज़ करते हैं। ये
एंड फर्मवेयर को एक्सप्लइट करते हैं। ये
सारी चीजें करते हैं। अब आपको यहां पे
नहीं दिख रही होगी। तो मैं इसको छोटा कर
देता हूं।
जस्ट यहां पे स्मॉल कर देता हूं ताकि आपको
ये दिख जाए शायद। अब दिख जाएगी यहां पे।
आई थिंक इट विल बी विज़िबल नाउ। राइट?
हम
ठीक है? तो ये लिखा है मिस कॉन्फ़िगर्ड
फायरवॉल रूल्स एंड फॉर्म फर्मवेयर
एक्सप्लइट्स। ये चीजें अटैकर जो है अब्यूज
करते हैं इस पर्टिकुलर नेटवर्क डिवाइसेस
एज अ अटैक वेक्टर जब यूज़ करते हैं। ठीक
है? जब नेटवर्क डिवाइसेस एज अटैक वेक्टर
यूज़ करते हैं। तो इसमें होता क्या है?
प्रोसेस क्या है? पहले तो प्रोसेससेस क्या
है? मैं आपको वो भी बता देता हूं। पहले तो
वीपीए के अकाउंट को कॉम्प्रोमाइज किया
जाता है। जो भी कंपनी क्योंकि कंपनीज़
वीपीएंस यूज करती हैं फॉर सेफ्टी
सिक्योरिटी।
देन यूटिलाइजिंग
डी अ ये जो डीसी सिंक बेसिकली एक
कांसेप्ट है या यू कैन सी कि डीसी सिंक एक
सॉफ्टवेयर या एक एक पर्टिकुलर यूटिलिटी है
एंड सीक्रेट्स डंप टू हार्वेस्ट
क्रेडेंशियल्स मतलब कि डीसी सिंक जो एक या
आपका सीक्रेट डंप्स करके यूटिलिटीज़ आती
हैं आपकी उसका यूज़ किया जाता है
क्रेडेंशियल्स को हार्वेस्ट करने के लिए।
देन आपका आता है फाइल्स स्टेक्ड इन
डायरेक्टरीज़। मतलब कि ये डिफेंस इवेशन
होती है। जो भी आपका डिफेंस आपने लगा रखा
है वो उसको इवेट करने की कोशिश कर करते
हैं। सिंपल डिस्कवरी यूज़ ऑफ़ नेट ऐप डॉट
exc अ वेरिएंट ऑफ़ नेट स्कैन। इससे ये
डिस्कवरी बेसिकली करते हैं। देन प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन करते हैं। एंड प्रिविलेज को
एस्केलेट करते हैं। जैसे अलग-अलग सीवीज को
एक्सप्लइट करके यहां पे आपका नॉर्मल यूजर
को प्रिविलेज एस्केलेट करके एंड इसको
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव यूजर बनाया जाता है। फिर
लैटरल मूवमेंट होती है जिसमें कि आप एक
नेटवर्क डिवाइसेस से दूसरे नेटवर्क
डिवाइसेस में अटैकर घुसता है। एंड देन
एग्जीक्यूशन हो के पर्सिस्टेंस होती है
एंड कमांड एंड कंट्रोल सर्वर सीएनसी सर्वर
जो है सेटअप कर दिया। एक बैकडोर सेटअप कर
दिया जाता है। एग्जीक्यूट कर दिया जाता है
अपने अटैक को एंड एक पर्सिस्टेंट जो है
कनेक्शंस रख लिया जाता है जिससे कि बाद
में भी वह उस बैकडोर के थ्रू उस व उस
पर्टिकुलर सिस्टम पे अटैक कर सके नेट ये
पूरा इस तरीके से एक ट्रैप जो अटैकर है वो
पूरा क्रिएट करता है इस तरीके से अटैक
किया जाता है तो अगर इन अटैक वेक्टर्स में
नेटवर्क डिवाइसेस को यूज़ किया जा रहा है
तो ये बड़े लेवल पे अटैक हो सकता है राइट
हां हां कॉपी वाले नोट्स बनाओ भाई कॉपी
वाले नोट्स सबको बनाना कॉपी वाले नोट्स
सबको बनाना है। यह नोट्स मैं आपको दे तो
रहा हूं अभी बट कभी देना बंद कर दूं क्या
पता। ऐसा भी हो सकता है। तो आप मेरे को
मेरे को ब्लेम नहीं कर सकते क्योंकि मैं
बार-बार बोल रहा हूं कि आपके खुद के नोट्स
बने होने चाहिए। यू हैव टू क्रिएट योर ओन
नोट्स। कॉपी पे लिख के बनाओ। जैसे बनाना
है बनाओ बट लिखो।
एवरीथिंग।
सर मैंने सिक्स प्रोजेक्ट किए हैं एसओसी
एल वन के लिए। इतना इनफ है। हां, ठीक है,
इनफ है। और भी कर सकते हो कोई दिक्कत
नहीं। देन अटैक वेक्टर में क्लाउड सिस्टम
आते हैं जैसे एडब्ल्यूएस, एजीओ, जीसीपी
जिसमें कि क्लाउड इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर के ऊपर
अटैक होता है। कोई कंपनी क्लाउड
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर यूज़ कर रही है तो अटैकर
उसके क्लाउड इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर पे अटैक कर
सकती है। जैसे हमने पहले भी देखा था
पब्लिक S3 बकेट्स एक्सपोज एक्सेस की ओवर
परमिसिव आईएम रोल्स, मेटा डेटा सर्विस ये
सेम चीजें वही चीजें हैं जो मैंने पहले ही
आपको बताया हुआ है कि पब्लिक S3 बकेट को
मतलब एक्सेस कर लेना जो पब्लिकली नहीं
होना चाहिए। बेसिकली उसको एक्सेस कर लेना,
उस पे अटैक कर देना, एक्सेस की को एक्स
अटै कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लेना। ये सारी चीजें
क्लाउड आपके सिस्टम के अंदर में आता है।
जहां पे एज अ ये क्लाउड सिस्टम जो है एज
अटैक वेक्टर्स यूज़ में लिए जा रहे हैं।
दैट्स इट। तो ये अटैक वेक्टर्स में हमने
मेनली क्या-क्या अटैक वेक्टर्स पढ़े हैं?
एंड पॉइंट्स, सर्वर्स, नेटवर्क डिवाइसेस
एंड क्लाउड सिस्टम। ये हमने मेन
इंपॉर्टेंटली पढ़ लिया है। इसके अलावा और
भी चीजें दो-तीन चीजें और भी वेक्टर्स
होते हैं और भी वेक्टर्स अटैक वेक्टर्स
होते हैं। इतना कोई अभी फिलहाल
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। जब जैसे-जैसे
रिक्वायरमेंट होगा हम इसको समझेंगे। अब
यहां पे मैं आपको एक चीज लेके चलता हूं।
मैं आपको लेके चलता हूं एक लैब के ऊपर
में। सो लेट्स गो थ्रू द लैब।
मैं यहां पे एक लैब के ऊपर ले चल रहा हूं।
और यह क्वेश्चंस आपको सॉल्व करने हैं। यू
हैव टू सॉल्व द क्वेश्चंस। मैं नहीं
करूंगा। आपको बताना है।
चलिए तो हम यहां पर प्रैक्टिस वाले लैब पे
हैं। यहां पर क्या करना है? आप ध्यान
दीजिएगा। आपको इसका आंसर करना है। यह आपको
आंसर करना है। याद रखिएगा। रिमेंबर आवर
फ़्रेस एनालॉजी। ठीक है? हटाओ। अटैकर्स आर
ओपोरर्चुनिटीज़। दे विल ऑफेन सीक द ईजीएस्ट
पाथ। वेदर थ्रू अ फ्लाव इन द बिल्डिंग
इटसेल्फ और मैनपुलेटिंग समवन टू ओपन अ
डोर। अटैकर कभी भी इजी रास्ता चूज़ करते
हैं। ठीक है? अटैकर को कोई मतलब नहीं है।
ह्यूमन हैकिंग है या सिस्टम हैकिंग है। सब
एक ही उनको लगता है। उनको बस अपने काम से
मतलब है। ठीक है? अब यहां पे अनलाइक
ह्यूमंस यू कांट ट्रेन द सिस्टम टू स्पॉट
द अटैक। मतलब आप सिस्टम को ट्रेन नहीं कर
सकते कि हैकिंग को या अटैक को स्पॉट करो।
यू कैन ट्रेन योर आईटी डिपार्टमेंट्स टू
कॉन्फ़िगर द सिस्टम एंड एक्सप्लेन हाउ टू
अवॉयड सिंपल मिस्टेक्स। ठीक है? तो आप
अपने आईटी डिपार्टमेंट को ट्रेन कर सकते
हो ना कि सिस्टम्स को। तो आईटी
डिपार्टमेंट जो है उसी तरीके से काम करते
हैं। अब आईटी डिपार्टमेंट में अलग-अलग
चीजें होती हैं। क्या होती है? पैच
मैनेजमेंट होता है। अ प्रोसेस ऑफ ट्रैकिंग
एंड पैचिंग द वनरेबल सिस्टम्स। ये पैच
मैनेजमेंट का काम है। ट्रेनिंग होती है
आईटी का। आईटी के लिए ट्रेनिंग होती है
जिसमें कि रिस्क ऑफ मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस एंड
क्या-क्या चीजें हैं उसकी ट्रेनिंग
प्रोवाइड की जाती है। नेटवर्क प्रोटेक्शन
होता है। सिस्टम इज़ मच हार्डर टू ब्रीच इफ
एक्सेस टू इट्स रेस्ट्रिक्टेड टू द
ट्रस्टेड पीपल और IPपी एड्रेस। अब सिस्टम
को अटैक कर पाना या ब्रीच कर पाना बहुत टफ
हो जाता है जब सिस्टम में प्रॉपर
रेस्ट्रिकशंस लगे होते हैं नेटवर्क में
एंड सिर्फ ट्रस्टेड आईपी और पीपल को ही
अलाउ किया जाता है। ये भी चीज़ होती है। और
एंटीवायरस प्रोटेक्शन मतलब एंटीवायरस
प्रोटेक्शन है तो फिर उससे बढ़िया कुछ भी
नहीं है। अब यहां पे है फॉर दिस लैब
कंटिन्यू योर एसोसिए एनालिस्ट जर्नी एट
ट्राईकमी। ठीक है? दिस टाइम डिसाइड व्हाट
टू डू विद द सिस्टम्स एट रिस्क एंड चूज़ द
बेस्ट मेजर टू प्रोटेक्ट योर सिस्टम्स
एट द रेमडेशन प्लान टैब्स। ओपन द
सिक्योरिटी डैशबोर्ड बाय क्लिकिंग व्यू
साइड एंड कंप्लीट द टास्क एंड फ्लैग लेना
है। तो हमें करना क्या है कि इन्होंने एक
ये एक सिनेरियो देंगे। हमें वो पढ़ना है
और हमें उसका आंसर करना है बेस्ट पॉसिबल
आंसर कि हमें उस सिनेरियो में केस में
क्या करना चाहिए। अभी पता चल जाएगा कि आप
लोग आप लोग में से कौन कितना समझ रहा है।
और याद रखिएगा कहीं भी कोई
वो नहीं करेगा। अ कहीं भी कोई मतलब
चीटिंग नहीं करेगा। फुल स्क्रीन मैंने कर
लिया। अब आप लोग आंसर करेंगे। मैं यहां पे
आंसर टिक करूंगा। ठीक है? आप लोग आंसर
करेंगे। सभी लोग का आंसर करेंगे। ठीक है?
देखते हैं। सिस्टम एट ट्रिस्क पे चलते
हैं। पहला क्वेश्चन है यहां पे। अलर्ट्स
कंप्लीटेड का यहां पे क्वेश्चन है।
क्वेश्चन यहां पे है। एचक्यू मेल 02 एट
रिस्क एक्शन रिक्वायर्ड। कोई एक मेल
सर्विस है। इसमें एक्शन रिक्वायर्ड है।
क्या है? द पेनिट्रेशन
टीम रिपोर्टेड दैट आवर एक्सचेंज मेल सर्वर
इज़ अफेक्टेड बाय सीवीई। ये एक सीवी है।
उससे अफेक्टेड है। यानी कि एक जीरो डे से
अफेक्टेड है। दे मैनेज टू ब्रीच द सर्वर
थैंक्स टू द टू दैट सीवी एंड सेड एनीवन
कुड डू इट सिंस आवर सर्वर इज इंटरनेट
एक्सपोज्ड। ये बोल रहे हैं कि क्योंकि
हमारा सर्वर इंटरनेट एक्सपोज है तो कोई भी
सीवी का यूज करके हमारे ईमेल सर्वर को
हमारे कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर सकता है। ये
स्टेटमेंट है। व्हाट एक्शन शुड बी टेकन?
क्या एक्शन यहां पे लिया जाएगा? ये मुझे
बताइए। आप लोग आंसर कीजिए। मैं 2 मिनट में
आया। आप लोग आंसर कीजिए। कौन सा आंसर
होगा? फिर मैं देखूंगा कौन आंसर आपका सही
है।
ओके। सो आई होप कि आप सब ने आंसर कर दिया
है। लेट्स सी हाउ मेनी ऑफ यू हैव आंसर्ड
करेक्टली। अभी पता चल जाएगा भैया।
करेंटली जस्ट राइट नाउ अभी पता चलेगा।
ओके। सो ऑप्शन थ्री थ्री थ्री टू टू टू
थ्री अ टू एक कुछ एक बंदा वन बोल रहा है।
ओके तो थ्री है। मैक्सिमम थ्री आंसर है
एंड टू भी बहुत सारे लोगों का आंसर है।
थ्री भी मतलब थ्री भी बहुत लोग बोल रहे
हैं। टू भी बोल रहे हैं। अब चलिए देख लेते
हैं। सिंपल सा फंडा है। एक्शन रिक्वायर्ड
में है। क्या है ये?
आस्क यहां ऑप्शन पढ़ लेते हैं। आस्क आईटी
आईटी टीम टू इमीडिएटली चेंज पासवर्ड फॉर
ऑल ईमेल यूज़र्स। तो यह तो नहीं होगा।
ऑब्वियस सी बात है। ये पॉसिबल ही नहीं है।
इतना बड़े लेवल पे वो करना। हो सकता है
हजारों एंप्लई हो। आस्क आईटी टू अप्लाई अ
पैच एंड अपडेट द एक्सचेंज। ओके?
रेस्ट्रिक्ट एक्सेस टू द एचक्यू मेल ज़ीरो
टू सर्वर्स टू ओनली ऑफिस आईपीस। हो सकता
है ना कोई एंप्लई बाहर से भी एक्सेस कर
रहा हो। कोई कहीं से एक्सेस कर रहा हो। तो
ऐसे रेस्ट्रिक्ट अचानक कर देंगे तो ये एक
बड़ा इशू आ जाएगा। तो यहां पे सेकंड ऑप्शन
मुझे लगता है कि इट्स परफेक्ट आस्क आईटी
टू अप्लाई अ पैच एंड अपडेट एक्सचेंज। तो
मैं सेकंड ऑप्शन चूज़ करता हूं। एंड यहां
पे करेक्ट डिसीजन इन्होंने बताया कि यू
चूज़ टू एड्रेस द रूट कॉज पैच द वबिलिटी
नाउ हंट फॉर थ्रेट्स दैट स्लिप्ड इन बिफोर
यू अप्लाई द पैच। सो ऑप्शन टू इज़ द करेक्ट
आंसर।
ऑप्शन थ्री इज़ नॉट द करेक्ट आंसर। तो ये
ऑप्शन टू आपका करेक्ट है। ठीक है? सो अब
आते हैं नेक्स्ट अलर्ट पे। नेक्स्ट जो
अलर्ट आएगा उस पर आते हैं। उसको देखते हैं
क्या अलर्ट है। नेक्स्ट अलर्ट आया है आपके
एसओसी एसआईएम टूल्स के थ्रू। क्या अलर्ट
आया है? कॉर्पोरेट वेबसाइट एट रिस्क एक्शन
रिक्वायर्ड। क्या है डिस्क्रिप्शन में? द
थ्रेट एक्टर्स मैनेज टू ब्रूटf एन एडमिन
पैनल ऑफ आवर वर्डप्रेस वेबसाइट एंड
रिप्लेस द मेन पेज विथ मैलवेयर लिंक्स एंड
गैंबलिंग एड्स। तो यहां पे अटैकर ने क्या
किया? एक वर्डप्रेस वेबसाइट को ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स करके कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लिया एंड मेन
पेज को मैलवेयर लिंक्स एंड गैंबलिंग एड्स
में कन्वर्ट कर दिया। मतलब वहां पर डाल
दिया। अब हम क्या एक्शन लेंगे? तो यहां पर
तीन ऑप्शंस हैं। तीनों पढ़िए और इसका आंसर
बताइए। रिस्टोर द वेबसाइट फ्रॉम बैकअप्स
एंड क्लोज द अलर्ट। अपडेट ऑल वेबसाइट
कॉमोनेंट्स टू द लेटेस्ट वर्जन। चेंज द
एडमिंस पासवर्ड टू अ मोर सिक्योर वन।
बताइए क्या आंसर होगा?
बताइए क्या होगा?
सो यहां पर आंसर जो है थ्री आ रही है
मोस्टली सभी मैक्सिमम लोगों से। एंड दैट्स
व्हाट आई ऑलवेज वांट कि आप समझिए चीजों को
अगर आप समझ जाएंगे तो आप आंसर भी सही
करेंगे। तो हम आंसर थ्री को चूज़ करते हैं।
एंड दिस इज द करेक्ट आंसर कि क्योंकि यहां
पे ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक हो रहा है। ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स अटैड मतलब एडमिन क्रेडेंशियल्स को
डंप किया जा रहा है। ब्रूट फ़ोर्स किया जा
रहा है। तो हमें वहां पे पासवर्ड चेंज
करना है। हमें कोई एक स्ट्रांग पासवर्ड
रखना है ना। नहीं तो वो तो बार-बार ब्रूट
फ़ोर्स हो जाएगी। आप कितना भी कुछ भी अपडेट
कर लो ब्रूट फ़ोर्स हो जाएगी। तो यू
मिटिगेटेड द रूट कॉज़ अटैक कॉज़ ब्रीज्ड
क्रेडेंशियल्स। यू शुड नाउ रश टू द
रिस्टोर टू रिस्टोर द चेंजेस चेंज्ड पेजेस
एंड लुक फॉर द लेफ्ट बैक डोर्स। तो
बिल्कुल सही ऑप्शन थर्ड वाज़ द करेक्ट
आंसर। नेक्स्ट अलर्ट।
नेक्स्ट में आते हैं। अब यहां पे क्या है?
थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस एक्शन रिक्वायर्ड। आवर
नेबर कंपनी वाज़ हिट विथ रैंसमवेयर अटैक अ
वीक एगो। इनका एक नेबर कंपनी है हमारा
जिसको कि रैंसमवेयर अटैक ने हिट किया। दे
से इट स्टार्टेड फ्रॉम एन एक्सप्लइटेशन ऑफ
देयर ओल्ड सिसको फायर वाल एंड एडवाइस अस
नॉट टू रिपीट देयर मिस्टेक एंड ऑडिट आवर
सिसको डिवाइसेस। यह हुआ है। ठीक है? अब
यहां पे एक्शन क्या है? इंश्योर ऑल
कॉर्पोरेट फायरवल्स आर पैज्ड एंड डू नॉट
हैव सीवीस। रिप्लेस ऑल सिस्को डिवाइसेस
विद अल्टरनेटिव्स लाइक फर्टिगेट। डिसाइवल
ऑल फायरव्स अंटिल द थरो ऑडिट इज फिनिश्ड।
बताइए आंसर क्या है इसका?
एवरीवन आंसर क्या है?
हां
आंसर सभी लोग मैक्सिमम लोग वन बोल रहे
हैं। लगता है सभी को चीजें समझ में
धीरे-धीरे आ रही हैं। ये बहुत अच्छी बात
है। अच्छा लगा मुझे ये देख के। एंड आई एम
आई एम आई एम आई एम फीलिंग प्राउड कि आपको
समझ में आ रहा है। मतलब सभी को क्योंकि
मैं बहुत सारे बिगिनर्स हैं यहां पे। एंड
इफ यू आर आंसरिंग करेक्ट देन इट्स अ
प्राउड मोमेंट। आई होप कि आप इसी तरीके से
सीखें और इसी तरीके से समझ भी जाएं। सो
यहां पे पहला ऑप्शन हम टिक कर देते हैं।
लॉक कर देते हैं। इंश्योर ऑल
डिवाइसेस फायर वाल जो भी पैच्ड है। तो ये
हमने कर दिया। तो ये बिल्कुल सही डिसीजन
है। ये बिल्कुल सही डिसीजन है। आवर नेबर
कंपनी वाज़ हिट विद रैंसमवेयर अटैक एगो। ये
चीजें थी। तो यू फाउंड एन आउटडेटेड फायर
वाल इन द लंदन ऑफिस एंड अप्लाइड द लेटेस्ट
पैचेस बिफोर इट वाज़ टू लेट। तो एक फायर एक
आउटडेटेड फायरवॉल था। उसको हमने पैच कर
दिया। दैट्स इट। अब आते हैं
नेक्स्ट अलर्ट पे एलपीटी 01518 एट रिस्क
एक्शन रिक्वायर्ड ये आप क्वेश्चन है। यू
ऑब्ज़र्व एन अनयूजुअल स्पाइक ऑफ सिक्योरिटी
इवेंट्स कमिंग फ्रॉम द डिज़र्स लैपटॉप। एक
अनयुअल स्पाइक है डिज़र्स लैपटॉप की तरफ
से। अ ट्रस्टेड 3D डिज़ एप्लीकेशन सडनली
स्टार्ट्स रनिंग मलेशियस कमांड्स आफ्टर द
रीसेंट अपडेट। यू नीड टू क्विकली प्लान
योर नेक्स्ट स्टेप। यह नेक्स्ट स्टेप हम
प्लान करेंगे। समझ लीजिए आप लोग। एक आपने
अब्सॉर्ब किया अनयूजल स्पाइक फ्रॉम अ
सिक्योरिटी इवेंट्स कमिंग फ्रॉम डिज़र्स
लैपटॉप। डिजाइनर्स लैपटॉप से
एक ट्रस्टेड 3D डिज़ जो था एप्लीकेशन वो
सडनली क्या किया? एक मलेशियस सीएमडी कमांड
रन करने लगा। एक अपडेट आई थी उसके बाद से।
यू नीड टू क्विक। अब क्या है? इट इज़ एन ऐप
मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशन मेड बाय द डिज़र। इट इज़ अ
न्यू क्रिटिकल वलेबिलिटी इन द डिज़र ऐप। इट
इज अ सप्लाई चेन अटैक कमिंग फ्रॉम द
रीसेंट अपडेट्स। सो बताइए इसका ऑप्शन क्या
होगा?
एवरीवन आंसर इट। पहले आंसर कर दीजिए तब
मैं बताऊंगा। तब मैं मतलब मैं सेलेक्ट
करूंगा।
जो आंसर सबसे ज्यादा होगा मैं वही ऑप्शन
सेलेक्ट करूंगा और देखूंगा कि आप लोगों ने
सही किया है या नहीं।
सभी लोग आंसर करें थ्री। इट्स अ सप्लाई
चेन सप्लाई चेन अटैक कमिंग विद द रीसेंट
अपडेट्स।
तो यहां पे यहां पे एक चीज लिखी हुई है
आफ्टर द रीसेंट अपडेट। रीसेंट अपडेट के
बाद ही ये कमांड्स रन करना शुरू किए हैं।
तो पहला बात है मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन तो नहीं
हो सकती क्योंकि अपडेट के थ्रू आई है तो
इट्स नॉट मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन। दूसरी है
क्रिटिकल वनेबिलिटी इन द डिज़ ऐप। अब ये
क्रिटिकल वनेबिलिटी होगी तो अपडेट के थ्रू
कैसे आएगी?
ये भी बात हो सकती है ना? तो हम तीसरा
ऑप्शन को लॉक कर देते हैं। एंड दिस इज़ द
करेक्ट डिसीजन। क्योंकि यस व्हेन द
ट्रस्टेड ऐप सडनली स्टार्ट शोइंग मलिशियस
बिहेवियर आफ्टर एन अपडेट इट्स लाइकली अ
सप्लाई चेन अटैक। तो अगर कोई ट्रस्टेड ऐप
हो और अचानक से ऐसी दिक्कतें होने लगी तो
वो सप्लाई चेन अटैक कहलाता है। अब यहां पे
हमें एक मिल गया है अ
फ्लैग। इसको हमें जाना है। एंड यहां पे
प्यार से सबमिट करना है। चेक करना है।
करेक्ट आंसर [संगीत]
हमने इसको कर लिया। फाइनली वी सक्सेसफुली
डिड इट। दैट्स ग्रेट।
ओके ये हो गई। चलिए अब आते हैं रेमिटेशन
प्लान पे। रेमिटेशन प्लान पे आते हैं। अब
रेमिटेशन प्लान में आपको चूज़ करना है।
क्या है? सेलेक्ट फोर रेमिटेशन एकशंस
फ्रॉम द लेफ्ट। क्लिक ऑन द एकशंस टू ऐड
देम हियर। चार रेमडेशन प्लान आपको इसमें
चूज़ करने हैं जो सबसे अच्छे आपको प्रॉपर
लगते हैं। जो सबसे प्रॉपर लगते हैं। तो
देखिए पहला, दूसरा, तीसरा, चौथा, पांचवा,
छठा, सातवां। ये सात यहां पे दिए हैं।
इसमें से चार यहां पे आपको चूज़ करने हैं।
तो आपको बताइए कौन से सबसे बेटर ऑप्शंस
हैं जो आप सेलेक्ट कर सकते हैं। सभी लोग
यहां पे देखिएगा। पहला है सिक्योर पासवर्ड
पॉलिसी। जो अभी आपने सिस्टम एट रिस्क में
करा ना उसी को ध्यान में रखते हुए वो जो
अटैक्स हुए हैं या जो भी प्रॉब्लम्स आई
हैं उसको ध्यान में रखते हुए करना है।
पहला है
एंटीवायरस प्रोटेक्शन। दूसरा है शेयरर्ड
अकाउंट्स सिक्योरिटी ट्रेनिंग फॉर आईटी
पैच मैनेजमेंट पॉलिसी सिक्योर पासवर्ड
पॉलिसी अब सिक्योर सर्वर नेमिंग एंड
वेबसाइट रेस्ट्रिकशंस। तो इसमें से
कौन-कौन से डाले बताइए? चलिए सिक्यर्ड
पासवर्ड पॉलिसी समवन इज सेइंग सिक्यर्ड
पासवर्ड पॉलिसी तो मैं सिक्यर्ड पासवर्ड
पॉलिसी पे कर देता हूं इनफोर्स स्ट्रांग
ऑटो जनरेटेड पासवर्ड ये हमारी ब्रूट फ़ोर्स
को बचाएगा बिल्कुल तो हमने यहां पे ये डाल
दिया दूसरा हम क्या डालें
सिक्यर्ड पासवर्ड आप लोग लिख के बताइए
नंबर में मत बताइए ये नंबर चेंज हो जाएंगे
जब कभी-कभी हो जाता है तो आप लोग लिख के
बताइए सिक्यर्ड पासवर्ड पॉलिसी एक हमने
डाल दिया और क्या डालें हम
पैच मैनेज सिस्टम पैच बैच मैनेजर सिस्टम
में एक बंदे ने बोला है कि डिफाइन अ
क्लियर प्रोसेस ऑफ फॉर आइडेंटिफाई
टेस्टिंग एंड अपाइंग सॉफ्टवेयर पैचेस। ये
एक बंदे ने बोला है। चलो हम फिलहाल के लिए
इसको डाल देते हैं। मतलब इसको हम डाल देते
हैं। ठीक है? चलिए तीसरा कौन सा है?
तीसरा बताइए।
एंटीवायरस। ठीक है? एंटीवायरस बोल रहे हैं
यहां पे। एंटीवायरस प्रोटेक्शन।
ठीक है? एंटीवायरस प्रोटेक्शन डाल दिया
हमने और चौथा अब बताओ चौथा क्या अब इनमें
से बताओ शेयरर्ड सिक्योरिटी ट्रेनिंग
ऑब्सक्योर और वेबसाइट रेस्ट्रिक्शन एक ही
और डालनी है बस
सिक्योरिटी ट्रेनिंग चलिए सिक्योरिटी
ट्रेनिंग फॉर आईटी डाल दिया ठीक है कॉमन
मिस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन से बचने के लिए अब यहां
पे सिक्योरिटी ट्रेनिंग जो डाली है ये मिस
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन से बचने के लिए डाली है ठीक
है मेनली ली मिसकॉन्फिगरेशन। अब यहां पे
सबमिट करते हैं रिमडेशन प्लान। एंड यहां
पे जब हमने सबमिट किया तो यहां पे यू शेयर
द प्रिपयर्ड हार्ड हार्डनिंग प्लान विथ
योर कॉलीग्स एंड अदर डिपार्टमेंट्स एंड
सून रिसीव्ड द फॉलोइंग फीडबैक। तो यहां पे
पहला सिक्यर्ड पॉलिसी बिल्कुल सही। दूसरा
पैच मैनेजमेंट बिल्कुल सही। तीसरा
एंटीवायरस प्रोटेक्शन बिल्कुल सही। चौथा
सिक्योरिटी ट्रेनिंग फॉर आईटी। बिल्कुल
सही। तो हमने बिल्कुल सही ऑप्शंस डाले हैं
यहां पे। एंड मुझे नहीं आप सभी को
कांग्रेचुलेशंस फॉर चूजिंग द करेक्ट
आंसर्स। क्योंकि मैक्सिमम लोग जो जो बोल
रहे थे मैं वही चूज़ कर रहा था। दैट्स इट।
मजा आया? बहुत अच्छी। बहुत अच्छी चीज है।
बहुत अच्छी बात है। तालियां हो जाए। अ गुड
राउंड ऑफ अप्लॉज़ फॉर एवरीबॉडी हियर।
तालियां तालियां। कांग्रेचुलेशंस टू
एवरीबॉडी। चलिए बहुत अच्छी बात है। बहुत
अच्छा करा आप लोगों ने। कम से कम समझ में
आ रहा है तभी आप कर पा रहे हो। नहीं तो
नहीं हो पाता।
चलिए तो पहला हमने करा सिक्योर पासवर्ड
पॉलिसी तो इसका मतलब यहां पे इट्स
कन्वीनिएंट बट इट्स द ओनली वे टू
प्रोटेक्ट अगेंस्ट ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक।
बिल्कुल सही। ब्रूट फ़ोर्स अटैक हुआ था
हमारा। याद हुआ पैच मैनेजमेंट पॉलिसी एन
ऑर्गेनाइज्ड पाथ मैनेजमेंट इज़ अ बिग स्टेप
टुवर्ड्स रिड्यूसिंग द रिस्क ऑफ
एक्सप्लइटेशन। तो ये पैच मैनेजमेंट पॉलिसी
होनी चाहिए ताकि एक्सप्लॉयटेशन को बचाया
जा सके। एंटीवायरस प्रोटेक्शन सिंपल एंड
इफेक्टिव रिस्पांस टू कॉमन थ्रेट्स लाइक
डेटा स्टिलर्स और USB वर्म्स। तो ये भी
होनी चाहिए। बिल्कुल सही। सिक्योरिटी
ट्रेनिंग अ वेल इनफॉर्म्ड आईटी टीम इज़ लेस
लाइकली टू लीव द सिस्टम ऑन प्रोटेक्टेड।
तो ये भी आपकी होनी चाहिए। अब मैं यहां पे
अप्रूव कर देता हूं इन पॉलिसीज़ को और
फ्लैग ले लेता हूं। इसको कॉपी कर लेता
हूं। और यहां पे इस फ्लैग को आराम से
पेस्ट करके यहां पे चेक कर लेते हैं। एंड
दैट्स इट। ऑल इट्स सॉर्ट। खत्म कहानी यहां
पे हो गया। कंक्लूजन खत्म। ये खत्म। अब
इसको मैं
[संगीत]
यहां पे हटा देता हूं। इट्स नॉट
रिक्वायर्ड एनीमोर। राइट? दैट्स इट। सो
दैट्स इट फॉर दिस सेशन गाइस। एंड मजा आ
गया आज के सेशन में। अभी आ जाते हैं हमारे
पॉपअप को। इसको थोड़ा सा पॉप अप चाउ चैट को
पॉप अप कर लेते हैं यहां पे। तो आप मुझे
बताइए कि हाउ वाज़ द सेशन?
डीड यू लव द सेशन?
डीड यू लव द सेशन गाइस? मजा आया?
हम लास्ट में आपको समझ में भी आ गई चीजें।
तभी आपने सही आंसर कराया ऑलमोस्ट सबने।
ठीक है।
ऐसा सेशन कोई नहीं देगा भाई। ऐसा सेशन
नहीं देगा कोई ऐसे फ्री में। मैं आपको
बोलोगे तो एक नोटरी पे लिख के दे दूंगा एक
लीगल पेपर पे। दे दे तो आ जाना मेरे पास
कि सर इललीगल हो गया।
है ना? ओके।
सर और डिटेल में पढ़ाओ। आएंगे भाई और डिटेल
में। अभी तो बहुत कुछ बचा है। अभी तो
स्टार्ट ही है।
आप लोग भी कंटिन्यू आओगे तो मैं भी आऊंगा।
नहीं आओगे तो आई डोंट नो। फिर तो फिर तो
कुछ नहीं कर सकते। ठीक है? सो दैट्स ऑल
गाइस। अगेन आपको मैं एक बार याद दिला दूं
कि ये बग बंटी की प्लेलिस्ट है। आप इसको
देख सकते हैं पैरेलली। आपको बहुत हेल्प
करेगी। रेड टीमिंग के टॉपिक्स और
वनेबिलिटीज और इन सब पे काफी हेल्प करेगी।
दूसरी किसी भी लाइव में एसओसी के जाके मैं
बार-बार बोल रहा हूं कि सेकंड या फर्स्ट
या थर्ड वीडियो जो भी वीडियो है आप उसके
डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाइएगा। एक WhatsApp
ग्रुप का लिंक होगा और एक WhatsApp चैनल
का लिंक होगा। दोनों को ओपन करके दोनों को
ज्वाइन कर लीजिएगा। WhatsApp ग्रुप को भी
और WhatsApp चैनल को फॉलो कर लीजिएगा
क्योंकि यहीं पे आपको सारी अपडेट्स
जानकारियां सारी चीजें अपकमिंग
सर्टिफिकेशन जो हमारी आएगी वो सारी चीजें
की डिटेल्स आपको इसी पे मिलेगी। तो आप फिर
बाद में ऐसा ना हो नोट्स भी आपके यहीं पे
शेयर होते हैं। WhatsApp ग्रुप के अंदर
में मैं नोट्स आपके शेयर कर देता हूं। बाद
में ना हो कि आपको आप बोले कि सर हमें तो
मिला ही नहीं सर मुझे तो पता ही नहीं था
सर ऐसे ही सर वैसा तो ये चीजें आपको ना हो
इसलिए आप बार-बार ये चीजें मैं आपको बोल
रहा हूं। बार-बार बोल रहा हूं। ठीक है?
रही बात Instagram का पेज है हमारा। इसको
फॉलो जरूर कर लीजिएगा Instagram पे।
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़ आपको कंटेंट्स
मिल जाएंगे यहां पे। मजेदार इंटरेस्टिंग
कंटेंट्स। एंड ये वेबसाइट है। इसको
एक्सप्लोर करते रहिएगा। वेबसाइट इज़ गोइंग
टू चेंज। चेंज होने वाला है बहुत कुछ
इसमें। तो आपको चेंज वेबसाइट भी देखने को
मिल जाएगी और एकडमी पे जाएंगे तो हमारे
कोर्सर्सेस आपको मिल जाएंगे जो हमारे पेड
कोर्सेज हैं जो जब हम फ्री में इतनी चीज
देते हैं तो पेड में आप इमेजिन भी नहीं कर
सकते हाउ मच कंटेंट एंड हाउ मच चीजें वी
गिव तो आप इसको भी एक्सप्लोर करके अपनी
मर्जी है भाई आपकी मर्जी है आना है तो आ
जाइए पेड कोर्सेस ले सकते हैं दैट्स इट।
ठीक है? सो ये हमारा Twitter पेज है। सो
आज के इस सेशन के लिए बस इतना ही। बहुत
देर से सेशन चल रहा है। ये 2 घंटे से भी
ऑलमोस्ट ऊपर हो गया है। एंड आई होप कि आप
लाइव में आएंगे। एंड अगर आपको ये सेशंस
अच्छे लगते हैं तो मेरी बस एक यही
रिक्वेस्ट है कि आप इसको दोबारा नोट्स
बनाने के लिए दोबारा देखिए रिकॉर्डिंग को
जब ये सेशन हो जाए जब आपके पास टाइम हो
रिकॉर्डिंग को दोबारा देखिए और जब आपका
कंप्लीट हो जाए तो आप लिख दीजिए कंप्लीटेड
अ आप लिख दीजिए डे थ्री कंप्लीटेड एंड
अपना नेम लिख दीजिए एंड अपने दोस्तों के
बीच अपने कोलीग्स के बीच अपने ऐसे बंदों
के बीच जिनमें इस चीज को सीखने की ललक है
जो यह सीखना चाहते एक्चुअल लर्निंग लेना
चाहते हैं। एक जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग करना
चाहते हैं फ्री में। उनके साथ शेयर कीजिए
वीडियोस को। उन तक यह मैसेजेस इन वीडियोस
को पहुंचाइए। आप लोग में से बहुत लोग शेयर
कर रहे हैं। मुझे पता है। आगे भी करते
रहिएगा। एंड लाइव को जितने ज्यादा लोग
अटेंड करेंगे उतनी ज्यादा मोटिवेशन मुझे
मिलेगी। एंड उतनी ही ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग
वे में मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा। इस बात की मैं
आपको गारंटी देता हूं। तो ये सब आपके हाथ
में है। मैं आपको पहले ही बोल रहा हूं।
अगर लाइव की क्लासेस आने में देरी होने
लगे या अगर लेट फ्रीक्वेंसी कम हो जाए तो
समझ जाइएगा कि आप भी नहीं आ रहे हैं। आप
भी इंटरेस्ट शो नहीं कर रहे हैं। अगर आप
इंटरेस्ट शो करते रहेंगे, लाइव में आते
रहेंगे मेरे तरफ से आपको 200% मिलेगा। आप
100% दीजिए मैं 200% दूंगा। दैट्स ऑल। सो
आज के लिए बस इतना ही गाइस। जब जाना जब
लीव करके सेशन को तो लाइक को ठोकते हुए
चले जाना एक बार। एंड थैंक यू सो मच।
50000 सब्सक्राइबर भी होने वाले हैं
हमारे। 500 सब्सक्राइबर्स होने वाले हैं।
एंड 500 सब्सक्राइबर पे भी एक बड़ा आपको
जो है वो सरप्राइज़ मिलने वाला है सभी को।
उस पे एक अलग सरप्राइज़ मिलेगी। ठीक है?
तो थैंक यू वेरी मच। एंड हां एक चीज और
अगर आप सब्सक्राइब करके रखते हैं तो एक
चीज और कीजिएगा कि ये जो सब्सक्राइब बटन
है तो ये बेल आइकॉन प्रेस जरूर करके
रखिएगा ताकि आपको नोटिफिकेशन जो है वो सब
मिलती जाए आराम से। तो ये जरूर कर
लीजिएगा। बिना बेल आइकॉन के मत रखिएगा। ऑल
पे करके रखिएगा इसको। ठीक है? थैंक यू सो
मच गाइस। एंड सभी को गुड नाइट टाटा
बाय-बाय टेक केयर एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट
क्लास में बहुत जल्द एंड धीरे-धीरे अब
लेवल बढ़ाएंगे एंड चीजें आपको जो है और
मजेदार लगने लगेंगी। सो
गुड नाइट। बाय। यू आर वेलकम गाइस। थैंक यू
वेरी मच।
लव यू टू गाइस। लव यू टू। हां, टॉप फैंस
की लिस्ट दिखा दूं। टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट
नहीं दिखाई मैंने। तो टॉप फैंस की यहां पे
लिस्ट दिखा देता हूं।
एमआर जे यू टीटी तुषाल ऋषु फॉर स्कल अ
ललित मोहन राधिका शर्मा डिनोविज़न अशोक
सहनी पीतांबर अ ये टॉप फैंस पता है क्या
होते हैं ये बेसिकली जो कंटिन्यू रहते हैं
लाइव में ये इंटरेक्ट करने वाले सिर्फ
नहीं होते हैं जो कंटिन्यू लाइव में
मैक्सिमम टाइम रहते हैं वो टॉप फैंस की
कैटेगरी में आते हैं। याद रखिएगा यह चीज़
तो मुझे पता चल मुझे पता है कि कौन बीच
में जा रहा है कौन क्या कर रहा है रोहन
अधिकारी शिव पंडित लोगन अमन शेख स्टक्ड
ऑफिशियल इट्स
इट्स हलीमन सलमान ऑफकोड चलो भाई ऑफकोड तुम
भी आ गए कल्याण निशा चौधरी ओके बाकी ये
बहुत सारे नाम्स हैं गाइस एक्सट्रीमली
सॉरी मैं सबका नाम आई थिंक नहीं ले पाता
हूं यहां पे आफरीन फैंटम नामिका िका आकाश
इरफान ज्ञान सिंह अश्विन डेफक
अलबिरोनी ज्ञान ठीक है अश्विन बहुत सारे
लोग हैं राकेश ओके ग्रेट अवनीश तो दीज़ आर
द टॉप फैंस लिस्ट पीपल थैंक यू वेरी मच
फॉर बीइंग हियर एंड थैंक यू वेरी मच फॉर
अटेंडिंग द सेशंस तो मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट
क्लासेस में थैंक यू बाय बाय